including congressman john lewis marion
wright edelman and bob woodward
[Music]
next on children's books a look at the
life of muhammad ali with eric velasquez
illustrator of the new biography
champion
it chronicles ali's life from his
childhood in louisville kentucky through
his controversial boxing career
and finally his ongoing battle with
parkinson's disease
during the talk mr velazquez also
details the process of illustrating
books for young adults
it's an hour and fifteen minutes
good morning
my name is mr corsetti for those of you
that don't know me
and first i want to take the opportunity
to welcome you all
and this morning iona grammar school is
fortunate enough to have with us
mr eric velasquez
the illustrator of champion the story of
muhammad ali written by jim haskins
he's also the illustrator of such books
as piano man the sound that jazz makes
and grandma's records which was his
first book that he authored
so without further ado please give a
warm round of applause to mr eric
velasquez
thank you thank you and uh good morning
and it's nice to be here at the iona
grammar school
okay before i tell you about champion
i'd like to tell you a little about
myself
um both my parents come from the island
of puerto rico
and
that's where
um
and they settled in spanish harlem where
i was born
although my parents spoke english and
watched english-speaking television at
home we spoke spanish
and as a result i spoke spanish until
the age of five
in order to get me ready for school my
mother brought home
picture books which he would read to me
and soon i discovered that you could
sometimes look at the pictures and tell
what the story was by just looking at at
the images
this was like magic to me and my
fascination with illustration began at
that point
soon i began creating my own uh
picture books i would draw my own little
stories based on the books
um
then at about the age of 10 or so we
moved to harlem which was about five
blocks away from spanish harlem but it's
a world apart
so
around that time as i um i discovered
comic books now as i mentioned
uh earlier
i i did start speaking english at a late
age so
as a result my reading levels were
always low
so
as i continue to read comic books
mom
like one summer in particular
my reading levels jumped two grades
so when i took the
reading comprehension test in school
the teachers thought that i might have
been cheating so they gave me the test a
second time
and of course i scored higher the second
time around
as a res uh as a result comic books
became a big part of my life i began
reading them a lot and i started to draw
my own based on drawing draw my own
stories based on my friends and
movies that my father would take me to
i just was you know having a ball at
that point
up until the time i was a senior in high
school i wanted to be a comic book
artist
but
when i was a senior that's when i was
introduced to oil painting at the high
school of art design by two wonderful
teachers
max ginsberg and erwin irwin greenberg
i then attended college at the
school of visual arts where i continued
to develop my painting technique
i began my career as an illustrator
right after receiving my bfa from the
school of visual arts
and for the first 12 years of my career
i concentrated mostly on doing book
covers and chapter books
then i got a chance to illustrate my
first picture book the piano man
for walker and company
the experience of creating the images
for the piano man reminded me
of my childhood when i would create my
own comic books
i loved it
so around after after completing my
fourth picture book of grandma's records
which i wrote and is based on my summers
with my grandmother in spanish harlem
walker and company asked me if i would
be interested in illustrating champion
the story of muhammad ali
i immediately became excited at the idea
of illustrating the life of a real live
hero
once i heard that the text was being
written by jim haskins i jumped to say
yes
at the time my editors emily easton and
tim travolini
were were not aware
that i had always admired muhammad ali
his razzle dazzle style of boxing
was magical to me
but however what impressed me most about
his career was that at the height
he was the heavyweight champion of the
world
and had given up his title because of
his beliefs in opposition to the draft
to the war in vietnam
ali would be willing to go to jail
rather than compromise his belief
as i began to work on this project
one of my biggest challenges that i
faced was that because muhammad ali's
career had been so documented so well
known by so many fans especially fans
like my father
and guys like my father are very
unforgiving if the details are not
correct when they read something
particularly about things that they know
it became essential that every detail
in ali's life and fighting career be
authentic
my dad has always has always been a
boxing fan so from an early age i was
familiar with most boxers including
muhammad ali and although i'm a little
too young to remember the first
cassius clay versus
sunny liston fight
i remember going to my uh elementary
school library
to find pictures of of the fight that my
dad called one of the greatest fights he
had ever seen in his life
i remember finding the book with the
photos in it and seeing the photos of
ali proclaiming himself the king of the
world after he um
after he beat sunny liston
and the photos seemed frightening and
chaotic
but i couldn't stop looking at them i
was captivated
more than 30 years later
i would be looking at the very same
photos as part of my research for this
project
i did more research for this book than
any other i borrowed photos from the new
york public library picture collection
i purchased six books on muhammad ali
prior to starting the project
i read the book king of the world by
david remnick which my editor tim
travolini sent me
along with a video called fighter of the
century
i also watched the film the greatest
starring muhammad ali the fox film ali
an american hero not to mention the
documentaries
when we were kings ali versus fraser
in addition to the
hours of fight footage that i taped off
at espn that i ran continuously in my
studio while working on this project
uh reference is something you can never
have too much of when you're working on
these projects
oh and incidentally the will smith movie
ali was still in production while i was
working on this so i didn't have the
opportunity to see that
so um before we go any further now i
think at this point i'd like to show you
how everything gets started
this is the original manuscript that i
received from tim my editor
which this is how everything starts
illustrators receive the manuscript and
as you can see is just words on the page
and it's our responsibility to put the
pictures to the words
so after reading the manuscript a couple
of times
i start making little thumbnail sketches
similar to these here
makeup i make hundreds of sketches like
this
which
kind of map the way for me later on as i
start developing the story visually
from that point
i take my favorite thumbnail sketches
and i create
this which is called a book dummy now in
the book dummy what i do is
i take the manuscript i cut it up
sometimes i blow up the words to suit my
needs
and i
paste them down and i
draw out what you know the images the
way i i
want them to be presented in the final
and
sometimes there it changes from this
point to the finish
but sometimes they're pretty faithful
as you can see by just comparing to the
boards
but this is probably the most fun for me
because it's just like when i used to do
my comic books at home and uh any one of
you that are interested in making your
own books at home is very simple to do
you just take paper and you fold it
paste it together
take your words you cut it out paste it
down
and you're telling a story and
this is my dummy book as you can see
there's
the prayer scene as you'll see later in
my slide presentation
uh how close this is from like the
initial
um idea to the finish
and then there were other times where
the ideas just didn't work like for
instance
there's
this scene
which my editor felt was not appropriate
for this
project
so
it was changed and actually when i
changed it it was a better um image so
my header was right
okay so after the dummy is done
i um
i draw the the pieces up on a large
sheet of paper and prior to painting i
do these
color sketches
and the purpose of the color sketch
is to make sure that the colors all work
well together
and to avoid any surprises later and it
also cuts down on time
but the color sketches also fun to do
that's the color sketch for the cover
which you see there
done on tracing paper
there's a color sketch for every page in
the book
so um
[Music]
we'll turn now to the slides
okay before i get started i draw out
everything on a large sheet of paper
like i mentioned and it looks something
like this this is the cover before i
started to paint on it um
i draw it out on pencil
in pencil on um
watercolor paper a heavyweight
watercolor paper
uh that's a picture of of me working in
my studio that my wife took just to give
you guys an idea you know what my studio
looks like and what i look like while
i'm working that's my wall stick the
image that's on the um
on the easel is from my book grandma's
records uh that i did prior to doing uh
the champion book
that's my palette um that draw contains
i don't know
hundreds of tubes of paint
and i lay them out in no particular
order in my on my palette but by mixing
the colors together i can create any
color that i want
and you can also see my brushes that's
just a portion of the brushes i own
hundreds and hundreds of brushes but um
that's my palette
okay
uh this is um the image for the
end papers and this is what it looked
like before i painted it as well
okay
and this is what the finish looked like
the end papers
for the end papers i wanted something
that just represented
maybe an old boxing gym maybe the same
gym where muhammad ali used to
practice before his big fight with sunny
liston for the championship of the world
so i i wanted the poster
to kind of echo the idea of the fight
that's coming that's coming in the book
as you read the book and the gloves you
know maybe represent
um you know the old pair of gloves
the same gloves that muhammad ali used
to fight sunny listen actually those are
the
um i used photos of the fight so that's
the color of the gloves that he did
fight um
sonny liston with okay
okay that's the title page of the book
um and now for here
i had to do
as part of my research uh the trunks
that uh ali used when he was still
called cassius clay when he fought sunny
liston where those trunks right there
with the black band and the
the red stripe down the side
i had to look through tons of reference
to find the color references back then
most of the photographs were in black
and white
okay this is the first image of the book
where ali is traveling in a plane
and he's looking out and realizes that
he's probably the most famous man in the
world at this point
so um
i always like the images of like planes
as they soar by and it just seemed
you know appropriate that uh
you know ali is riding in this plane and
he's looking out at the whole world
realizing that you know he is at this
point the most famous man in the world
um this is one of the first images in
the book where you see his mother and
father um
this there's no existing photo like this
so what i had to do is i had to find
photos of muhammad ali's mother and
father and his brother
rachman or at this time
rudy
and
i put it together by just using the
different pieces of reference um like a
family portrait of the four
and then for the image down at the at
the bottom
i had to find a model to be um muhammad
ali at about the age of 12 or so
so
uh my nephew andy who looked a little
like muhammad ali seemed to be like the
perfect model
uh
this is once again this is um near the
beginning of the story where
uh ali is um he used to race the bus to
school
uh
and just showing the people on the
street the bus the buses in louis uh old
louisville um
i use myself as one of the models for
the people on the street and i think i
have my wife next to me i try to always
make a cameo appearance in all my books
and this is it for me in this book um
okay
uh this is uh ali as a young very young
boxer
when he's introduced to boxing by a
a policeman that ran the pal p-a-l
athletic league
you'll learn more of this as as we read
the story later but um
i wanted to focus on my uh nephew andy
who i gave him a pair of um boxing
gloves and asked him to pose his
muhammad ali first of all i was
surprised that he even knew who muhammad
ali was and once he put on the boxing
gloves he um
he became ali he started the trash
talking and he i was so blown away by
the fact that he understood who ali was
and that he was able to step into the
character um over the years i've used
family members many times as models and
i'm always so surprised and touched by
the fact that they always are able to
step up to the plate and and deliver and
you know andy
just you know he he knocked the ball out
of the park for me
um down below we have ali as he's
getting a little older and he's training
now for the olympics
uh this is the olympic page is i call it
with the medal i had a
research
the metal
the color for the trunks and the and the
tank top i had to do
a lot of reference for that
once again because a lot of the
reference materials in black and white i
had to find everything in all the color
photos for uh
you know to get the colors just right
um and that's when he returns home uh
his mom and his dad and his brother um
are waiting for him awaiting him rather
uh this is when uh
ali or at this point still cashes clay
signs with the phoenix group uh the uh
group of investors louisville investors
that um
that
support his career early on
and i also found a photo of his tour bus
which i always found very interesting
because of all the colors there so i i
put that in there as well
and uh
this
is the first
fight with sunny liston now this was an
opportunity for me to really uh combine
my love of comic books with the picture
books that i'm doing uh this was a lot
of fun for me i love the paneling and
this is like
based on the photos that i did see
when i was um about
eight years old or so um in the
elementary school library of him
fighting sonny liston and then
the chaotic scene after the fight
um that you know had me mesmerized as a
child and i really wanted to pay tribute
to that um
you know that that whole moment for me
so
you know i i put together this
composition
okay this is when he uh joins the nation
of islam
and although in the text uh jim haskins
doesn't mention
malcolm x much
i
decided to put him in
as part of the narrative and sometimes
illustrators have to
you know put in things that the the
writer might leave out but
you know in in the long run it all kind
of works well together but uh you know
you have to tell the story sort of
alongside the author
um and this is like one of the examples
uh
where i had to do that
okay this is the prayer scene um
probably my favorite in the book
and simply it's just a quiet scene and
it's just a man
in prayer
uh prior to the fight and
what what attracted me to putting this
image together was that there's a
dichotomy here because you know fighting
is such a brutal and violent sport and
yet prayer is such a quiet
um thing
it's just i was just attracted to the
image of just this quiet before the
storm
ah okay
okay
uh this is during the time where um ali
was speaking out against the war in
vietnam and um
which ultimately ultimately led him to
uh to be
stripped of his title
and once again i put in howard cosell
which you see in the ali movie more
prominently but once again in our story
he's not really mentioned so i put him
in
and the book he's holding up the book
that ali is holding up message to the
black man when i was growing up in
harlem um a lot of the um
black muslims used to walk around with
this book and hold it up and and sell it
just
so
once i saw the book in my in my
reference i knew i had to put it in
because it was a book that you would see
all over the place you know as the uh
the black muslims at the time were
always carrying it and selling it
uh this is the image of ali as he's gone
to um
to africa
uh
my idea in this image unlike the others
wasn't so much to to be completely
uh
realistic i i wanted an image that
seemed more like a place in ali's mind
that he went to you know to find peace
and calm within his religion so um
you know i put the composition together
kind of based on on that idea that um
it's
it's just a place he might go in his
mind so as you can see that's why it's
composed that way with so much white
space
okay this is the comeback
when he comes back to boxing
after being stripped of his title
and i just wanted something dynamic and
that that really said you know i'm back
and i'm you know better than ever
so uh
the fight scenes are put together from
um actual
uh photographs that i um found
i altered them somehow uh somewhat i i
started being attracted to the idea of
light um
you know
when um you see boxing it's you know you
see all the flashlights the flashes of
the flash bulbs going on going off all
the time and i wanted to put that in as
part of the images it's something like
my dad told me um that you know in
boxing
sometimes when you're there live you
can't really see what's going on there's
so much chaos and the lights are
flashing all over the place sometimes
you're not even sure of what you may
have seen
so i try to incorporate some of that
into these images where you see the
flashes
uh going off and another thing is that i
separated all the boxing scenes from the
you know ali's life scenes by bordering
all the boxing scenes with like black
borders to separate the two worlds of of
this man you know the boxing of the ali
the boxer and ali the man
okay
okay this is uh after he defeats george
foreman for the heavyweight champion of
the championship of the world where he
regains his championship
okay
uh this is what i call the rope-a-dope
piece where he's
he begins his down downhill spiral and
that's uh larry holmes who
you know begins to pick ali apart as you
can see they're fighting he's you know
taking a beating
leon spinks also uh
gave ali quite a a pounding
um and those are his corner men uh
bondini brown
and angelo dundee
telling him probably that it might be
time for him to retire and uh
at the end there you see
probably ali contemplating that this is
perhaps the end of his career
and this is the last scene and a very
special one for me because
um
ali is holding the torch and i remember
seeing this on television and being
really moved by it because at this point
um ali as we know is
stricken with the parkinson's
parkinson's syndrome
and uh you know he shakes somewhat but
um
he was able to hold the torch there for
like
a moment
and for me
it symbolized that this is a man who
lived so much of his life in the
spotlight and the light always was being
shown on him
and here he's kind of shining light
for us and he's sort of passing the
torch you know passing the light on to
us and
you know in a symbolic way so you know i
i really
um you know felt really that this is a
special moment in time in ali's career
and uh over here also is um
an image of his wife lonnie and uh
their son that he that they um
adopted uh
his name
tim is not gonna help me okay
uh
and now
uh
my editor tim is gonna read from the
book
champion
the muhammad ali story
uh
you'll have to forgive me
in the book uh that we we've inserted a
few of ollie's own words and
and there's no way i'll i'll do justice
to that but
i'll do my best
muhammad ali was riding in an airplane
one time
although he didn't like flying he
realized it gave him a special view of
the world
he looked out the window and down to the
earth below him
i could hitchhike around the world he
thought no matter where he was someone
would know him
someone would feed him someone would
give him a place to sleep
he was probably the most famous person
alive
he was the heavyweight boxing champion
of the world
some said he was the greatest boxer in
history
everyone said he was the fastest he was
more than that
he was a new kind of boxer
he lived a clean life and had never been
in jail he was deeply religious
he did not like to hurt anybody he had
helped change the image of professional
boxing from a brutal pastime to a widely
popular sport
had also shown the world that he could
be true to himself and his beliefs
and still be a winner
muhammad ali was born on january 17
1942 in louisville kentucky
he was named cassius marcellus clay jr
after his father
he was also named after 19th century
white plantation owner who had freed all
his slaves and worked to end slavery
cassius jr's great grandfather had grown
up on that first cassius clay's land in
kentucky
his father was a sign painter who loved
to talk and make jokes cassius began to
talk at a young age and also liked to
make jokes not only did he tell jokes he
was a practical joker
cassius mother odessa clay earned money
for food by cooking and cleaning for
white people
she was very religious
she read the bible every day and took
cassius and his brother rudy to church
every sunday
cassius grew up in a time when blacks
were forced to stay apart from whites
he and rudy had to go to a school for
blacks
like most other blacks in louisville
then the clays were quite poor
there was no school bus for black kids
and the clays didn't have enough money
to pay bus fare for both boys
so they usually had to walk to and from
school
young cassius announced that he wanted
to be rich one day but his father told
him he could never be rich because his
skin was not
white although he was basically a happy
child cassius sometimes cried himself to
sleep over what his people had to suffer
for his 12th birthday cassius received a
shiny red bicycle
it was stolen almost as soon as he got
it
angry and upset cassius wanted to find
the thief and beat him up
a policeman told cassius that he had
better learn
how to fight first cassius never got his
bike back
he got a mission in life instead
the policeman ran a gym he offered to
teach caches to box
cassius decided that boxing as a sport
was more important than fighting in
anger
he learned that there were many famous
black boxers in fact there were more
black boxers in in the united states
than there were white boxers
boxing was a way he could become rich
and famous he went to the gym every
chance he got
he ate and drank only healthy things
he began running five miles every
morning he also started racing the bus
to school
cassius got better and better at boxing
he was very fast he had quick reflexes
while he was a junior in high
while he was in junior high in high
school cassius fought in amateur bouts
talkative and funny he started
predicting in what round of the fight he
would knock out his opponents
he made up silly poems to tell reporters
when they interviewed him
one went like this
this guy must be done i'll stop him in
one
by the time he was 18 he had won 100
amateur fights
these included four national boxing
championships
he had lost only eight bouts
in 1960
the summer olympics were held in rome
italy
cash has tried out and made the u.s
olympic boxing team as a light
heavyweight
he was so afraid of flying
that he brought his own parachute he
bought his own parachute
at an army surplus store and he wore it
on the flight to rome
in rome cassius met wilma rudolph a
young black woman from harlem in new
york city
she was an inspiring athlete who had won
three gold medals in running at the
olympic games
cassius had a crush on rudolph but she
was already engaged to another runner
cassius fought four olympic bouts
he beat fighters from australia belgium
poland and russia to win
the olympic gold medal
he was so proud of that medal that he
wore to bed at night
back at home his father painted the
front steps of the house red white and
blue
the city of louisville gave cassius a
hero's welcome
cassius recited a special poem for the
occasion making reference to a figure in
roman history who was also named cassius
it began
to make america greatest is my goal so i
beat the russian and i beat the pole and
for the usa won the medal of gold
italian said you're greater than the
cassius of old
not long afterward cassius clay walked
into a restaurant and ordered a glass of
orange juice
the owner would not serve him because he
was black
cassius was angry and hurt
he says that the pain he felt was like
having to take punches without hitting
back
after the olympics cassius turned
professional from then on he fought for
money
a group of local white businessmen paid
his expenses they hired a white boxing
trainer named angelo dundee
at 6 feet three inches tall and weighing
almost 200 pounds
cassius was now a heavyweight boxer
he had the same quickness as when he was
12. he also had the same loud mouth
people called him the louisville lip and
blabber mouth
he didn't care he bragged
they all must fall in the round eye call
in 1964 cassius went up against the
heavyweight champion of the world
sunny liston was an ex-convict
backed by the mafia
cassius boasted
sonny liston is great but he'll fall and
ate
secretly
he was scared
liston was older and bigger and a brutal
fighter
cassius knew he could get hurt
sports reporters were predicting that he
would be knocked out in the first round
cassius knew the only way he could beat
liston was to be smarter than him
one of his trainers said he would have
to float like a butterfly sting like a
bee
that was the way cassius fought liston
he danced around the bigger man he
dodged liston's fist round after round
when he saw that liston was getting
tired he started throwing punches many
of them found their target
listen refused to come out of his corner
for round seven
clash's cassius clay was heavyweight
champion of the world
raising his arms and victory shouted i
am the king i am the king
then he looked down at the reporters who
had predicted he would lose
he shook his fist at them and cried eat
your words eat your words
the day after he beat sonny liston
cassius clay made a surprising
announcement
he was no longer a christian
he was now a member of the nation of
islam also known as the black muslims
the nation was a militant black
organization that not only taught blacks
to be proud of themselves but also
preached that they should keep
themselves separate from whites
it claimed to follow the beliefs of the
world religion of islam although islam
does not preach racial separation
followers of islam who are called
muslims worship god and call him allah
cassius had been interested in the black
muslims since high school
he admired elijah muhammad their leader
and malcolm x the minister whose fiery
speeches had attracted many new members
to the nation
black muslims often took new names to
honor their muslim faith
or as a sign that they rejected their
place in white american society
some like malcolm x used an x for their
last name
cassius clay took a whole new islamic
name
muhammad ali
like muslims all over the world muhammad
ali prayed to allah five times a day
he also prayed in the boxing ring before
every bout
he attended nation of islam temples and
world
muslim mosques
wherever he could find them he married a
muslim woman
he did not have to change his habits of
eating a healthy diet and being clean he
had always lived that way
especially since he had started
boxing
officials of the nation took over
management of his boxing career but ali
kept his white trainer angelo dundee
over the next two years muhammad ali
defended his world title several times
fighting british german canadian and
american opponents
including a rematch with sunny liston
he was at the top of his form and he
kept the world heavyweight title for a
total of three years
there's no telling how long he would
have remained champion
[Applause]
in 1967 the united states was deeply
involved in the vietnam war
u.s troops were helping south vietnam
fight against the vietcong of north
vietnam
young men across the country were being
called to serve in the army
muhammad ali refused to join the army
saying
keep asking me no matter how long on the
war in vietnam i sing this song
i ain't got no quarrel with them
vietcong
the united states had outlawed racial
segregation while ali was heavyweight
champion of the world
nevertheless blacks were still denied
many opportunities it would be a long
time before they enjoyed equality with
whites
ali said he did not believe in fighting
for freedom for other people
when his own people were not free
members of the nation of islam did not
serve in the military
in those days they did not get involved
in politics or even vote
muhammad ali said it was against his
religion to join the army
the united states government charged him
with the crime of refusing military
service and prosecuted him for draft
evasion
ali was sentenced to pay a fine and
spend five years in jail he was allowed
to remain free while he appealed the
verdict to a higher court but he was
banned from boxing and his title was
taken away from him
most people believed he was guilty
the ban was a terrible blow to muhammad
ali's career
he did not have a professional boxing
match for nearly four years
as other heavyweight boxers won and lost
the championship ali insisted that the
title was still his
until someone beat him in the ring he
believed that he remained the true
champion
ali spent his years of exile speaking
out against the vietnam war
during this difficult time he drew
strength from his faith
islam had helped him overcome other
challenges in the past
it helped him conquer his fear of flying
and had enabled him to take his first
trip to africa where there are many
muslims
ali learned that unlike the nation of
islam world islam is not anti-white
all true believers are accepted
as had malcolm x before him he would one
day break away from the radical nation
of islam and devote himself to world
islam
eventually the supreme court the highest
court in the land
recognized ali's devotion to his faith
and ruled that he had been treated
unfairly
american citizens have the right to
refuse military service because of their
religion
ali did not have to pay a fine or go to
jail
ali was nearly 29 years old when he
returned to boxing
he had lost some of his speed some
people believed his days as a winner in
the boxing ring were over
ali proved them wrong winning his first
fight against jerry quarry by a knockout
in the third round
by the time he went up against argentine
argentinian boxer oscar bonavena
he was writing poems again
his poem about the bonavena fight ended
with
before round nine is out the referee
will jump and shout
that's all folks this turkey is out
this time his prediction did not come
true
it took him 15 rounds to knock out
bonavena
on march 8 1971 ali went up against the
world heavyweight champion joe frazier
ali was almost knocked out and the
judges awarded the win to fraser
it was the first loss of his
professional career
ali accepted the defeat
but he declared that he wanted to fight
frazier again
three years passed and many of ali's
matches
lasted much longer than they had when he
was younger he had his jaw broken in a
fight against ken norton for his second
loss
meanwhile joe frazier lost the
heavyweight title to george foreman
finally the 2x champions ali and frazier
had their rematch this time ali outboxed
frazier
the judges awarded him the win
now ali could go up against foreman for
the heavyweight boxing crown
by 1974 foreman had won all 24 of his
professional bouts
by knockouts
ali trained harder than he ever had
before
the fight was staged in the african
nation of zaire and was billed as the
rumble in the jungle
it was a proud moment for all of black
africa which was fighting against white
south africa's support of racism
ali hoped
ali hoped it would be a proud moment for
him he knew it was going to be a tough
fight foreman was younger and stronger
nevertheless ali was faster and more
experienced
he knocked down foreman in the eighth
round and the referee counted him out
after seven long years muhammad ali had
won his title back
during those years ali had also won
respect
most americans had come to believe that
the united states was wrong to fight in
vietnam
they admired ali for standing up to the
government
they also understood that he was sincere
in his religious faith he had not tried
to escape from the draft by using
religion as an excuse
he remained a devoted follower of world
islam
ali said many times he would know when
it was time to retire he wanted to leave
boxing before he was seriously injured
he believed that his style of boxing
protected him as he put it in one of his
poems
in the ring i can stay until i'm old and
gray because i know how to hit and dance
away
his style depended on speed however and
he was slowing down
he had to learn how to take a punch
although he won many bouts he was
injured several times
his third and final bout in 1975 against
joe frazier in the philippines known as
the thrilla in manila
is considered by many to be the greatest
boxing match of all time
ali won but at a great cost
he took nearly 440 punches during that
one fight
in 1978 after defending his title
successfully 10 times he lost it to leon
spinks
he regained the title by beating sphinx
seven months later and became the first
boxer to win the heavyweight
championship three times
he then announced his retirement
sadly against the wishes of his friends
and family he returned to the ring for
two more bouts in 1980 1981 and lost
both
at 39 years old
he was beginning to suffer from brain
damage
he looked the same but he sometimes had
trouble speaking
his reflexes were slowing and his
movements could be stiff
boxing had given him an incurable
condition called parkinson's syndrome
does not threaten his life or affect his
intelligence but it does steadily erode
his control over his own body
since retiring from the boxing ring
muhammad ali has enjoyed his life
although he doesn't live there now his
heart has always stayed in his hometown
of louisville kentucky where his brother
rudy still lives
ali intends to build a muhammad ali
center to train young boys in the sport
that gave him so much
ali is close to his fourth wife lonnie
and to his nine children
he was not around much when the older
children were growing up so he
especially enjoys playing with the
youngest assad whom whom he and lonnie
adopted
assad and the many people who visit
enjoy the magic tricks that ali does to
entertain them
ali remains a devout muslim and prays
five times a day
he considers himself the world's
goodwill ambassador and appears in
public quite often
although he rarely speaks
in 1996 muhammad ali made a surprise
appearance at the summer olympics in
atlanta georgia
he was the final bearer of the torch
that lights the olympic flame
and opens the games
his arm shook as he held the symbol of
international sporting competition
no one had expected him
and the crowd in the stadium and the
billions of television watchers
throughout the world
cheered with love and respect
ali was as much a symbol himself as was
the torch
he was a symbol of strength and skill of
courage and pride
he was a man who broke down barriers and
who brought people together
a champion
in more ways than one
thank you
[Applause]
okay well thank you tim for reading the
book um
at this point i'm going to ask if there
are any questions
uh
you have to go to the mic and then
in your own opinion
do you think muhammad ali is the best
boxer of all time
well in my opinion i think he is
especially after doing this book i i
just um
you know i i
have great admiration for him
however
if you ask my dad who's like the real
boxing fanatic in the family god he
still feels that sugar ray robinson is
the band
so and my dad and i always go back and
forth about that but uh i believe he is
and in a fight between those two who do
you think
ali of course he float like a butterfly
sting like a v
i told my question okay thank you
are you happy guys you guys have to go
to the mic good
uh go ahead
do you plan on um
illustrating another book about muhammad
ali in the future
another book on muhammad ali
unless you write it
um
we don't have any uh in the works um do
you have any ideas
maybe as he gets older or something like
that yeah oh no though this
just one but now
okay good right
what book was the most fun
um for you that you illustrated
the most fun
well
i would say a champion only in that i'm
getting closer and closer to combining
my love of comic books
with um you know my love of picture
books um you know i
i did write grandma's records and
illustrated that and that was a you know
a lot of fun but it was very difficult
because i had to deal with it as though
someone else wrote it and
it's just a whole other uh you know
sensibility
this one was just pure fun a lot of
agony but a lot of fun are you gonna do
a comic book ever
did you ask me that before uh no uh
there are plenty of guys out there that
are like really good at that um
i i think my
my future lies in just combining the two
um you know disciplines
and uh incidentally everyone this is uh
ryan rossi who's um
his mom is responsible for setting this
whole thing up so
i just want to give my man
a nice shout out here
[Applause]
okay
how long did it take to illustrate
champion oh that's a good question um it
took about eight months uh maybe even a
little longer from start to finish it's
the longest project i ever worked on
it took a long time
uh and did you think you could have
finished it like
sooner yeah no way
in fact
i still needed more time when i was
finished it was um my editor tim who
started pressing me to get it closer to
a finish you know okay thank you okay
did you ever actually meet muhammad ali
no we were trying to set something up
but um
uh he's he was contracted through the
movie that was in production at the time
uh to appear only in conjunction with
the film so they kind of exit us out of
the of the deal but uh we really wanted
to meet him i had a lot of questions for
him
i still expect someday to meet him
not not yet okay
uh anyone in the back oh okay so
um you said that you got into
illustrating from
the storybooks that your mother read you
and uh comics that you read is there
anything in particular that you kind of
developed a technique from or any
particular artist oh yeah definitely
from the comic books the paneling
i love that stuff
you know because it moves the story
along and that's what i felt was missing
from picture books uh you know in
picture books usually it's just one
image per page and i felt that um you
know the panels that you see in comic
books are almost more natural and more
movie-like and i'm a big movie fan so
i i
i've answered your question thanks
how did you come to admire muhammad ali
well the thing is that
you know muhammad ali was always
there
from early on i've always heard his name
you know when it was still cassius clay
since my dad was always watching the
fights on television back then they were
on a wide world of sports so every it
wasn't it's not like today that you have
to do pay-per-view and all that the
fights were always on television either
wide world of sports would show them
later
uh but um there was never a time in my
life when i wasn't aware of you know
muhammad ali or cassius clay you know
because of my dad
and did you learn anything new when
you're doing the project oh yeah um i i
have just a greater and deeper respect
for the man now um you know more than
just yeah i see him as more than just a
boxer in fact um
you know i see him more as a hero a
champion
then i and i do it then i do it uh just
a boxer
so
do you think anyone would fight like
muhammad ali in the future
well sugar ray leonard came pretty close
to
getting that style down
but uh he sort of fell short um
but i'm hoping you know he he made the
the sport really exciting you know with
his old razzle dazzle you know style and
all the trash talk i mean you realize
that he's sort of the father of trash
talk like when you see the rock and
those other wrestlers do that today
that's all from muhammad ali you know so
my gran my grandfather is
he used to be a fan of muhammad ali but
now he's a fan of felix trinidad
[Music]
who do you think is the best boxer right
now
wow right now
well i do like felix trinidad he's from
the part of puerto rico that my father's
from
um so i've been watching his career
pretty closely um
so
i guess trinidad and
you know and i i still have some hopes
for tyson if he ever decides to come
back or you know can get his act
together but um
you know
i'm always looking for whoever's on the
horizon something someone new
um i'm from puerto rico too um
what part of
puerto rico were your parents born in
okay that's a great question
fajardo puerto rico my father is from
there and my mother is from santos my
grandmother as well
most of my family's from san juan san
juan well santosa is pretty close to san
juan yeah so do you speak spanish
no oh we should learn
you should learn
thank you
do you enjoy writing or illustrating
books better
i think i prefer the illustrating uh
more than writing
what my approach to writing is so much
like illustrating
i have to write stuff out and then i i
write it over again and over and over
again it's not something i do as well as
as drawing i'm i'm just it just flows
easier to just draw it out for me
oh um as a kid what was the first thing
you wrote about
um
well at first i would retell like the
stories in the like the picture books
that my mom would bring home she the one
that was my favorite was one called the
lollipop party
and uh you know i i made my own version
it was like the ice cream party you know
it it it changed you know uh there's
this snow ice it's like a snow cone uh
we call it pidagwa you know so it was
like the pedagogua party uh
and then after that i started doing my
own comic books and those were based on
the the exploits of my my friends and
cousins when we went to a junior high
school together and got into all sorts
of trouble so i i started documenting
that in these the series that i created
called the sunshine boys of joan of arc
junior high school 118. so those were
the stories
what's the hardest part of writing for
you
uh all of it
um
the easiest i'll start with that the
easiest is coming up with the story
but like i said i write things out the
first time out and then i rewrite it and
then rewrite it and get it you know so
getting it just right so it sounds right
to me probably is the hardest you know
so it takes me a lot of time you know to
kind of rewrite things and get it you
know to sound just right uh but the
story part that comes you know instantly
you know making up the story has always
been easy for me and i think because
i've always you know looked at film and
read so many comic books yeah so
um what age were you again when you
started um
actually drawing and writing well i
started drawing at an early age at about
four or five years old i was already
drawing um you know once i started you
know saying the picture books that my
mom brought home so i was always
scribbling and drawing now
don't get the idea that my drawings look
like you know michelangelo it were
really crude
uh drawings it wasn't until later that i
started developing you know a more you
know realistic style
like yeah why age did you start like
really getting good
about 11 or 12 i would say yeah
i i at one point i was like the most
famous uh artist in the school when i
started doing my little series based on
my my cousins and i in junior high
school but then i went to the high
school of art and design
and everybody there was better than me
so
you know
it was a little devastating but
eventually you know i i i
snapped out of it and started picking up
some steam
thanks
what's your favorite book or comic book
series
um
the green arrow green lantern series
back when neil adams was doing it i
don't know if you're a comic book fan or
you remember neil adams work at all uh
no but that that neil adams had a way of
drawing comic books he was like his
style was really realistic more so than
the other guys like sal bashema maybe um
so i started following neil adams's
career you know so like whatever he
would put out you know i would buy that
you know like when he did the x-men i
did and i bought that entire series
another um comic book uh series that i
followed was the spirit by will eisner
because his storytelling seemed so much
like watching a movie that i was drawn
to that you know so i started collecting
you know the spirit comic books as well
which were like they were black and
white printed black and white okay
um in those times when muhammad ali um
had had lost and he got really um
injured and sometimes if he got injured
valley and in european do you think he
may have felt like
trying another match or just or just
felt like he was just going to stop but
then he but then the thigh fighter
probably came back about doing another
match
okay you said a lot there
um was the question
if he should have um stopped sooner or
continued fighting is that yeah
i'm of the belief that he should have
stopped sooner than than when he did and
you know probably the muhammad ali that
you would know today would be a whole
lot different than the one that you know
is out there now
um are you going to write another book
and
if you are um what's it going to be
about
um yes i'm in the process of writing
another book it's
actually a prequel to grandma's records
um
but it's a slow process for me and i'm
also working on other books that i'm
illustrating so uh
it'll be once again based on my
grandmother and i uh which was a special
time for me
so
yeah look for it maybe in two two three
years
okay okay
do you consider the boxers of muhammad
ali's time better than the boxers today
that's a tricky question
uh
because when i started watching all the
the fight footage i noticed that the
actions seem a lot slower at times and
the the action that we're used to today
um and unless i guess we put those you
know the two boxes like let's say
someone like um you know like mike tyson
in the ring with someone you know such
as muhammad ali you really won't know
um
but there was a magic in the the the the
older boxers that the younger boxers
don't seem to to um to capture but
yeah
unless you see the fight you you really
can't tell that's that's the way i feel
about it
okay um how was it where you used to
live how was it yeah in spanish harlow
how was it um it was great uh spanish
harlem is a community
uh you know a lot of stores a lot of
people everyone sort of knows each other
um most of the people in spanish harlem
the park that i grew up in 115th street
madison avenue they're all from puerto
rico the same part of puerto rico so a
lot of them know each other
going way back i mean it was a great
place harlem also a great place
it's very different you know
for us because we were sort of the
outsiders and um you know we gradually
you know assimilated into that community
that answer your question yep okay thank
you
were you ever had any boxing matches
me yeah no no i i i think in my whole
life i probably have maybe just
one big fight in sixth grade and uh it
wasn't even much of a fight we just
rolled around the the playground all
over the place until the principal came
out and separated us
i'm a lover not a fighter
were you born with the talent to draw or
or did you get taught to draw
uh i was not born drawing at all um like
i said when i although i love to draw
it didn't really look like much
it was through actually good teachers
and
you know trying to yeah copying things
out of books and magazines that i i
really got better but um you know i was
not born peter troy not at all and uh
what did you major in in college
uh illustration yeah
do you admire any other
people like muhammad ali do i admire any
other people like muhammad ali any other
people
tons of people
but
most of the people i admire tend to be
people in the arts uh you know either
jazz musicians
or other artists
um i think muhammad ali is probably like
the only real sports figure
that that's in my list and that's
probably be that's probably what
surprised my editors so much but they
they weren't aware that that i was into
muhammad ali at all because i'm always
talking about jazz i'm talking about art
all the time and i don't really talk
much about about sports
oh okay
i have two questions my first one is um
what made muhammad ali change his
religion
um he uh if you saw the movies or movies
um he came in contact with malcolm x
early on when he was still in miami
prior to the sunny liston fight
and he listened to
malcolm speeches that he would give at
the local mosque
and uh i guess you know he liked what he
what he heard and he was drawn to you
know the the whole idea
of um you know the nation of islam at
that time but you gotta understand that
the context in which all that happened
was you know there was a lot of racism
in america at the time um you know a lot
of suffering
uh
you know so you can almost understand
why at that time you know someone might
be drawn to um the you know the messages
in in um malcolm x's speeches
and um
second question is oh do you know what
muhammad ali's record was when he lost
joe frazier do you know how many fights
he won i would defer to it too for that
one
you know what we were working on the
project we were like muhammad ali
experts but i've since illustrated
another book and i'm currently working
on another so
you know it starts to fade in your mind
you should have caught us about uh six
or seven months ago
sorry
have you illustrated any book covers
that you haven't written for like you
haven't you're involved with the book
just a book cover
um well
are you asking about the book covers
that i did yeah title page yeah i did
i i
i
pretty much did like 300 images before i
started doing my first before i even did
my first picture book i don't know if
you're familiar with the encyclopedia
brown series i did all the book covers
for that i've done
book covers on just about every topic
journey to joburg chain of fire or two
of them like more popular books that
i've um
did the cover and some interior
illustrations for
um
tons of stuff
uh amazon.com just punch my name and
it'll all come up
is that it
okay i
want to thank you for being a great
audience
[Music]
eric velasquez is the illustrator of
champion the story of muhammad ali it's
published by walker and company online
at walkerbooks.com
next week on children's books anna
harwell chalenza tells the story behind
franz joseph haydn symphony number 45
known as the farewell symphony
you can find out more about the
program's ace that professional sports
in america are closely tied to radical
politics and his new book what's my name
fool
next hear the stories of olympic
sprinter john carlos and boxer muhammad
ali as well as former nfl player pat
tillman who joined the army rangers and
was killed in afghanistan this is 45
minutes
good evening ladies and gentlemen
and welcome to barnes noble astor place
tonight i have the distinct pleasure of
introducing dave zirin mr zirin is the
editor of the prince george's post and
writes a weekly column for the paper
called edge of sports he's the regular
sports commentator for air america's
national radio show on the reel with
chuck d
and in addition he's a senior writer at
basketball.com and regular columnist for
slam magazine
his journalism has appeared in the
source the college sporting news the san
francisco bay view and z magazine to
name a few
and he joins us this evening to discuss
his first book what's my name fool
sports and resistance in the united
states
mary radcliffe author of the san
francisco bay view has said of the
author
he is that rarest of commodities in
sports writing an original voice this
book will be loved by both athletes and
by who hate politics and by activists
who hate sports so won't you please join
me in welcoming dave zirin
[Applause]
what's my name fool
sports and resistance in the united
states
now this book just to make it clear in
one sentence is about times when radical
politics found expression in the world
of professional sports in the u.s
now just to be clear i have heard some
of the jokes about this book
like radical politics in u.s sports
that'll make a great pamphlet
and why don't you just write about
something that has a little bit more
material to it like the great atheists
of the christian coalition or
strom thurman's favorite black history
moments
now but there is a tradition and that's
the case i make with this book deeply
hidden of times when the struggles off
the field exploded onto the field with
absolutely electric consequences now
this tradition runs counter to the
carnival of reaction that i think a lot
of us see in sports who watch it on a
day in day out basis whether that's for
work or not
in this country
now i actually had a front row seat for
this carnival of reaction just last
month when i went to a washington
nationals game that's my home team and i
went because you know big shock i
actually wanted to see a baseball game
but instead what i was treated to was
what the nationals were calling military
appreciation night or
man
where
20 young men right there at the home
plate an emphasis on men were sworn into
the u.s marines before the start of the
game
now this took place with george w bush
sitting in one of the owner's boxes up
top
as you know like caesar you know waiting
for lions to emerge from the dugout um
as the announcer thanked bush and the
troops for fighting for our freedom in
iraq and honestly i sat there just
slack-jawed which is not my normal pose
just utterly speechless not my normal
mode of action because i mean as fans i
mean this is when the speechless part
came we were informed by that kind of
disembodied god voice that comes from
the speakers
that we too could sign up to fight for
operation iraqi freedom
at a stand located right outside the
stadium wow peanuts cracker jacks and
war that is a great evening if i ever
heard one now if like me you're one of
the you know 61 percent of the country
who doesn't think that the troops in
iraq happen to be fighting for freedom
right now
you find yourself in this stadium with
absolutely no voice you find yourself
with no way to express yourself to the
athletic industrial complex and i was
sitting there and it just it just never
ceases to amaze me how sports something
that had a huge role in shaping me
growing up something that was an
incredibly positive influence on me
growing up that i believe should
celebrate beauty and the best of
competition and cooperation and fun god
forbid can be used in such a disgusting
way now i love sports and that's why i
think we need to fight for sports we
need to actually reclaim them we need to
take sports back and if we're going to
do so what we need is we need to know
our history that's our greatest
ammunition in this fight we need to know
our history of the athletes the sports
writers and the fans who have stood up
to the machine if for no other reason
than knowing this history i think allows
us to look at the world and see that
struggle can affect every aspect of life
in this system even the swoosh adorned
ivory tower known as sports
now
i want to start here really by talking
about where the title of this book comes
from and to be honest i used to have a
joke that clunked mightily when i would
when i would talk about the book where i
would say what's my name fool no it's
not a tribute to mr t which only
had that kind of reaction
and um
but but what occurred to me was i was
actually
at a bookstore a couple weeks ago when a
young well-meaning person came up to me
and said oh my god is this the book
about mr t and was totally serious
so i repeat that just to say that our
history has been robbed from us i think
is a safe
assessment and i want to start though
about where this title actually comes
from because i think it tells a great
deal about the book and it's also a
direct reference to what i believe is
the high point of that connection
between sports and resistance which in
my view is the time when the heavyweight
champion of the world had one foot in
the black freedom struggle and one foot
in the anti-war movement and of course
i'm talking about the great muhammad ali
now today in 2005 i think people
especially people who are say under 30
you know noah lee most is sort of like
the walking saint the guy who lit the
torch at the 96 olympics in atlanta the
guy who comes out to throw out the first
pitch or toss the ball and when you see
this and you see president sort of pat
him on the back and lead him by the hand
you just would never know that this was
the most despised slandered brutalized
and also heroic athlete on the face of
the earth in the 1960s
now ali made everybody confront his
politics of resistance when he changed
his name first from cassius clay
to cassius x actually and then of course
to muhammad ali and if we're going to
talk about ali just to be very clear
everybody has to get will smith out of
their heads because it's just too
upsetting to me to think that people are
the fresh prince of bel air is
moving on okay now there are really no
words for the storm that this caused
when cassius clay changed his name i
mean the heavyweight champion of the
world in this country in the 60s when
boxing was arguably the biggest sport in
the united states the champion was the
symbol of americana red white and blue
strength power aggression all of these
things and all of a sudden you had the
heavyweight champion of the world first
of all talking about how pretty he was
which shocked people you know in and of
itself but then joining the organization
of malcolm x joining an organization in
the nation of islam that unabashedly
believed in self-defense for people
fighting in the south in the civil
rights movement and the mobbed up
corrupt right-wing fight world
absolutely lost their minds but
what was incredible about that time was
overnight whether you the name became so
seminal to the 60s because whether or
not you called the champion clay or ali
it said everything about you it said
what side you were on in the black
freedom struggle what side you were on
in the free speech movements breaking
out on campuses soon the war in vietnam
as well it was an incredible thing and
just to give an idea about this uh my
step aunt was was telling me this story
when i was showing her the book about
how she actually moved out of her
apartment for a week where you know
living with her dad she's 17 years old
she moved out and stayed on a friend's
couch because she got in this huge fight
with her dad about whether the
heavyweight champion's name happened to
be clay or happen to be ali
now
you might think that this sounds like a
pretty dysfunctional family and you'd be
right but
but the bigger issue is that it was
really not an argument about his name it
was an argument about the political
period it was an argument about the
radicalization breaking out and which
side of the barricades you might have
seen yourself on
now this whole name controversy really
reached its peak in november of 1965.
that's when ali fought a former two-time
champion a man who was proudly patriotic
named floyd patterson now in the
pre-fight hype patterson this is what he
said to reporters this is a direct quote
he said this fight is a crusade to
reclaim the title from the black muslims
as a catholic i am fighting clay and yes
his name is clay as a patriotic duty to
return the crown to america
now ali's response to this just shocked
reporters because he had no response at
all i mean this was the man they called
louisville lip gashes cassius cash the
brash and he had nothing to say in
response to this he just let it simmer
and then he did his talking in the ring
nine rounds against patterson he just
took him apart and as he was jabbing at
patterson he yelled out so everyone in
press row could hear he said come on
america come on white america say my
name is my name clay what's my name fool
and that's where i get the title of the
book
that's just the title so it's a good
book
now what's interesting is i'm talking to
people about this book i've been had the
privilege to go around and speak about
it is that most sports fans i talk to
know ali is the person responsible for
saying what's my name fool not mr t and
most know that it's in reference to his
name change and religious conversion but
it's the background that people don't
know the swirling black freedom struggle
the symbolic and very personal
importance ali's fights had to people
just figuring out how to stand up on
their own i mean as brian gumbel said
and
i can't believe i'm quoting brian gumbel
but it's a really good quote he said
one of the reasons the civil rights
movement went forward was that black
people were able to overcome their fear
and i honestly believe that for many
black americans that came from watching
muhammad ali he simply refused to be
afraid and being that way he gave other
people courage and another person julian
bond who back then was a young civil
rights activist today is one of the
heads of the naacp he said
the act of ali joining the nation was
not necessarily something we all agreed
with but we just love the fact that he
seemed to be telling white people to go
to hell for us
now i want to give two examples of that
sense though about ali's actual presence
giving people confidence in the
movements going on outside the ring that
i think are very evocative and certainly
not something we're taught in sports
century moments on espn um the first is
something that took place in alabama
where you had a group of
african-american activists and snick the
student nonviolent coordinating
committee basically the youth wing of
the civil rights movement they were
organizing a group there called the
loans county freedom party they were
trying to register the poorest of the
poor african-american voters in alabama
sharecroppers people who work people who
worked in factories down there and
they're famous in this in sort of the
annals of the civil rights movement
because they were the first people to
ever use the symbol of a black panther
and huey newton and bobby seal in
california they used that as an
inspiration to call themselves the black
panthers that's something people who
know the history of the civil rights
movement know that oh yeah that's where
they had the symbol of the black panther
in alabama but what a lot of people
don't know is that their slogan that
they had emblazoned underneath the black
panther was
we are the greatest when they took the
ali i am the greatest and put a big
plural on the front of that
another example is martin luther king
when he came out against the vietnam war
in 1967 this is something that's
generally talked about with king in
general discussion but it's not
remembered the degree of pressure and
criticism he received for doing it at
the time not just from like the
mainstream media but also from the
established civil rights movement who
thought that king shouldn't be speaking
out about international affairs of war
when king gave his first press
conference to actually speak about the
war in vietnam he said in his remarks
like muhammad ali tells us we are all
victims of the same system of injustice
and oppression like incorporating
muhammad ali's name to explain why he's
coming out against the war that to me is
incredible
now i think these stories are incredible
i i hope i'm not alone but i think the
problem is in sports history itself as
it's told on you know the worldwide
leader espn is that it it gets marketed
to death with the soft lighting the bad
music the booyah all that stuff and and
like ali it becomes utterly sort of esp
ended you know it's like it's political
teeth just get extracted and that's
really what the book is about is trying
to reclaim that history and learn about
the fire underneath the icons
and i want to give some examples of that
sort of like the history that we know
and then the history that we're not told
like for example it's it's well known
that jack johnson was the first black
heavyweight champion of the world
winning the title in 1908 but do we know
that he when he defended the title
successfully against jim jeffords who
was called the great white hope his
defeat of jeffords actually started the
greatest race riot this country had ever
seen and ever would see until the 1968
king assassination the character of
these riots were white mobs and sensed
at johnson's victory attempting to enter
black neighborhoods and and black
communities defending themselves by
force after a boxing match this occurred
in 1910
i mean and just to continue that just to
show how like what happens off the field
or out of the ring influences what's in
the ring booker t washington who was
just um outraged in sense you know
conservative black leader at the time
went to johnson and demanded that he
condemn people for rioting and johnson
said you can kiss my i can't say that
because it's on tv but but johnson
responded you can kiss my black ass is
what johnson said in response i just got
the okay from c-span okay
i mean we may also know that that
baseball was segregated for 50 years
until 1947. but do we know the story of
lester red rodney who is the sports
editor of the communist party's
newspaper the daily worker i mean a lot
of people i talked to their first
response is wow the daily worker had a
sports section that's the first point of
surprise but that lester rodney used the
sports section as an organizing center
to fight for baseball's integration a
campaign that garnered over a million
signatures collected at ballparks around
the country from wrigley field to
comiskey park to yankee stadium out here
in new york now
i i got to interview lester rodney for
this book and it was an absolute
privilege and something that i will
never ever forget
and 95 years old sharp as attack
i mean we may know that jackie robinson
was that man the first one to integrate
baseball in 1947 but i think we know him
mostly as this kind of quiet suffering
black saint who was brought to the
dodgers under the sort of paternal
warmth of branch rickey now what we
don't know him as is a person who wrote
a political sports column for the new
york post which dealt with the issues of
civil rights and this is when the new
york post was not something you used to
wipe your floor but actually was a
liberal publication and we also don't
know him as he was the the number one
requested speaker of the naacp in the
united states at that time in the 1950s
and he barnstormed around the country
speaking at meetings the number two
speaker at the time was someone you
might have heard of named martin luther
king and when the way robinson would
wrap up his speeches is he would always
use this one line that people would go
nuts he would say
if i had to choose between the hall of
fame and full citizenship for my people
i would choose full citizenship time and
again
and that to me is like almost like
instinctually like the best tradition of
the left in this country like when
former labor labor leader and socialist
party candidate eugene debs would say
when i rise it's going to be with the
ranks not from the ranks that's what i
hear in robinson's words and it's i
think it's incredible
we may know for example about the famed
uh black power salute of tommy smith and
john carlos at the 1968 olympics i mean
you can go outside probably and buy it
on a t-shirt i mean it's even being
commemorated
last month it was commemorated in a
statue in california but there's a lot
about that picture we don't know and
it's one of the most marketed pictures
certainly in the last 100 years but we
don't know that tommy smith and john
carlos they also wore beads on the metal
stand to protest lynching they didn't
wear shoes because they wanted to
protest poverty that john carlos
actually wore his olympic jacket open
which was a massive breach of etiquette
at the time that shocked them almost as
much as the fist thing and when i got to
interview john carlos for the book and
when i asked him why he left his jacket
open he said quote i wanted it open
because i wanted to represent shift
workers blue-collar people and the
underdogs the people whose contributions
to society are so important but don't
get recognized and we certainly don't
hear about the instances that were
occurring around these guys in 1968 that
led to that moment you know the
assassination of dr king and how it
influenced those guys to make a stand at
the olympics you know the strikes in may
in paris uh the movement that was
occurring in south africa at the time
against apartheid which was very
influential to smith and carlos and of
course the assassination of 500 students
and workers in mexico city right before
the olympics by the state police as they
attempted to make mexico city safe for
the olympic games and so we hear that we
see the picture but we don't hear any of
the history which to me is the
equivalent of like telling the story of
the titanic and forgetting the iceberg i
mean it's bad history it's bad politics
and it's it's i think generally bad
writing as well
to put it bluntly okay
i mean i need to get some water possibly
i got personal crutches
this
book about like the underdog and whatnot
i'm like hey you on the crutches get me
some water that wouldn't be
that would
be terrible
i mean
moving on um we may know about billie
jean king's battle of the sexes match
against bobby riggs one of the most
watched television programs in the
history of this country but whenever
they do retrospectives of that we don't
hear about how deeply embedded that
match was at the time with the movement
for women's liberation especially one of
the most enduring victories of that
movement and that's a title ix
legislation which which ensured equal
funding even though it's it's largely
unenforced but still an incredible
victory um that allows women equal
funding not just for sports it's
commonly thought of as just a sports
thing but also educational opportunities
in general
i think we need to know this history
because it's a living history and it's
alive any time athletes today attempt to
use their hyper-exalted commercialized
platform to speak out on social issues
or draw inspiration from struggles in
the streets this history is alive when
carlos delgado who's a slugger for the
florida marlins when he was playing for
the toronto blue jays last year said he
wouldn't stand on the steps for the
american flag because the war in iraq
was quote unquote murder based upon lies
it's alive when the nba's etan thomas
who plays for the washington wizards
shows up at anti-death penalty events in
dc to read his slam poetry that calls
out the racism of this system in utterly
stark terms and people should check out
his book of poetry called more than an
athlete which will absolutely blow your
mind
it's alive when felipe alou who's the
manager of the san francisco giants
stands up to the anti-immigrant racism
on sports radio and does it proudly
it's a and i think it's especially alive
when the u.s congress and their steroid
hysteria hoopla you know kind of like uh
like joe mccarthy's like little cousin
stuff you know it's it's ridiculous um
feared calling barry bonds to testify on
steroids out of concern that he would
say to them what he'd been saying to
reporters namely quote why is steroids
cheating but making a shirt in korea for
50 cents and selling it here for 150
isn't
now knowing this history positions us to
support and embrace not just the
athletes who go out on a political limb
but also fans who thrilled of their
exploits and i think by confronting
these messages that are pumped out
through our play we can dissect what we
like and what we dislike about sports
and then challenge not only sports but
also our society to change i mean when
warplanes fly overhead as they do before
baltimore ravens games uh in my neck of
the woods we can actually ask how many
physical education classes are cut to
pay for every blue angel
when those disgustingly sexist beer
commercials trade on women's oppression
for the high cause of selling beer
we can make clear that this kind of
stuff has no place
in sports
when college athletes are just massacred
in the media for taking under the table
payoffs we can ask about like whose
blood sweat and tears actually paid for
that new enormou dome on that campus
when announcers on fox become like as
aghast as like southern bells when they
see a touchdown dance get too raunchy i
mean we can ask how a network that pays
bill o'reilly millions and promotes
shows like who's your daddy and the
littlest groom which is a i don't want
to say what that's about but it's
kind of gross but how they have the
right to be the purity police when our
cities like this city are attempted to
be soaked by sleazy stadium deals like
the rat house by bruce ratner that he's
trying to build in brooklyn we can stand
up as sports fans and say hey we may
love baseball we may love basketball it
might be nice to have the nets in town
what have you but i'm not going to give
a billionaire a 350 million dollar
present for the privilege of watching it
now by speaking out for the political
soul of the sports we love we do more
than just build a fighting left that
stands for social justice in every arena
we also begin to impose our own ideas on
the world of sports a counter morality
to compete with the yawning hypocrisy of
the pro leagues and to me these are this
is a morality that allows us to thrill
to barry bonds to not give up sports
just because they soak it with their
ideas to thrill to michael vick to
thrill to mia ham kicking a soccer ball
but unlike the mainstream sports jabber
it's a morality that actually recognizes
these athletes as human beings with
minds as well as bodies not just as
extensions of equipment i think it needs
to understand that the incentive of
athletes to speak out for social justice
lies not in their individual brilliance
but on our ability to build a struggle
outside the arena in other words if we
want more muhammad ali's more john
carlos's and more billie jean kings if
we want to see a gay male athlete have
the courage to risk his neck by coming
out instead of players like mike piazza
calling press conferences just to let us
all know that he's not gay i think
that's going to take building a broader
movement for social justice outside the
arena so our heroes will have people to
look up to and in that fight we need
every drop of history we can get our
hands on as tommy smith himself said
about his fame black power salute it's
not some this is what tommy smith said
he said quote it's not something i could
lay on my shelf and forget about my
heart and soul are still on that team
and i still believe in everything we
were trying to fight for in 1968 it has
not been resolved and it's going to be
part of our future i mean he's
absolutely right struggle is part of our
future and when that struggle occurs it
will affect and is affecting right now
athletes and fans alike what the book is
about at the end of the day is is about
knowing that those who speak out
actually stand in a tradition that goes
back a hundred years and that speaks to
actually beyond the field of play to all
of us it's tradition that stands on the
broader fight for social justice it's
tradition we should embrace whether
we're sports fans or not thank you
[Music]
okay
we're taking questions
uh remind people that were on tv
wait for the mic uh makeups in the back
if people wanna no just kidding
um
just raise your hand
i've been i've been mulling on this
question for about 10 years so
i'm happy i've been really looking
forward to being here i read i can't
think of a better place for you to ask
than on television i read your article
in the international socialist review
about the jacks johnson riots and so i i
remember in 1992 when i was in i guess i
was a freshman in high school the
chicago
during when the chicago bulls first won
the nba championship
um
they i mean i remember just seeing on tv
you know rodney the rodney king trial
verdict that just happened there had
just been the rebellion in los angeles
so i remember seeing on tv that after
the bulls won
fans rushed to the vip like end of the
stadium because i think the chicago
stadium is on the poor side of town they
they were i mean you know assaulting the
limousines and all the important people
they were burning police cars i mean it
was you know there was a little
rebellion going on and so basically my
question and and i haven't i've tried
since the advent of the internet to look
this up and i just basically want to ask
about
like given the fact that the chicago
police are like racist and brutal like
what is it about that that allows these
little opportunities for people to fight
back in such a you know uh you know i
don't know a victorious way where they
you know you know they they won they
drove the cops away
and and like do you know of anything
else um i don't know in world sports
history even where there was some
political
i don't know advance
after a sports victory or a defeat
i mean as far as world sports i'm not do
sports take place outside the united
states i'm sorry i'm
i'm a born i'm a born and raised in this
country so i've never heard of these
other sports no i'm just um
i mean
i mean yeah i'm not gonna take the pro
sports riot stance um as a mode for
social change but but but just to say
that when sports riots do occur i mean i
i do think that obviously like you don't
go out and burn a limousine if you're
feeling really good about your life and
your options and what what's going on in
the world i mean so i think that they
are largely
if not entirely expressions of
alienation i mean whether they occur on
college campuses or occur in cities that
doesn't mean necessarily even that
they're politically progressive
in any way i think they're they're
expressions though i mean it's not a
good thing like i had somebody um
like once at a meeting asked me like hey
i was at syracuse university and there
was this riot after we won the
championship how do we channel that into
the movement against the war and it's
like well you don't i mean in some
respect it's an expression of of
people's utter sort of disconnection
from politics not an expression not an
expression of their connection i mean
it's more like an outgrowth of just
anger and frustration that people feel
not an expression of
i think even something positive that we
can organize i think the jack johnson
thing is different because it was the
character of people defending their
neighborhoods against white lynch mobs
and feeling the confidence to do that in
the context of what jack johnson
represented against a great white hope
so i think there's a qualitative
difference there than some guys lighting
their mattress on fire in their frat
house and throwing it out in the street
not that i don't want to talk to those
guys but
just when they're not drunk
yes i have several questions um
let's talk about the olympics first um i
don't know if you mentioned in the book
i'm in the middle of reading the book
right now but uh i think juan sammerage
i think is right pronunciation he's the
uh was the head of the international
olympic committee i don't have you
brought this out but he was a former uh
i think education or physical director
for francisco franco
and i was wondering what if you know the
history historical background behind
that how he impacted on the olympics and
i don't know whether or not you talked
about uh the situation in the berlin
olympics in 1936 where
the jewish athletes marty glickman i
believe was one of them that were
excluded from
uh the olympics participating in the 36
berlin olympics because they were jewish
and whether or not you had included that
in the book itself
um the other the other question i had
was a transformation a metamorphosis of
of george foreman because i remember
growing up watching george foreman i was
a young kid
that back in the 75 he was he was really
quiet and you know he's really close and
didn't say very much whereas ali was
really boisterous
and it's like
a complete metamorphosis and george
foreman is really loud and have you
talked about that and how what the basis
of that transformation of course ali we
know because of his disease and because
he took too many punches probably but um
i'm going to make a comment on that and
one last thing is about did you monitor
your book
uh of back in the 70s school in your
face i don't know if you remember that
book it was a book that was a sports
book that talked about the issues that
you very similar to that at that period
of time
wow um
first about the olympics and juan
antonio samaranch whose name he
pronounced just fine um
i mean i mean he he was the head for a
long time of the international olympic
committee the ioc now the ioc throughout
their history in the last hundred years
i mean had had more fascists sitting
around the table than like your typical
outtakes of the nuremberg trials i mean
it is an outrageous motley crew of
people who supported franco spade and
hitler i mean it's like find me a
fascist these guys were i mean they
followed him around like groupies would
follow the grateful dead i mean these
guys are are pretty outrageous and it
actually connects very well with like
kind of the history of the olympics so
the modern olympics started in 1898
which was also the year of the
spanish-american war in this country and
i mean it had to do with actually
organizing the divisions of the world
through games i mean representing what
was happening in the broader sense in
the world and i do talk about that in
the book but you know the modern olympic
movement it's kind of a contradictory
thing because it's like on the one hand
you actually do get to see sports that
are utterly marginalized in the other
time it's like i i like watching those
sports i like not having to watch you
know the same thing all the time and a
lot of the in a lot of those sports i
think there's just incredible beauty and
and it's wonderful really i mean the way
in the state of maryland the way it
really did come alive around like
michael phelps the swimmer and all of a
sudden people are talking about swimming
and that to me is interesting and
learning stuff and it's different
especially women's sports get a profile
in the olympics they don't get other
times but the olympics itself as a quote
unquote movement and they talk about the
olympic movement i would argue is
utterly barbaric and reactionary in
every way shape or form and if you want
proof of that you raised one example
which to me is the tip of the iceberg
and that's the 36 olympics in berlin the
history of when the olympics actually go
to a place and what they do to a place
in terms of organizing a city is about
crushing a municipality and actually
crushing the people who actually live in
a given city and people in new york you
guys should give yourselves a hand for
warding off the 2000
is it 12 olympics
you did very well for yourself and just
the last thing i'm sorry to say about
that is one of the reasons why you guys
didn't get the olympics is because they
were flooded with emails and phone calls
from people in new york city saying
please do not send us the olympics
because people here had some sense of
actually what that means for ordinary
people there's a whole history about
that which we can talk about foreman i'm
not going to talk about other people
have questions i'm sorry i'm going on so
i have a lot about foreman in the book
so i got to interview him which was was
really cool especially when he started
singing bob dylan to me over the phone
that that everybody must get stone song
he started singing that over the phone
and then he said you know what that
song's about and i'm like i don't know
what drugs and he's like no it's about
you know when people throw stones at you
when you make a stand and i was like i
don't know george i think it's about
drugs
should go get stoned i mean
i don't know sorry
dave i'm wondering if there was a pivot
point that got the sports labor movement
started
and if you can tell us if the american
labor movement can learn anything from
the pro sports labor movement
i mean yeah i mean first it's an
understanding that sports unions i would
argue are part of the labor movement
which is kind of a difficult argument
sometimes because you have some athletes
like michael jordan magic johnson who
are part owners of teams and i don't
care how good your union is if you're a
steel worker you're not going to own a
string of steel mills at the end of the
day so it's it's highly distorted it's
different you know players organize
individual contracts but the whole
reason why players make their super
salaries is actually because of the fact
that there was a union movement in
sports particularly in the 1960s and the
pivot for that was really two events and
um i talked about it extensively in the
book a whole chapter on it um one was
the hiring of marvin miller who was a
steel workers uh union organizer and i
got to interview marvin miller for the
book and he brought a different kind of
approach to organizing baseball players
who at the time baseball players what
they made in a year average salary in
the mid 60s for a baseball player was
like low 20 000 at that point i mean
every player unless you were like mickey
mantle basically you worked in the off
season i interviewed older players i
mean they worked in quarries in the off
season like crushing rocks it's hard to
imagine alex rodriguez going to the
quarry
you know but that's what the conditions
were like at the time and they they won
that bigger piece of the pie through
active struggle and solidarity and the
pivot for that was marvin miller in his
relationship with kurt flood which i
talk about in the book kurt flood
was it was a different kind of player
who represented a lot of people in that
he came from oakland which means he came
from a city and he was african-american
growing up in oakland so it's like that
was different for the major leagues in
the 60s because at the time there was
still a small minority of black players
and the ones who were there tended to
come from very small towns in the south
very isolated very atomized here you had
kurt flood coming in representing a lot
of players who were new at that time
coming in and having to play like in the
southern minor leagues and people would
be calling him boy and asking him to eat
on the on the bus and you know all that
stuff and he would be like who are you
talking to you know i'm from oakland i
will kill you you know he's just like
you know it's a very different kind of
attitude that he brought to it that was
and so what he did was him and marvin
miller marvin miller the genius of
marvin miller was he got that the labor
movement and i think a lot of labor
leaders today need to see this does not
exist in a vacuum he got that black
workers were becoming radicalized he
talked with kurt flood about how to
actually use that to push forward and
even though kurt flood i mean his story
ends up being being a tragic one but he
fought to end the reserve clause which
was really the trigger for the salaries
uh spiraling upward to where we are
today and what i agree with what i take
from it all is what one major league
player about alex rodriguez who they
said about him if alex rodriguez has a
soul he'll send ten percent of his
paycheck to kurt flood's family
dave
is there is there any truth to the rumor
that you were on steroids when you wrote
this book
that that's not that's not really my
question okay um could you talk about
the way
um the sports world and then
the ensuing madness in the media
co-opted pat tillman's
move from pro football into the us
military
so i'll just say the person who asked
that question is a writer named mickey z
who's one of the best writers out there
if you've never heard of him you should
get his stuff i i'm sorry i just wanted
to say that
he's an incredible incredible writer um
to answer the first question
though if
i am taking storage there's a doctor
who's going to get sued pretty damn
quick i'll tell you that
um
the second part though the pat tillman
story is um
is to me like almost overbearingly
overwhelmingly tragic and it's one that
i think is worth reviving and talking
about especially given what cindy
sheehan is doing right now in texas i
mean
[Applause]
it's one of those things where you say
never let anybody tell you that one
person can't make a difference i mean if
they're willing to actually get out
there and put themselves on the line and
i mean the connection with cindy sheehan
has to do with pat tillman's parents
people know the story of pat tillman i'm
going to assume they do he's
turned down millions of dollars in the
nfl he joined the army rangers we we got
the big uh nationally he was killed in
afghanistan there was a nationally
televised funeral that john mccain and
other quote unquote political luminaries
spoke at bush even spoke on the
jumbotron at the arizona stadium where
he played during the election season to
address the fans as everybody cheered
and they flew the blue angels usa usa
the only problem with it was that it was
a total unequivocal and disgusting lie
because pat tillman actually died at the
hands of his own troops and how that
occurred is still something that's very
unknown and and because they burned all
the evidence at the time claiming that
it was a biohazard which is actually not
true i looked it up because i'd all
these people email me after i wrote
about it saying you don't understand
military law man they had to burn the
evidence i was like
that's like great you know love that
love the uh laptop commandos like with
their
you know but but the but what makes the
story so so just like relentlessly
disgusting was the fact that pat
tillman's parents were not told that he
died in this matter pat tillman's
brother who was in his platoon who he
went to the rangers with was not told
and they were left at the funeral
basically being used as props so people
asked what did pat tillman actually die
for i mean in the literal sense he died
for pr for this war and it's also not a
coincidence at all that they needed to
sell his death as heroic because it came
out the same week as abu ghraib and the
scandal there they needed that story
they needed a hero and they needed
someone in pat tillman who couldn't turn
them down as he did when he was a live
soldier and say i'm not going to do your
ads i just want to be a soldier whatever
you know whether you agree or disagree
with what pat tillman did the point is
that they ruthlessly exploited him in
death and his parents pat and mary
senior after they heard this they're
both known very quiet people very
conservative people they're divorced
couple they spoke out jointly about this
they condemn bush they condemn the war
they condemned just the entire charade
that their family was put through and
then they immediately got quiet again i
was really hoping that they would use
that as an opportunity but two things
happened that i thought were a shame one
was that because this story really did
get relegated to the sports section i
you didn't see like the anti-war
movement the left actually go to the
tillman's and be like let's get your
story out there let's talk about it
because it exposes how sick this system
is which is something i would argue
should have happened
and the second thing but what i'm hoping
now is like with what cindy sheehan is
doing that it's going to give confidence
and courage not just to the tillman's
but to everybody who's lost a family
member in this disgusting war and that
includes iraqis as well to actually get
out there and have their story heard
[Applause]
one more question
i wanted to
ask you about uh well say something
about john roberts for a second because
one of the things that this moderates
apparently you know a very palatable
um supreme court justice talked about is
being against title ix and just i was
wondering if you could just talk a
minute about like what title ix actually
meant
in this nation for women's sports and
like what and maybe what it would look
like if something like that was opposed
yeah i mean first just i mean title nine
it's it speaks to me i have a um 12
month year old daughter right now so
it's like when i hear about them
overturning title ix you know
doing women's rights work was one of the
first political things i ever did in
college but now that i have a daughter
i'm just kind of like oh this [ __ ] just
got personal
you know what are you doing
you know because before
title nine was enacted
roughly one
out of ever well let me put it this way
right now one out of every three women
slash girls in the united states take
part in sports on the junior high or
high school level one out of three
before title nine it was one out of
twenty seven i mean you are talking
about a radical radical difference in
the lives of women um because of this
legislation and if you look at it
statistically issues about um
with regards to uh self-esteem
likelihood of being in an abusive
relationship likelihood of having an
eating disorder these things can be
connected with sports and this to me
with all that's disgusting about sports
speaks to what's good about sports
because obviously people are get
something productive out of it that does
something positive for them in their
lives if it can produce those results
and this is what john roberts wants to
destroy not and actually what george
bush wants to destroy as well now
why do they want to destroy it i think
they want to destroy it for not because
they dislike watching the yukon women's
hoops team you know i think they want to
destroy it for the same reason that they
want to overturn roe versus wade i mean
i think they want to destroy it for the
same reason that that they're actually
trying to roll back everything that a
previous generation ali's generation won
in the streets and i think for that
reason alone it's worth fighting for but
it's also worth fighting for because it
represents an attack on all of us nobody
benefits on this and they tried out all
this garbage about it about um oh it's
just funding teams that don't need to be
there look at the men's crew team they
had to be you know eliminated look at
the men's wrestling team just two facts
for people to leave here with one is
that the number one
budget eater in all of college sports is
football
men's football the budget for men's
football destroys athletic budgets and
men's football is like a lottery if you
roll out a team and you happen to go
11-1 you are going to make millions and
millions and millions if you roll out a
team and you're four and seven you just
created a sieve and your budget is
destroyed and they invest in the chance
of of reaping that kind of money that's
one thing the second thing is that there
is no record anywhere anytime in history
in history
of a woman's team being funded them
rolling out the balls the coach comes
out with the whistle and nobody shows up
that's never happened it shows time and
again if you give people if you give
women the opportunity
to actually practice
athletic arts practice that kind of
freedom of expression with sports they
will grab that time and again
oh
oh final i get a wrap up this is great
um
yeah my child needs shoes no um
no just kidding um no i mean
i'll just say really quickly the most
rewarding thing about doing this book by
a mile
has been people who've come up to me and
said like hey i was never able to have a
political discussion with my dad before
or with my daughter before with my son
before but i gave them this book and
they actually read it
and now we're i mean and now they're
like hey i didn't know this about ali i
didn't know this about billie jean king
and then all of a sudden i realize i'm
talking about civil rights with my dad
i'm talking about anti-racism with my
dad and it's like if you can use sports
as a way to actually talk to people
because i think we live in a country
where politics is a dirty word it's a
bad thing at my job if you're political
to be political and i think that's
because people view politics as what the
two ugly white guys with the bad
haircuts do on c-span and not politics
is what we live and breathe every single
day and that is politics politics are in
art politics are in culture and politics
are in sports and we should not like
walk away from that political arena we
should jump in it with two feet have out
the fights and get a new generation of
people pissed off at the system and get
them to not burn up the cars after
syracuse wins the championship but go
out there and raise some hell about this
war and about this world thank you
dave zirin is a writer for the source
magazine
and a senior writer for basketball.com
what's my name fool is published by
haymarketbooks for more information
visit haymarketbooks.org
terry history that's saturday at 11 30
p.m eastern
next sunday at noon abolition democracy
angela davis on america's treatment of
political prisoners
and at 10 pm eastern take it back paul
begala and james carville on their new
premier for democrats
in the big empty 82 year old norman
mailer answers questions from his 27
year old son john buffalo mailer next
weekend on book tv you can see the
mailers as they address topics ranging
from president bush the iraq war and
corporate culture to boxing cards and
women that's saturday at 10 pm eastern
in sucker punch jack cashel makes the
claim that muhammad ali exaggerated
parts of his biography to create a
grievance narrative at this talk from
the kansas city public library mr cashel
also examines the impact ali's
relationship with islam had on the civil
rights movement this is an hour
i always do really brief introductions
for the guests because we like to spend
as much time as possible with them and
that's certainly true this evening
so tonight our guest is jack castle the
author of hoodwinked for his new book
sucker punch
and so i hope that you will join me in a
warm welcome for mr jack cashel
[Applause]
thank you all for uh coming down to this
lovely building and thanks vivian and
rainy day books for the actually really
extraordinary service they do i don't
think anyone in this area does more for
a local culture than rainy day books and
it's good to see them keeping the
the whole
enterprise of reading alive and well
especially through small bookstores
i want to talk tonight about
essentially about boxing at least on the
surface but i'm really going to be
talking about a deeper subject and that
is how we choose our heroes
and
how those heroes are presented to us
and also finally
how
that presentation changed dramatically
about 40 years ago and blindsided all of
us including the subject of my book
tonight muhammad ali he is not so much
the author of the sucker punch in
question
as the victim
as many of us are and i think as and
finally the nation is i was first
introduced in a serious way to
heavyweight boxing
at the premiere
of on the waterfront i was six years old
this is the film premiere of on the
waterfront the movie
that wasn't the hollywood premiere
exactly
and it wasn't the new york premiere
exactly
and it wasn't even the newark new jersey
premiere exactly what it exactly was was
my neighborhood newark new jersey
premier of on waterfront and given the
humbleness of this premiere at the
tivoli theater on orange street
uh we didn't get marlon brando and we
didn't get carl maldon we didn't even
get eva marie sane or rod steiger both
of whom are from newark
but we got someone actually who is much
better
and that was of course as you all know
tony galento that is two-ton tony
galento just to clarify in case you
don't know who tony galento is he was
the first real celebrity i had ever met
and it was my most exciting celebrity
encounter until
last year when i sat at a table next to
brad pitt at the in the santa monica
restaurant so it was
just incredibly exciting night everyone
in my neighborhood was there
and um
tony tutun tony introduced the film and
in the movie he plays a union goon which
if you know anything about two-ton tony
was not much of a stretch it was sort of
a natural role
when what made it just a little bit
distracting was that every time he came
on the screen which wasn't often
everyone in the theater would go hey
tony you know so this went on six ten
twelve times
but
how could you not like a guy like
two-ton tony glento especially when he
came out of your own neighborhood here's
what he did in his career first of all
he knocked down
in a heavyweight championship fight joe
lewis which is not a inestimable
thing he also fought
to us even more impressively a a bear a
kangaroo and an octopus
now
for the record here's what happened
he beat the bear
he beat the kangaroo
he
lost
a split decision to the octopus because
he fled the tank when it squirted his
inkjets at him this is true story
and once joe lewis got up off the canvas
days that uh really surprised at two-ton
tony put him there he of course whooped
two-ton tony's but but not many guys in
my neighborhood had knocked joe goes
down so that was quite a feat in and of
itself
now
the question is then
i i went back and started looking
and i said to myself how many
uh
books
has uh two-ton tony been the subject of
and i thought this would be an
interesting uh
exercise and just to see what
uh
how famous people are and how fame works
well it turns out
the two-ton tony is the subject of one
book
and it was called galento the great it
was written in 1939
and is 119 pages
now it's not as though he were actually
slighted
because in fact
other boxers are typically not
any more written about than two-ton tony
galento for instance joe frazier how
many books have written about joe
frazier that he didn't write himself
the boxer
one
uh and it's called the joe frazier the
unknown story
understandably you know how many books
are written about george foreman that
aren't cookbooks
one
right
whoa
we planned that that was part of the
excitement here
okay
yes honestly
now the question then becomes is how
many books were written about muhammad
ali
anyone take a guess
108
and i stopped counting i didn't count
books like the fight by norman mailer or
on boxing by joyce carol oates or even
uh
the ghost of manila by mark kram because
they didn't feature solely muhammad ali
that was 108 books that i counted on
amazon about muhammad ali at least 15 or
20 of these are children's books or
books for adolescents i just brought a
couple of them along here
and the theme of these books
is is generally the same and that is
let me just read just from the back uh
this one this is a book for 12 years 12
years of olds and up 12 years of age and
up it says from his childhood in the
segregated south to his current fight
with parkinson's disease ali never
backed down he was banned from boxing
during his prime because he refused to
fight in vietnam he became a symbol of
the anti-war movement and a defender of
civil rights the greatest he was called
he was a boxer of undeniable talent and
courage he took the world by storm only
ali could float like a butterfly and
sting like a bee and this is essentially
the message
that is being uh sold and given to
children throughout the world now
if you're a fan of ali you may not like
a large part of what i'm going to talk
to you about tonight because i'm going
to talk about the third of his life that
he himself is less proud of i'm also
going to talk about the third third of
his life which he's more justifiably
proud of in the first third of his life
which is admirable in many ways but the
middle third was not
uh that notwithstanding the great
majority of books about ali i would say
105 out of 108
just by my own estimation
celebrate the middle third of his life
and
when you look at the way that life is
celebrated for instance
his authoritative biographer uh thomas
houser who wrote muhammad ali life and
times the bible of the ali library
hauser interviewed nearly 200 people and
it's really the without which not of
studying ali's life
he says of ali
he says to some ali was the greatest
hero
to come out of the vietnam war
and that sum
includes thomas hauser
that sum
includes virtually everyone else who
wrote about muhammad ali uh the yale
educated scholar thomas ayatollah when
he's talking about the years 1960 to
1975 he said a year that the period had
damaged virtually all reputations in
america ali was one of the few people to
come out of that era with his reputation
enhanced
and he was actually fairly accurate
about that he did
the question well i'm going to ask is
how
and why
the question i'm going to ask tonight is
how we choose our heroes and why we
chose them
now
what what makes ali's life most
interesting i think is this
is that he had a different take than his
biographers did on that very period of
his life let me just read you some
quotes about how he felt about that
period that he went through roughly
the period that he was in the nation of
islam from essentially 1964 when he
joined officially to 1975 certainly when
elijah muhammad died that was his mentor
his his guru i should say this by the
way just to clarify it there is a big
difference between the nation of islam
under elijah muhammad
and islam
it is something like the difference
between say the ku klux klan
and christianity i mean the one uses the
symbols and but you know appropriates
them in odd different directions the
nation of islam under elijah muhammad
for instance didn't believe in an
afterlife it was more of a social
organization cultural organization than
a religion
uh
for the record
the nation of islam fell dormant for
about three years after elijah muhammad
died and farah khan picked it up i don't
know what it's like today or how it
compares to was under elijah muhammad
but for the reckon i'm talking when i
talk about nation of islam i'm talking
about elijah muhammad's
branch thereof
here's how ali himself talks about his
glory years
he traces his hour of enlightenment to
quote around 1983
that's when he began to see the light
and his own his own perspective
it was only then he said that he became
a quote true believer
i thought i was a true believer but i
wasn't
i fit my religion to do what i wanted
i did things that were wrong and chased
women all the time
i conquered the world and it didn't
bring me true happiness
the only true satisfaction
comes from honoring and worshiping god
this is what he the conclusion he came
to in about 1983 and since then he's
lived his life
i'd say according to that fairly nobly i
mean he's born his cross but i could use
that word
pretty gracefully now to show you what a
great transition he made in 1983
in 1984 he shows up publicly
at
of all places
and this is something that his
mythologizers have totally suppressed
the republican national convention as a
ronald reagan supporter in 1988 he
supported george h.w bush
and he was a big fan of arlen specter
now this is for the i you know the
mythologizers of uh muhammad ali's is
fairly embarrassing but it's testament
to how dramatic a transition he made in
his life it was real
this is a guy who a few years earlier
was i'll tell you what he was saying
this is a stunning admission it should
inform everything that's been written
about muhammad ali but it hasn't
the people who continue to write about
muhammad ali act as though
he did not have his own road to damascus
moment it's as if you were writing about
saint paul and all you talked about was
his christian bashing and you celebrated
it
come and think of it all he did his fair
share of that but
they continue to celebrate it it's as if
you're writing about saint augustine
i mean the confessions of saint
augustine if anyone's read that i mean
what makes the book interesting is how
he lived his life before he
he had his moment
but the book doesn't celebrate his
carousing and his whoring and is running
around
the authors of ali books continue to do
that as though he never had a moment of
coming to allah
a more likely analysis is in a more
complex analysis
is
malcolm x
now malcolm x and i'm going to tell you
a little bit about the history of
muhammad ali and malcolm x because it it
actually uh
shapes ali's life it shapes the whole
history of racial relations in america
malcolm x was a member of the nation of
islam under elijah muhammad he was uh
in a sense guided by the same man who
would guide muhammad ali
malcolm x was a more formidable
character than ali he was older wiser
smarter and more self-determined
however
here's what he says about his 12 years
under elijah muhammad and these 12 years
didn't end until essentially late 1963
or always 1964 a year before he died
he says
i was a
zombie then
like all muslims i was hypnotized
pointed in a certain direction and told
to march
well i guess a man is entitled to make a
fool of himself if he's ready to pay the
cost
it cost me 12 years this is malcolm x on
elijah muhammad's nation of islam and
his 12 years there what we celebrate
about malcolm x's life
is really the last year of his life
when he broke from the nation of islam
when he began to see that white people
weren't blue-eyed devils necessarily
when he stopped waiting for
the big-headed yakub and the spaceship
circling earth to come down and destroy
the white race when he finally realized
in the last weeks and months of his life
as he told
his biographer alex haley that
brotherhood is the only answer and this
is inclusion he didn't come to the last
year of his life his life is worth
studying and worth honoring because of
that last year not because of the 12
years
when he was a zombie it wouldn't make
sense
however in ali's case we celebrate the
zombie period
it's just one of those things
now
uh
malcolm x isn't the only one who gives a
witness to this period of ollie's life
what i did in uh doing the book i
realized that sports writers and
generals tend to write about their own
experiences what they've seen and heard
and there's a whole library of books
about ali that go unread
or unsolicited or uncommented on for
instance
virtually every major fighter
in the late 20th century wrote an
autobiography a lot of them had contact
with ali some of these books are
incredibly illuminating most notably
archie moore's sugar ray robinsons floyd
pattersons
you know larry holmes george foreman
they all had contact and they all shed a
lot of light on it
one woman who sheds an awful lot of
light on ali's period his zombie period
was his first wife sonya
whom he married in 1964.
when they divorced she said
she wanted a man who was quote who would
be his own master
and from her perspective that was not
the young muhammad ali
as she would tell jack olsen in sports
illustrated they've stolen my man's mind
this is the critical period of his life
they've stolen my man's mind now howard
cassell who plays a really interesting
role in
uh and a critical role in ali's
essential eventual acceptance
and he's also constantly speaking out of
both sides of his mouth so it's hard to
figure out exactly what he's saying but
in this case
on the question of the draft always
cosell writes ali bent neither to
pressure nor friendly overture
but then one page later
he's quoted as saying
uh he quotes ugly as saying can't talk
to you no more not without elijah's
permission
and then kasel comments
this was simply further evidence of the
degree of control
the muslims exercised over ali
now ali's no-nonsense aunt who spoke
unlike kasell out of only one side of
her mouth
and his ants are great because they're
such straight shooters
she says of her nephew
he was brainwashed
he's going to mess himself up so won't
nobody go see him
now
uh
this book isn't uh as i said earlier
it's not really about muhammad ali it's
about how we have come to choose that
period of ali's life and make it heroic
now
there is um
one
two things that happened uh one is
general it happened at that period one
is specific to ali that make for the
transformation of ali the brainwashed
the man who had his mind stolen into a
national hero
the other one is specific dolly the
general one i describe in the book as
what i call the grievance narrative
now
the grievance narrative essentially
develops in america probably in the
early part of the 20th century but only
in special cases like the case of sacco
and benzetti come to mind where these
were two guys were guilty of shooting a
payroll clerk in massachusetts there
were two anarchists but when they were
tried they realized that their best
defense was to throw themselves on the
mercy of the court to let the court know
that they were anarchists that they were
you know they were being persecuted
because they were italian immigrants
they're anarchists etc uh but that's not
the truth it wasn't the way it was that
remained in the background for about 40
years it really wasn't until the 1960s
that the grievance narrative became
normative became more or less the norm
and it's become more or less since then
now in the grievance narrative um what
you see
is uh
historically you would have a story a
hero would be someone who faced
obstacles as a young man or a young
woman overcame those obstacles and
through perseverance and hard work went
on to become a hero of some sort by
doing good deeds the grievance narrative
had different take on it instead of
overcoming obstacles and hardships and
injustices you nursed them like grudges
and they became you and you you sort of
soaked them in and they were who you
were so uh and then instead of
overcoming them because there was no
overcoming them in a world with uh that
was dictated by
uh institutional racism and structural
poverty what you did is you asked for a
collective reordering of society
so in other words
there was no individual accomplishment
in this world it was a collective
accomplishment done through
the nursing the airing of the grievance
and when you write a grievance narrative
when you write a typical narrative
heroic narrative what you try to inspire
in your audience is a sense of
accomplishment and joy and hope when you
write a grievance narrative which you
try to instill is a sense of of guilt
and anger and that's that's the way the
grievance narrative works now
i'm going to take a quick sip of water
here
and then i'm going to talk as while i'm
drinking this water
i'm just watching a
an edgar bergen movie the other night i
was watching i was amazed at well he did
that
that's the
father of candice bergen for those who
care
um
the
here's a classic sentence in the way the
grievance narrative works it's from
joyce carol oates's book unboxing now
joyce carlos by the way is obviously
national book award winner noted author
she's also a heck of a boxing writer
she's no dileton she writes extremely
well and extremely knowledgeably on the
subject of boxing
on the subject of the culture in general
however she's uh
locked into the grievance narrative and
and here's what she says about the very
first sentence
about muhammad ali in her biographical
sketch of ali
ali and i'm going to invite you to tell
me what is the the one phrase in here
that sticks out
that's beyond the
the expected
muhammad ali born casious marcellus clay
in louisville kentucky on january 17
1942
grandson of a slave
began boxing at the age of 12
and by 18 had fought 108 amateur bouts
which one phrase in there
doesn't seem to belong that's beyond the
obvious let me read that again for you
muhammad ali born caseis marcellus clay
in louisville kentucky on january 17
1942 grandson of a slave began boxing at
the age of 12 and by 18 it fought 108
amateur bouts
grandson of a slave
i mean why is that particularly relevant
uh for instance and this is the
grievance narrative really kicks in in
the middle of the of the 60s in 1961
jack newcomb wrote a very smart book
about floyd patterson then the reigning
heavyweight champion
in which he doesn't mention the fact at
all that floyd patterson was a
descendant of slaves
he doesn't even mention the fact he
doesn't even mention the race of any one
of floyd patterson's opponents
he does not mention floyd patterson's
race that's 1961.
in 1963
ali i mean
martin luther king in the famous march
on washington would would make the
stirring comment about we're not
interested in calling your skin but the
content your character the nation of
islam called the march on washington the
farce on washington
they were turning this direction back
and it was a pretty dramatic change
joyce carol oates plays right into it
the grandson of a slave
you ask yourself is there no other
better interesting more interesting way
to introduce him how about his parents
why not why talk about whose
grandparents were one of his parents
he had a loving mother and a skilled
muralist for a father who is a
professional sign painter
why not talk about his aunt who is a
math teacher or his uncle who is a
mathematician which may account for
ali's intuitive smarts
why not talk about
the fact that he was an oldest son and a
two child ambitious middle-class
uh african-american family in louisville
kentucky this is all thrown away because
we're focusing on the grievance the
grandson of a slave
why not talk about
ali's childhood compared to other
childhoods of famous heavyweight
champions
i'm just going to run through a few of
them for you ali remember second of two
children i mean the first of two
children middle class home
jack dempsey ninth of 13 father an
itinerant drunk who took them all across
the country
joe lewis the seventh child of a
sharecropper who was sent to an insane
islam in age two his mother married into
a guy with seven children of her own the
14 of them
kids and two parents moved to detroit
just in time for the depression
um
let's talk about some others how about
uh floyd patterson himself floyd
patterson shared his bed with more
brothers than ali had
he was uh
one of uh i think he was the third of 11
children dirt poor brooklyn family cold
water flats he'd been arrested 30 times
by the age of 10 and sent to reform
school
that was floyd patterson's upbringing
um sunny liston
sunny listens makes the previous one
sound like
you know andy hardy
he was the 22nd child of a vicious
arkansas sharecropper sonny liston says
the only thing i ever got from my father
was a weapon
he left home at 15 and for a life of of
almost primal thuggery until he was
rescued by a catholic priest in the
jefferson city prison
uh rocky marciano the second of seven
children his father was a italian
immigrant who volunteered to fight in
world war one was gassed in the argonne
forest and never recovered he eked out a
meagre living in brockton massachusetts
shoe factory
none of these guys
muhammad ali graduated from high school
none of these guys even went to high
school i'm sorry
marciano went two years
um
even into the present times when you
look at guys like
joe frazier and this is the ones that
hurts the most and the one that's most
telling the 12th
child of a
south carolina moonshiner one-armed
moonshiner living in gullah country in
south carolina which is the part of
america closest in spirit to the african
homeland and he's younger than ali
george foreman who's seven years younger
than ali the fifth of seven children a
child of a texas sharecropper who was
out on the streets by the time he was
12. when they he fought ali in uh
in the rumble in the jungle in zaire
they asked him the news people asked him
they said how do you feel about fighting
at three or four o'clock in the morning
and george foreman answered without even
kidding he said most of my fights have
been at three or four o'clock in the
morning
these are tough lives i mean larry
holmes
seventh grade education one of twelve
mike tyson and it's a tragic case there
he was on the streets of time at 12 just
like floyd patterson 30 or 40 arrests
sent to upstate home in in new york
state to to find himself these were hard
childhoods and yet of all their
autobiographies only one is a grievance
narrative
and it's muhammad ali's
one other date one other factor that
joyce carlos might have talked about is
the date he was born january 17 1942
what was the world like in january 17
1942 this is six weeks after pearl
harbor
um
how many children in january 7 1942
think about this how many children who
are born on january 7 1942
were born into a modern hospital had her
father pick him up in his own car drive
them home to a house with indoor
plumbing hot and cold running water
electricity and no bombs falling through
the roof
i'd say about two out of every
two or three out of every 100 children
in the world were born that blessed
in uh the year 1942. now let's face it
there are
ali's father and his family face all
kinds of maddening indignities growing
up in the border south pre-civil rights
but at the same time there was a lot to
be grateful for and historically people
were grateful for it
and the traditional grievance and the
traditional heroic narrative when it
deals with race
the racial awareness moment comes when
the hero
realizes that the other race
is not bad is not all evil is good
potentially good this goes both ways
black white it goes you know israeli
palestinian it goes you know belgian
french it goes every possible way
whenever two races come together a
classic case is archie moore
his book and now archie moore knows a
whole lot more about racism than
muhammad ali ever did fighting in
midwest and southern tank towns in the
30s and 40s
his book is called any boy ken
right his autobiography any boy can
and his moment of racial awareness comes
when he's he and his manager is also
black have a car accident terrible
accident in oklahoma on the side of the
road he's bleeding to death
a couple of uh young interns just
happened by white
uh with their dates
they take them into the car and drive
them like 80 miles to the nearest
hospital and archie moore's saying but
i'm bleeding i don't want to bleed all
over your car and they said come on
don't be serious and they take them and
at that moment archie moore said no he
goes not all white people are bad i
can't think that way there's good and
bad in every race that is the typical
hero narrative
and the grievance narrative is just the
opposite and the grievance narrative you
learn that all races are kind of
terrible
oh by the way there's one other problem
with uh
uh joyce carlos calling ali the grandson
of a slave you know what that is
he's not the grandson of a slave
he's not i mean he's 77 he was born 77
years after the passage of the 13th
amendment of course he's not a grandson
of a slave but when you're doing a
grievance narrative things don't have to
be true you can embellish and you can
you can make stuff up because typically
uh the people who care aren't going to
check and in her case why bother
checking and grandson of a slave just
sounds so much better than great
grandson of a slave and besides some of
his great grandparents at least two of
them were white one of them came from
ireland
abe grady i mean he married his uh
his mother's grandmother dinah this is
after uh
after the end of the civil war
and which is probably a pretty brave
thing to do is not his his parents his
aunts and uncles were equally proud of
their white ancestors they were their
black ancestors but not in a grievance
narrative that's all now it's all rape
and defilement
okay
in the grievance narrative and in my
book hoodwink by the way and if you're
interested
it's
castle.com
www.casual.com find that and others um
i talk about a series of of made up and
manufactured lives uh ward churchill the
guy who passed as an indian for his
entire professional career because no
one bothered the checking edward saeed
probably the most significant figure in
the multicultural movement the father of
orientalism who passed himself off as a
palestinian refugee for his entire
career when in fact he was an american
citizen an episcopalian born in a lap of
luxury in cairo and educated american
prep schools from the age of 12 on
or rigoberta menchu who was
a nobel prize winner from guatemala who
in her grievance narrative has her
brother and 20 others
you know indians being burned to death
in a town square an anthropologist stops
on upon the crown the town square just
innocently and says hey isn't this where
brigoberto manchu's brother was burned
to death
with 20 other people and some old guy
says no
and the anthropologist says are you sure
and the guy says in a small town we'd
remember if they burned 20 people to
death in the town square no it never
happened the whole book was a
fabrication she still has her nobel
prize in the grievance narrative you're
allowed to make stuff up
so what happens to the young already
when does he begin to to start making
stuff up when does his life become a
grievance
well in 1960
when he became my hero when he won uh
the light heavyweight uh medal in the
olympics in rome
he came back
a russian journalist tried to provoke
him in rome about racial problems in
america here's what ali said
tell your readers and it's a wonderful
sentence written in sort of perfect
mid-continent rotarian patois you know
it's a tell your readers we got
qualified people working on that problem
and i'm not worried about the outcome
that was muhammad ali in 1960 and what a
wonderful statement that was because
it's pretty much true at least to the
degree that there could be an outcome in
it but the qualified people were working
on it let's face it they were some of
them were paying with their lives in
their heads but they were working on it
he returns to louisville after winning
the olympic gold the whole town turns
out for him white and black uh the mayor
they give him the keys to the city his
father when he comes home he paints the
stairway red white and blue and sings
the star-spangled banner for the
surrounding crowd this is in 1960.
um
he is the happiest kid alive the a group
of
wealthy white uh millionaires from
louisville get together and form a
sponsoring group and they give him the
best and fairest starting contract any
young boxer has ever had and included in
that is a ten thousand dollar signing
bonus equivalent about seventy thousand
dollars today and a brand new cadillac
so here's muhammad ali in 1960
he's got a cadillac he's got sponsors
he's got six thousand fans showing up
his first fight in louisville as a 19
year old he's got loving parents a
middle class home great friends uh and
he's on the the cutting edge of really
breaking through racially in america
he's the coolest of our cold war heroes
for kids like myself i was 12.
what happens
well
in the grievance narrative you've got to
create a scenario where something bad
happens
because it can't be just he changes his
mind or he falls under the thrall of
elijah muhammad they've got to make
something up and the vehicle for making
that up was a book called the greatest
which was
muhammad ali's autobiography which came
out in 1975 excuse me a second
and
here's has anyone read the greatest or
seen the movie that was made of that
at the time it was pretty popular book
it sold lots of copies the movie was
made regular hollywood feature it
starred in addition to muhammad ali
playing himself which is a little
ludicrous uh james earl jones robert
duvall and you know regular cast george
benson sang the theme song famous song
more famous than a movie actually
here's what happens in a movie and in
the book let me start with the book
uh
he comes back from
louisville he comes back from the
olympics he's in louisville it's
muhammad ali
shortly after he comes back he goes to a
diner with his friend ronnie they're on
their motor scooters and they ask to be
served
the
owner of the diner even though he has
his gold medal on turns him down
uses as many vile racial slurs as he
could possibly think of as all the
patrons of the diner the two of them
leave the diner to be confronted by a
motorcycle gang clad in swastikas and
confederate flags the motorcycle gang
chases them over to the
the uh a bridge over the
ohio river and uh
a dozen or so of them attacked muhammad
ali and his friend and somehow muhammad
ali and his friend prevail and they beat
these guys up uh
frog and kentucky slim were the two
leaders of the motorcycle gang they wimp
off ali says then this whole thing this
whole american dream this whole gold
medal it's all a fraud and he takes his
gold medal and he drops it into the
middle of the ohio river that's what the
book says
in the movie version it's a little toned
down
even though the movie was written
screenplay by ring larner jr sort of a
unrepentant stalinist of the hollywood
ten stage
uh that was a little too much for him so
he tones it down to the they get
insulted in the restaurant go off to the
bridge drop the gold medal into the
middle of the ohio river now either one
of these stories is true and one's not
but in fact neither of them is true
this myth didn't materialize until
several years later early
the people who were around ali early in
those years
testified that he wore the metal until
it just you know the the gold came off
and he wore his usa boxing trunks in his
first bout this is all made up
tony morrison ghost wrote his
autobiography it's not every boxer has a
nobel prize winner writing his
autobiography she may have thought it
was true it was being dictated by
herbert muhammad the book
um
it's
the corruption this literary corruption
starts at the top and we're worried
about jamie frye i mean come on
here's what the editor-in-chief of
random house says the random house
published the book by the way the new
york times called the book honest and
convincing
editor-in-chief james silverman if you
check winston's churchill's version of
history you'd find it somewhat at odds
with other versions by historians
so he compares it to wins and
churchill's books uh
the book is what the book is and why
it's not just fraudulent but
destructively so is it what it tells
young people young black people
especially is that
life is going to be filled with racism
even if you're the light heavyweight
champion in the world there's no hope
for you
now in the book also
they and in a movie they do this too
when ali comes back after his exile in
1971 to fight
uh jury quarry in his first fight in
atlanta
uh he's out living in a house in uh
a center state senator's house outside
of atlanta and a group of ku klux klan
or someone come and start shooting at
them and and trying to drive them away
bandini ali's faithful friend comes out
shooting and they and scares them away
none of this ever happened this is all
made up but what they're telling
what they're reinforcing is the nation
of islam message at this time that
nothing's changed even now in 1971 after
the passage of the civil rights act and
the voting right to accent even after
ali has established himself as a
national hero nothing's changed the
grievances continue to to fester
here's what historian thomas italia says
about the motorcycle gang fight on the
bridge right
totally bizarre and fabricated
while inaccurate in detail the story was
metaphorically true
no it was metaphorically false and it
was false in detail everything about it
was false it was false and it was
destructively false but that's the way
the grievance narrative works
what really happened to ali
what really happened is unfortunate and
it's sort of prosaic but he went to
miami because he couldn't he never
worked the job in his life his his
management team first sent them out to
work with archie moore
and
california archie moore's place was
called the salt mine it made people work
in addition to uh actually boxing ali
wanted none of it so they sent them down
to miami to train with angelo dundee and
dundee just said hey you just do your
thing in the ring whatever you do
outside is you're doing outside he's 18
years old ferdie pacheco who is the ring
doctor says he was a ship adrift
rudderless without a captain but now
listening to the wisdom of the old man
ali saw the way the old man was elijah
muhammad he fell under the sway of the
nation of islam where i was alone in
adrift in miami as an 18 19 year old and
they worked very hard on him they
surrounded him 24 7. and there was one
other tragedy in ali's life that was not
well known at the time and then made him
particularly vulnerable to the nation of
islam
he was illiterate he couldn't read
despite the fact that he graduated from
high school he graduated from high
school because he was a teacher's pet
they loved him
he also by the way graduated from high
school of virgin and he fainted on his
first kiss this had an andy hardy
childhood but
alone in the drift in miami unable to
read beyond the headline and barely that
all the information in 1961 too is
coming to you through print
or else people are telling you stuff and
the nation of islam just filled his head
with stuff stuff stuff stuff 24 7 stuff
um and it wasn't just a temporary
situation and this is a a very difficult
part of his life
when um
he joins the nation of islam uh
formally in 1964 and you know in name
they give him uh iskacius clay then
joins nation of islam next day they
announce his joining you know a name
they give him trivia question
anyone it's keisha's ex a quick trivia
question he's keisha's ex for about a
month and he becomes muhammad ali
um
when kesha clay joined the black muslims
he became a champion of racial
segregation and that is what we are
fighting against you know what says that
martin luther king
it's in 1964.
um you know the one senator
in uh
in washington who went on to the floor
of the senate to defend ali's choice
to join the nation of islam i'm going to
read what he says
cases clay in common with 180 million
other american citizens has the right to
join the religious activist choice
without being blackmailed harassed and
threatened
that was the arch segregationist georgia
senator richard russell the one who came
to
ali's offense this is what it was like
in 1964 when he joined
and this was not just a temporary
aberration
when he was interviewed by playboy as
late as 1975. this is the year that
elijah muhammad died and and ali begins
to regain himself
um
he's asked by the interviewer if he
thought lynching was the answer to
interracial sex
whether
interracial couples should be lynched he
answered
a black man should be killed if he's
messing with a white woman it's 1975. he
also said that in reverse with white men
blackman
at the same interview he said america
don't have no future america is going to
be destroyed
in 1978 he was asked about equality for
females he said someone's got to wear
the pants and someone's got to wear the
dress there isn't going to be any
equality it's 1978
now
the in the grievance narrative when
there's information you don't like you
suppress it and that's essentially what
they did here
and
the
there are certain things though that
were very difficult to suppress
one thing
was the um
relationship with malcolm x and this was
very troubling uh and this is a story
that
most boxing writers know about they just
don't want to talk about malcolm x had
nurtured the young ali
through his early period and he took a
particular interest in him elijah
mohammed was backing off a little bit
because they thought he was going to
lose the sonny liston
and when he did not as soon as he won
the fight against honey listen the first
fight against sunny listen elijah
muhammad called him and said listen i'm
going to make you a member of the nation
of islam i'm going to give you the name
muhammad ali an arabic name something
malcolm x doesn't even have if you do
one thing
and that is you have to sever your
relationship
with malcolm x
and that's what he did so he dropped
malcolm x colt even though malcolm x was
the only one in ringside that night the
only one who stayed with him and it gets
worse uh immediately after that
the nation of islam elijah muhammad put
a fatwa on malcolm x's head they went
out to kill him
not only him but leon forex amir who was
malcolm x's uh who's loyal to malcolm x
within a year both of them would be dead
about a few weeks
before
malcolm x was murdered in the audubon
ballroom in 1965
february february 21st
his wife came to ali she found him in
harlem at the teresa hotel and said you
see what you're doing to my husband
don't you
and
he raised his hands in his hair and said
i'm not doing anything to him
now that's what the average 22 or 23
year old might do i mean he's scared to
death and he has reason to be scared to
death i'm i don't have anything to do
with him
but the hero of children's books we
expect more of and that's that's part of
the tragedy of this whole story how did
this come to be
and then uh to answer the question
that's the the grievance narrative is
the thing the general topic that made
the story worth telling the specific
thing to ali and this is the amazing
thing the thing that
caused the media to embrace and by 65 66
67 he was getting booted every fight
he got booed at the second sunday listen
fight and sonny listen was the least
popular champ of all time what is it
that caused america to embrace muhammad
ali
at this period
and it's an amazing kind of answer
he dodged the draft
this is a really astonishing thing when
you go back into it and say how did
dodging the draft make him a hero here's
what happened in 1967 there's a changing
of the guard in america's newsroom just
about to take place
and the young writers saw in ali to this
point their movement had been lily white
they were embarrassed by that they were
being accused of being cowardly and
yellow and weak and not
having courage and then all of a sudden
they saw in muhammad ali their best
selves they began to celebrate not so
much muhammad ali but themselves
and that is essentially how they began
to change the image of ali when the
older writers retired the newer guys
especially the new guys in broadcasting
and
tv
began to change and take ali with him by
the time ali comes back in 1971
he's a hero
and it's astonishing to watch this take
place and there's no really other reason
for it because on the racial front he
hadn't changed
but to the people who were celebrating
themselves
their newly splendidly liberated selves
they really didn't care about race
they really cared about
their own image as portrayed in muhammad
ali and then all of a sudden was a
celebration okay you see he's in favor
of lynching interracial couples you know
african homeland america america is a
terrible place
and wasn't that an issue anymore
so
and then what happens uh
after that you know most of that story
and i'm going to leave a lot of that to
you to follow in the book
but
when he comes back
he um
runs into a series of situations that
caused him to
position himself against white america
and he makes the unwitting
representative of white america none
other than joe frazier the 12th child of
a south carolina moonshiner and from
gullah country who left home at 15 by
himself on the greyhound worked in a
meatpacking plant became the model for
sylvester stallone's rocky in many ways
and then found himself in 1971
as a white man and the media turned not
only against joe frazier but they turned
against everyone who rooted for joe
frazier uh jerry eisenberger you know
famous sports writer would say 25 years
later
today you'd be hard-pressed to find
anybody the guy who would have to be a
died in the wool nazi who doesn't feel
that ollie's stand on vietnam was
understandable and basically justified
um
or another writer in 1999 a british
writer the people who wanted frasier to
beat ali this is mike marxie
were the die-hard racist the love it or
leave it brigade the people who resented
everything ali stood for
so in 1971 weeks before uh the fraser
ali fight the media give that part of
white america its own hero and archie
bunker ten years earlier than ralph
cramden that's what they that said it
changed they had polarized and divided
and they used ugly as a point in the
polarization division it didn't get
better
in the second half of the book
i talk about the consequences of the
myth and what happens to it and i'll
i'll leave that to you to find out but i
just like in the first part rather than
just telling a story about heroes and
myths
the the world of boxing is so filled
with great and and powerful stories that
i'd rather tell it through the stories
and in the second half i tell it through
the person of mike tyson which is really
one of the most tragic and unfortunate
and unnecessary stories in our time it
didn't have to happen what happened to
him and it was
uh in a sense very
much the result of what happened with
ali in the 60s and 70s the whole
racialization of boxing the creation of
don king and the exploitation of
everyone who've gotten don king's way
and with that i think
i'm going to tell just one last thing an
example of a story we should be telling
to school children then i'll turn it
over to questions
um
here's the story i would tell if i were
to pick one story to talk about in the
last 50 years of heavyweight boxing
i would tell the extraordinary story
of george foreman
think about this story here's a guy
who's fifth of seven children his father
isn't really his father he hates him
from the beginning battered beaten
abused out on the streets he's saved by
an
unusual combination of a loving mother
and the job core you know the first
success story the job corps ever had
in 1968
when everyone when the black fist in the
air is the uh the popular thing he goes
into the ring and waves a small american
flag and endeared himself at that time
to a good chunk of america he still was
seriously adrift for the next bunch of
years he was
surly and sullivan and self-absorbed and
and
just not himself not who he would become
he gets beat by alien to rumble the
jungle a year later he has a genuine
come to jesus moment i mean a virtual
out of body come to jesus moment
and then instead of just talking about
helping people and just talking about
you know doing good he quits at the peak
of his career he's 28 years old and
becomes a street corner preacher in
houston
and then
people begin to take him seriously
because he's good at it and then he
realizes to reach youth he has to start
a community center so he takes all of
his money and he opens a community
center with his brother in houston and
he's reaching youth and then he's
running out of money so he says what am
i going to do
well i'll go back and make one more stab
at the heavyweight championship
at the age of 45
uh
he fights michael moorer and if you
believe in i mean this is if you don't
believe in god this is luck if you
believe in god this is god he loses the
first nine rounds and then in the tenth
round he finds himself and he knocks a
you know more out like you know he's
getting more it's the camera's like a
sack oats he's gone
um
foreman gets down on his knees and prays
well if he was really praying pretty
hard because right after that the sultan
company approaches
george foreman with the single most
inspired idea in sports marketing
history
the george foreman grill
he sells you how many cop how many forms
george woman girls was sold
70 million
george foreman girls
after several years
the sultan company says you know this is
costing us too much money let's buy
forming out you know how much they have
to pay to buy a mound
137 million dollars uh that brings his
total to 250 million dollars
which he pours back into his youth
center right now this is a story that
kids should be tall and it works on
every level but this is not the story
they're being told
and uh what i'm here for tonight is just
to to try to inject back into the
american narrative stories that are
ennobling and inspiring and they're
powerful and they're positive rather
than asking people to nurse their
grievances for the rest of the 21st
century uh the people who tell those
stories obviously is one reason they
don't tell them
because none of them have a george
foreman lean mean fat grilling machine
thank you
why don't we take some questions here
[Applause]
yes sir
stand up yeah sure
how much of the joe frazier stuff with
ali was real animosity and how much of
it was arnold bailey uh joe frazier
thinks it was all real animosity because
in in both the uh in the first fight
uh in 1971 the fight of the century uh
they already had their guarantees in in
the bank they each got 2.5 million
dollars for it and that was guaranteed
frazier never forgave ali frazier is the
one person who is
he's gotten better in the last few years
but if you read his 1996 autobiography
uh he's angry because in 74 71 he
portrays him as a white man by the time
they get to the uh the third fight and
manila the thrill in manila he's
portraying him as a gorilla
and uh and that just rubbed it hurt him
i mean even his hometown of philadelphia
fraser became a pariah uh and it was
difficult so uh part of it was stick
though it just got out of hand it just
got it just got ugly
any questions comments
yes back here
i'm curious how you you came to the idea
of talking about heroes what's kind of
inspiring you writing this book
um you know it was actually meeting
two-ton tony galento
i don't know you know i mean if you grew
up as a sports fan
uh and and part of the book is
semi-autobiographical and i didn't get
into this too much but i grew up in
newark new jersey which was a city in
full collapse in the mid 60s and there's
a famous story
uh and it may be true
where there's a black man on death row
in the 30s
and just as they're ready to pull the
switch
he's yells out save me joe lewis save me
right
and it's really poignant and kind of sad
but in in mid 60s newark when i was a
kid
and ali was in kesha's clay slash
muhammad ali was out there
we almost saw him as the person like
save his quesabas i mean who's a person
who transcended race
and in his dealings with with people
he has always been great
you know i mean and i don't mean to run
him down entirely because he's
charismatic and he was bigger than life
and all of my friends
we you know we listened to that first
sunday listen fight on the radio as our
lives depended on it we were afraid he
was going to get killed and i stuck with
him all the way through 67 all the way
until he went off into the draft it was
getting harder and harder because
there's a lot more i have not seen not
here
but
i think when you're a kid especially
especially in a troubled time and place
heroes are very important
and that was part of what my motivation
was
yes sir what inspired uh ali to look
into and explore politics and uh
consequently what uh where the did the
republicans exploit his interest yes the
republicans explained his interest in
fact it's a it's funny when you read it
thomas houser's book and it's the
authorized biography and it's very
comprehensive and when he reaches the
part where ali shows up in the
republican national convention he
prefaces it by saying and then another
problem arose right
and then he interviews people like
julian bond and whatnot and they're all
horrified you know but they pushed this
one to bed very quickly ali this was a
problem in a sense with his being uh
illiterate is that he was very um
subject to uh manipulation by people
including orrin hatch you know frankly
and there was some lawyer who was
pulling his strings at the time i don't
know that he's a sincere republican i
mean i mean he could have been you know
in the sense that by 1984 he didn't
drink dance you know or uh
run around and he would be a very
god-fearing person it could have been a
member of the moral majority for all i
know but
it doesn't seem like it was a genuine
commitment to republican politics nor
was it genuine before that
again he was being led by elijah
muhammad
yes what do you admire most about it
what do i admire most i would say what i
admire most is his post how how
gracefully he's born uh the burden he's
had to bear i mean he's done that i
think very well and very uh
admirably uh he doesn't have parkinson's
disease by the way he has what's called
pugilistic parkinson's which is he's
been hit too many times and
part in a sense you became the victim of
his own myth because his the
mythologizer said fight once more fight
once more you're doing it for the people
you know your peace justice love vietnam
and he fought about six years longer
than he should have
uh but
knowing that and and he knows that
uh you don't see him complain you don't
see him you know gripe about it he's
gone back to the sort of sweet innocent
kid he once was in louisville yeah so
as far as i could tell anyhow it seems
pretty sincere
yes sir
you talk about the apotheosis by the
journalistic lab of muhammad ali
and it took a willful suspension
disbelief because
as late as 1968 to 1969 he appeared at
the joint press conference
with a member of the klu klux klan the
two of them there to denounce the mixing
of the races yeah right it took a lot of
uh overlooking stuff
in fact the the
elijah muhammad's nation of islam was
always comfortable with the ku klux klan
just like marcus garvey was you know 50
years old you want to go back to africa
sure that's fine with us
uh the thing they don't talk about here
for instance is that when he fought for
first came back from his exile do you
know which governor finally gave him
permission to fight
it's lester maddox in georgia
uh
so that the nation of islam was had a
very cozy relationship and and shelby
steele talks about this very uh
knowledgeable he's a black uh social
theorist author of
content of our character and other books
but he talks about it as creating his
own a decency so if you're a white
reporter
you put yourself in the zone of decency
and you put other white people outside
of it so joyce carol oates for instance
and other authors several of them are
constantly referring to white america
and so joyce carlos says how shabbily
white america treated muhammad ali as
though what she's not white
you know as though she's someone else or
someone different they do that all the
time and so and and this kind of
would shelby steele calls redemptive
liberalism as opposed to real
civil rights liberalism where you get
your heads banged in you don't care
about race other than to make yourself
feel good and so who cares what happens
to mike tyson as long as i feel good
about it you know and that's what it
comes down to i'll ask
i think we have time for one more
question yes
in these days of uh
especially in religious tensions
especially what we're dealing with right
now and racial relations as well how how
well do you see this brook
book being perceived in the community
especially in america but even around
the world um
i hope that it's my hope is that it will
be perceived and then it will generate
some discussion and it's not an easy
book i mean if someone came to kansas
city and wrote a book about
george brett having a creepy period i'd
probably be thinning i don't want to
hear this get out of here
but then george brett never presented
himself to the world as the greatest or
as the liberator of the world or is the
henry kissinger like muhammad ali did
jimmy carter never sent george brett on
a mission to africa to represent america
um
i think we have to overcome that
instinctive uh reluctance to hear
the truth and what i've heard so far
from people you know not everyone likes
what i've said i was on a show in
philadelphia they were they had on
muhammad ali's daughter one of his
daughters and that was not i don't argue
with people's daughters um
and i don't blame her for defending her
father and i didn't mean to be attacking
informally but until we begin to look at
the subject honestly and no one has yet
said to me this isn't true
a few boxing writers said oh everyone
knows all this well everyone may know it
well why don't you share it
i mean all boxing writers may know this
and they did they just didn't share it
and that's the problem is we've got to
get beyond
closing ourselves off to contrary
information
and i think if we do that we can begin
to make some progress but for the last
40 years we've skidded sideways because
it's so hard to have an honest
conversation i think we have time for
one or two more questions uh so anyone
else wants to raise your hand
yes sir i was fascinated by your comment
about the floyd patterson book and
no mention of of black or white race
whatsoever right
comment please on the possible negative
ramifications of the civil rights
movement in that we now seem to always
talk about and perceive and with regards
to race whereas
the floyd patterson book might might be
that we just didn't even bother to think
in those terms well we did it's just
that the movement up until that time and
this was the early civil rights movement
the movement was away from racial
consciousness and i think that climax in
63 at the at the
martin luther king's speech and the 64
with the
civil rights bill 65 with the voting
rights act what happened after that
is i think is that the the civil rights
act movement was hijacked by
people who were more interested in
self-aggrandizement than in actual civil
rights and and that's why we've skidded
sideways and in the classic case of this
is
what happens with mike tyson and don
king
and just quickly
tyson grows up with this extraordinarily
feral child in the streets of brooklyn
now probably the most difficult child in
america at that time he sent to a boy's
home in upstate new york
um
there
he's discovered at a 13 year old by
customato who also had discovered floyd
patterson
and custom otto sees him as a 13 year
old and he says to him if you want to be
you're going to be the heavyweight
champion of the world
and he takes him out as a 14 year old he
and his woman he's living with and this
big happy boxing family in catskill new
york they literally adopt him they bring
him home
and tyson's never had any family or
parents or anything is any any he calls
these people his parents
joyce carol oates writing about him
and when he's 18 years old says this is
the first boxer who has the chance to
transcend race this is what joyce carlos
says all of his fans were white and when
you go back and read about the young
mike tyson it's hard to believe
uh how much hope and promise there was
in this young guy
he was
you know like floyd patterson he was
just borderline personality because his
life had been so difficult customato
dies don king swoops in and to get him
away from his management team he starts
praying on them racially you don't want
to work with these jews in suits do you
no come with me you know support the
black man
and just sort of steals him away
and then just leads him downhill so
quick and so fast mike tyson didn't know
what happened to him and he ends up in
and japan fighting buster douglas
totally unprepared who loses 42 to one
shot
and then from there on in it's
downhill downhill downhill and it didn't
have to happen and it was and it was
largely a result of don king's ex-boy
don king is by the way he showed up at
the 2004 republican convention also don
king's exploitation of race i mean don
king exploits everything patriotism i
mean whatever it doesn't matter but it
became something to to uh exploit rather
than something to to feel and live and
and that's i think uh the larger problem
um i think we're going to take one quick
last question and wrap up
yes sir
me yes
peter ferrara
is the author this is book tv on c-span
2.
my name is sarah baleen i'm the events
director here at kramer books and it's
really my pleasure to welcome you and to
welcome randy tonight for his book blood
brothers uh randy is a distinguished
professor of history at purdue
university he's written biographies of
iconic athletes and celebrities who
specializes in u.s history u.s sports
history and the history of popular
culture which clearly combine uh in this
new book
um
the blood brothers the fatal friendship
between muhammad ali and malcolm x is
really the first book
to offer an in-depth portrait of their
complex friendship and it
really
goes deep and uses previously untapped
resources uh from fbi records to
personal documents and so we're so
so pleased to have randy here today
and we're really glad that randy is
joined tonight by kojo nandi
kojo is the host of the kojo nami show a
live talk show produced by wamu 88.5 the
arizona weekends at noon weekdays at
noon excuse me on fridays at noon uh
kojo hosts the politics hour on wau
working as a journalist in the district
since the 70s at multiple media multiple
media outlets kojo has been dubbed quote
the washingtonian of the year by
washingtonian magazine and it has been
listed among the district's most
influential people by the pub by that
publication washingtonian and by deceist
we're so glad that kojo could join us
tonight this is one of our many partner
events with wmu 88.5 our local npr
station
we are so pleased to partner with wamu
they
share so many of our values of bringing
community together
having great discussions and having
great conversations and asking wonderful
questions so we're so glad that wmu can
be here in our community and here
tonight in the bookstore thank you again
so much for coming everybody please join
me in welcoming randy roberts and
kojonovdi to kramer
thank you so very much sarah and thank
you all
for showing up on what's clearly a dark
and stormy night
if you've been to bermuda you know
that's a drink also you can get a dark
and stormy tonight would be a good night
for a dark and stormy before we get
started with tonight's events i'd just
like not only to thank sarah and the
whole staff here
at kramer books but
the wamu team is working with the team
here on events because well we know that
listeners are also readers
and tonight
we're here as you heard to talk with
randy roberts about blood brothers he
and i will get the conversation rolling
and move to a question and answer
session with you after we have talked
for a little while but first
randy roberts welcome
thank you very much
happy to be here and i am happy to be
here with you
first what got you started
on looking at this you have written
about sports stars and sports legends
before
but this as far as i can see is the
first time
you looked at this combustible mix
of sports and politics
in a relationship
well i have looked at relationships
before
i well
i i did a book earlier on uh joe namath
and bear bryant so i i looked at a
relationship
i started with the idea that i wanted to
write a book about
muhammad ali and i was writing the book
this book was co-written with johnny
smith so i want to give him full credit
uh for co-writing the book
because quite frankly muhammad ali
was my champion okay
if you're if you like boxing if you
followed boxing people that lived
through the 1930s and the early 1940s
joe lewis was their champion and in the
1950s rocky morsianna was in their
champion or in the 1920s it was jack
dempsey well if you live
through the 1960s
and the 1970s muhammad ali was your
champion in the ring he was your
champion and what is even rarer
outside of the ring
he was my champion and so i thought wow
i'd like to write a book about that
and
johnny and i started to work on it and
the more we worked on it the more we
decided you know
what's really interesting is how
cassius marcellus clay
became muhammad ali what went into that
and the more we looked at it the more we
realized it was it was malcolm x the
cassius clay was almost inhabiting the
mind of malcolm x and we decided you
know that's an interesting story it's
it's a short period of time
we can look at it fully and and deal
with all the sources that we could dig
up on it and and it's a it's it's a
moment that
helps change american history i think
from that period in the first half of
the 1960s the three
great black leaders martin luther king
malcolm x and
improbably
cassius marcellus clay
who later became muhammad ali right i
was a teenager growing up in guyana
south america
and we sent boxers to the olympics in
rome in 1960
one of the boxes we sent there
even though he got knocked out in the
first round of his fight
somehow he managed to get a photograph
of himself
and the eventual winner of the light
heavyweight division
at those olympics the winner in that
division
at that olympics was who
it was cassius marcellus clay and and
and quite frankly it wouldn't be hard to
get your picture with cassius clay he
met everybody he was every place in the
olympics there was a one article we we
we read that i i remember reading and
one of the things that the athletes in
the games did is they exchanged pins
and the new york times said the official
winner of exchanging pins in the
olympics was cassius marcellus clay uh
you know for an athlete to expend an
enormous amount of energy
running around the olympic village
running around rome meeting everybody
accepting every interview
it probably wasn't a good thing to do
other than
he won the gold medal so he couldn't do
any better than that but when we looked
at the photograph what we saw was this
unbelievably handsome young man
and as you said he accomplished all of
this at the olympics and he had what for
us was the unusual name of cassius
marcellus clay we discovered that his
brother was named rudolph valentino clay
and so it all started in a way with
their father what we did not understand
at the time was that they had not led
the lives that cassius's appearance
would have led you to believe
that they led
they had a much rougher upbringing and
the consciousness
about the relationship between black and
white people started with his father
talk about them
no question about it and that is his
father by the same name cassius
marcellus clay
was a sign painter and an artist you can
still go to black churches in louisville
and you can see signs of his work he
believed
that he was a great artist okay he also
believed he was a great singer and he
would break out in a song i've listened
to interviews uh that are
in in archive collections and interviews
of of of the father and he would break
into a song and he would talk about how
good of a singer he was and what a great
artist he was and he was destined in his
own mind to be
famous he was michelangelo
frank sinatra though he said frank
sinatra was a pathetic singer
i can't go along with that dean martin
gave high remarks to but anyway uh he
thought he was going to be but he was
kept down his career was stunned because
he was black and it was a theme he
talked about with his with his sons
all the time not sometimes but all the
time uh oppression of whites he grew up
the cash both of them in a segregated
section of louisville in in cassius
learned early
that you stayed away from white people
okay that you
enter if you interact with white people
it can do you
no
good harm is going to come from it the
one thing i interviewed one person from
louisville who was a friend of cash's
when cassius was younger and he said he
talked about the lessons that they
learned what their parents told them
don't go here don't go here don't do
this don't do that number one
don't get arrested because if you go to
jail we can't protect you there's
nothing we can do it you know danger
will come up i think about that i mean
we're living through
and
what seems to be an unprecedented plague
of of black
kids being murdered uh murders too
strong but being shot by policemen and
maybe there was some truth to it that's
what his parents were warning him
against but it also helps to explain
why despite the fact that he was able to
charm everyone around him why despite
the fact that he was doing so very well
as a boxer
he became attracted to the nation of
islam he started going to nation of
islam meetings why how come
well remember let's let's look at
he was born in 1942 okay
he was about the same age as emmett till
he remembered the the murder of emmett
till his father talked about emmett till
all the time who was down in money
mississippi i think and was uh taken by
uh several white men for supposedly wolf
whistling a white woman probably didn't
emmett till had a stuttering problem i
don't know if you know the story of emma
tell but
he had trouble saying certain letters
and
he's a kind of whistle because it would
put his mouth in a position where he
wouldn't stutter
maybe that was what happened but anyway
for
whatever he did he ends up dead and and
muhammad heard this over and over also
in mohammed's neighborhood there was a
family that moved just a few blocks away
into a black neighborhood and their
house was firebombed so he felt
you know um he was interested he wasn't
interested in integration okay he wasn't
part of the uh advancement uh
national association advancement he was
he wanted
he believed in in in separation of races
and so obviously the nation of islam
appealed to him he and his brother
rudolph started going in the back door
at meetings of the nation of islam when
he was in locations where he had
a fight or some other event he was
obviously attracted to the nation and
ultimately
he would meet malcolm x and be attracted
to malcolm x and malcolm x would also
be um very very interested in who was
then
cassius clay but as things have evolved
in popular culture they were during a
time
when as you know there was a dispute
between malcolm and dr martin luther
king about what the best way forward was
but when we look at popular culture
today or when i look at popular culture
today here's what i noticed
there was a movie
a popular feature film made about
malcolm x
there was a popular feature film
made about
ali
and it wasn't until the last two years
that there was a feature film that was
made not about dr king but about his
role in selma what has emerged from that
era
is that the most charismatic figures of
that era turned out to be
malcolm x
and muhammad ali who now capture the
popular imagination why do you think
that was charisma
partly charisma though
my goodness i mean martin luther king
had charisma
his
as his speaking ability was
non-peril
um
i think
malcolm
and cassius muhammad ali had a harder
edge to him
you know they they weren't compliant
they
they were tougher they were
stronger you know
they they didn't preach turning the
other cheek okay as malcolm once said
you know
you shoot my dog you better watch out
for your cat okay you know he was going
to cut he was going to come aft
it wasn't it was going to be an eye for
an eye and a boxer has that same sort of
defiance so maybe it's that
well it also seemed to me that it was
in part because of their relationship
and in part because both of them at one
period were hated
people forget
that there was a time
when
both malcolm x
and muhammad ali were hated
because of their relationship with the
nation of islam i hear you're absolutely
right on that
you know i'm dealing with a time where
muhammad ali was probably the most hated
athlete in american history now that
will change his stand on the on the
vietnam war ameri he never changes
america will change and and but at the
time i'm dealing with he is absolutely
hated and of course
malcolm x
was the most hated
black leader the most hated politician
in america i mean this is a person when
the president of the united states was
assassinated only about a week later
malcolm x said well as far as he was
concerned it was chickens coming home to
roost that america's violence was being
revisited upon america
so
cassius clay gets interested in the
nation of islam
malcolm x is the minister in the mosque
in new york
how do the two meet
cassius went to train
in miami
and when he was in miami he started to
attend
some nation meetings and he met a person
who became kind of a tudor forum in
miami a man by the name of captain sam
saxton
and captain sam told them the theology
of the nation of islam and the leaders
and they talked about different aspects
of the nation but one time when cassius
was back home in louisville
got a call from captain sam captain sam
this was in june of
1962. captain said um there's going to
be a rally a nation of islam rally in
detroit
and
why don't you come i'll come pick you up
we'll drive up to detroit and you can
meet malcolm x and malcolm was the
spokesman for the nation of islam he was
by far the most famous figure in the
nation of islam and cassius said that's
fine so they went to a luncheonette
before the rally
and there
[Music]
sort of shaped like this
but sitting in the back at a table
facing the door where he always sat
back facing the door was malcolm x and
cassius goes up and says hello my name
is cassius clay
smiles
god was he handsome
and malcolm sees this dignified strong
powerful man but he has no idea who
cassius clay is you know he's never
heard of cassius clay he doesn't follow
boxing he just sees a very impressive
very
seemingly charismatic man but he picked
up boxing he learned it
the nation of islam at that point
did not allow its members to participate
in what they call sport and play
so
why was it
that despite the fact that this guy had
a profession in sport and play as a
boxer
did malcolm x see something there that
he thought needed to be developed that's
an excellent question
by that time
malcolm
and elijah muhammad who was the head of
the nation of islam
were starting to split apart there was a
power struggle who's going to succeed
elijah muhammad elijah muhammad was
older his health was bad he had been in
chicago but he was living mostly in
phoenix at this time and there was a
sense that maybe malcolm was too
powerful so there was a division taking
place and and malcolm was beginning to
chaff
under the constraints of the nation of
islam you know he wasn't he wasn't
allowed to do malcolm wanted to become
more active in the struggle and elijah
muhammad said no you stay away from it
okay
we we do not se we do not deal with with
members of the naacp we
you stay away from king we're our own
separatist organization and this wasn't
enough for malcolm and so i think in the
back of his mind the germ was
taking shape
that he was going to start his own
organization someday and he could see
the charisma
of this person you know uh you know that
that that athletes have
could have a a potential political use
he had charisma he talked all the time
he never seemed to listen
but he listened very closely to malcolm
why was this
outgoing
talkative person
the real cassius glen
that's several questions there
let me first say
who knows who the real captain explained
was
this is a person
that uh
that was
he was the most wonderful
mimic
possible he could inhabit another person
so one person said of cash is clay in
fact i've heard this from several
persons if he's if you said something he
liked the next day he would say it and
the third day he would say it better
than you said it and he would think it
was his okay i mean
and he could become whoever he wanted to
become you know there's a
there's a a poem that i like uh the uh
the love song of jail for proof rock and
i bet you have a copy of elliot's java
but in that
there's this one
line where uh the poet is he's going
towards an assignation he's talking
about there will be time there will be
time time to prepare the face
to meet the faces that you meet
okay the idea is
who is he
maybe we're a bunch of different people
i mean
you know we're one person with friends
we're another person with colleagues
we're another person with you know we're
a succession well this is the way
cassius was
in the rome olympics for example
he was a representative of america an
offender of america when a russian
reporter asked him about racism in
america he said oh don't don't don't
worry about that we've got we've got
important people taking care of that
okay it may be hard for me to get a
dinner sometimes in the district of
columbia he didn't say the district of
columbia but he could have said the
district of columbia but but it's
getting taken care of and america is
still the best country ever including
yours russian
okay that's one face then
he turns professional
there was a a moment a aha moment he was
he had a fight in las vegas
and he was interviewed early in the
morning
by radio
and he and also fighting in las vegas at
that time in a wrestling match was a guy
by the name of gorgeous george
and so they're both there early in the
morning and the interviewer turns to
muhammad first cassius clay at this time
says cashes how are you going to do in
the fight kasha says i'm going to win
the fight i'm very confident i'm i've
trained i'm in shape
my opponent's good it's going to be a
good fight i encourage everybody to come
out and watch a fight that's going to be
a good fight but i'm going to win
then he turns to gorgeous george and he
says george gorgeous whatever you call
him
how are you going to do it i'm going to
murder him i'm going to rip off his arm
i'm going to tear out his if if i lose i
will crawl across the ring on my knees i
will kiss his feet i will ask for
forgiveness and cassius went
wow
i'd like to see that fight okay
so it suddenly was born the louisville
lip that's another cache's clay and then
we have other so
so i forgot the original question he
realized that that was a performance
that could enhance his career
and so he developed that performance
but in fact
he was a young man
looking for knowledge oh
back to malcolm okay
and that's what he found that malcolm x
was able to provide and so it turns out
that this young man just listened very
carefully to everything malcolm x told
him he had never seen a man
so strong so proud
and so outspoken
he said after meeting malcolm for the
first time he said how can a black man
say that and not get shot okay he
couldn't understand it that that this
guy could would speak his mind in such a
forceful manner
and that strength
appealed to him i think
that strength appealed to him
the religion appealed to him
elijah muhammad appealed to him but his
relationship with malcolm was so close
and you're gonna have to read the book
to find out a lot of the details of all
of these fights but
at the most crucial fight in his life
the heavyweight championship fight
against sunny liston
is when the relationship with malcolm
became closer than ever
why
cassius clay
in in february of 1964
was fighting the most
fearsome
man in christendom
or beyond christendom
sonny liston
sonny liston was joe lewis mike tyson
and every
tough fighter you can imagine an ex-con
just
tough
he had won his two previous it won the
title on his first defense both with one
round knockouts
it was assumed
he was going to end cassius clay's
career i interviewed him with his life
if not his wife i interviewed one
reporter that for the fight robert
lipscite and bob told me he said look
when i was sent down there as a young
reporter for the new york times to cover
the fight
his seniors at the time said okay here's
what we want you to do kid
you're going to cover the fight because
they're not going to send a top-notch
reporter because it's only going to last
a few seconds so they said to lip sync
look you go down here's what i want you
to do when you get down there number one
find the fastest way from the arena to
the nearest hospital okay because we
want you to get there first to be able
to interview cassius clay or to when
they pronounce him dead you know to
report on this and so he goes down he
doesn't so
everybody thinks that every reporter
thinks he's going to lose everybody
feels that he's afraid of listening that
this that this kid will not last
but malcolm
gave him strength
malcolm said
look
allah has not brought you to this point
for you to lose
this is ordained
you are part of allah's plan for america
for the world you are going to win this
is a battle between the crescent and the
cross and before
he came to
now malcolm came to the dressing room
and they got down and they prayed
together and of course
if you've ever been in the vows of a big
auditorium and tried to find out where
exactly is east okay if you want to pray
straight
[Music]
which way is east they did the best they
could um and but it was and malcolm said
this is the crescent and the cross what
is crucial also you find out in this
book
is that this was the time as you pointed
out that
malcolm and elijah muhammad were
drifting apart
and
until i read this book i didn't know
that not even
elijah muhammad
and his sons in chicago
really believed
that cassius clay would win this fight
malcolm it would appear was the only
person
who
in the nation of islam
believed that he was going to win oh i'm
certain that's true
cassius i think maybe had an inkling
that he could win he had a plan for
winning but as mike tyson once said you
know everybody has a plan until they get
hit in the face
then plans go out the window you know
it's odd b what's b option on my nose is
bleeding um
but yeah he he he had
a belief
but
by this time
malcolm has been silenced by the nation
he's once
well he's silenced because remember the
argument
we're talking november i mean november
22nd right kennedy was assassinated and
so we're talking about a flight that is
now february 25th so we're
just a few months away from that
america is just coming out of its
mourning one of the great stories also
it talks about kind of a pivot
in our culture at that time
but mohammed was interviewed was
introduced to uh
four
white
brits that he had never really heard of
uh hardly
they were the beatles okay so you know
here we have the beatles
and and
still cashes clay
dealing with each other before the fight
it's almost you know you can foresee the
direction of
the of our american population
two of them were the most two most
important
cultural phenomena of the 1960s the
beatles and who was then cassius clay
well
that's my opinion but i don't think
anybody's going to you know you're not
going to convince me they weren't the
two most important well at this point
malcolm and elijah muhammad are having
their differences
why
not only because malcolm wanted to
become more politically active
but because he had he was becoming
disillusioned
with elijah muhammad at the time and
elijah muhammad having suspended him
was livid at him but when
cassius clay
wins the fight
these two men are very close together
what pulls them apart
what pulls
cash yes
now suddenly the nation of islam
is embracing him
brother we knew you were going to win
that fight okay
we we know we didn't say anything we
didn't want to jinx it but we knew it
all along that you were going to win the
fight
malcolm is going another direction
elijah muhammad
doesn't care about malcolm leaving okay
that's a foregone conclusion but he
wants cassius clay in the organization
now cassius clay imagine you've been
mentored by a man
who when he says anything to you
begins it with the phrase the honorable
elijah mohammed teaches
okay the elijah the honorable
elijah muhammad says the the source of
all wisdom the source of all power of
malcolm's power of ali's
power comes from elijah muhammad but now
malcolm says you know
the honorable elijah muhammad is a
hypocrite okay he's not practicing what
he's preaching he's doing all these
things wrong
what does claisen think
have you been lying to me all these
years you know
i'm not sure i believe that okay
also
malcolm is venturing out into very
dangerous territory
because if you leave the nation of islam
at that time
bad things could happen to you okay and
and and and members of the nation are
saying to cassius what
malcolm will get what's coming to him
the chickens will come home to roost
again
and so what's he going to do he really
plays it safe
he stays with and then finally elijah
muhammad gives him his name
malcolm wanted him to have another name
well his first name was was cash's x
correct
and the x stood for
the nation believed that
your slave your last name was your slave
name the black's last name so what you
did is you got rid of your last name and
you used x x symbolized your lost
african culture and that's why you had
malcolm x and
leon x and lewis farrakhan at that time
louis lewis
exactly
but
when
elijah muhammad gave him the name
muhammad ali
psychologically i guess
malcolm knew he had lost him
malcolm was listening
to the sermon when the name was given to
him he was in a car
and when he heard it malcolm said that's
political that's for any you know he
realized
he had lost
and
once he had lost him and
he had also lost
the nation of islam their
paths veered away from one another
and he tried and tried
to see muhammad ali and couldn't see him
and then after he broke from the nation
of islam
he went to africa
to god he had become more international
in his outlook
what happened in ghana
the last time
that muhammad ali and malcolm x saw each
other was in ghana was in accra ghana
outside of the ambassador hotel it was
totally by a coincidence
malcolm was leaving cassius was arriving
and i might say in africa is when ali
starts to think of himself as the king
of the world worry but
malcolm
as he throughout his visit
in africa people sometimes confused him
with muhammad ali and would come up to
him he said no no that i'm not
i i'm not mohammed and he pull out a
picture of him and muhammad he said this
is this is muhammad ali the heavyweight
champion this is my friend my very good
friend so malcolm still loved ali still
cared about him still considered him
friends and when he saw muhammad ali he
started to say
muhammad brother muhammad and he started
going to him and ali looked at him i
mean look
dead in his eyes just
darts coming out and said you shouldn't
have said that about the honor of elijah
muhammad and turns around
and walks away
and maya angelou was with was with
malcolm she was driving him in her
little fear she was and and she
and she said that the malcolm said you
know
i've lost a lot maybe too much i mean it
just it broke them it almost broke them
and
we all know what happened after that
ultimately with malcolm x but
in the case of muhammad ali he stayed in
the nation of islam for another maybe
decade or so yeah in 1975 after elijah
muhammad dies he follows wallace
mohammed who moves the nation into a
more
orthodox islamic direction
and so he becomes a more orthodox muslim
right a couple of things about the book
first the title why is it called blood
brothers
several people said they were like
brothers
okay and and and that's certainly part
of it one person even said they were
like blood brothers but beyond that
we're dealing with blood
as a leak motif throughout this book i
mean boxing is a sport of blood
uh politics at this time was a sport of
blood this is a time of assassination
this is a violent time for america and
uh uh we're trying to get that sense of
the violence of america and and yet how
do you maintain a relationship between
two powerful people
during that time
we are almost about the point where
we're going to take questions from you
so if you have a question simply raise
your hands and we will come to you
the other thing that fascinated me about
the book is the cover
i have never seen
malcolm x looked this playful
before
he's
looking down at muhammad ali with a
camera in his left hand he has his
hand on muhammad ali's shoulder muhammad
ali is
looking over his shoulder
as if he's trying to figure out
is this the same serious
leader that i've known
so far why is he being looking so
playful
because they were playing with each
other uh at that time they were they
were celebrating that was taken the
night right after
cassius clay won the heavyweight
championship of the world
and instead of going to the fountain
blue hotel
big famous
hotel in miami
they went back where there was supposed
to be a big celebration for clay the
problem with the celebration is nobody
really had planned one because everybody
thought he was going to lose so they had
to kind of throw it together at the last
second um
but that's where his white sponsoring
louisville sponsoring group went but he
went and malcolm went back to the
hampton house
uh a black hotel in the black section of
miami and and they were
playing around and joking and you know
smiling at each other and mugging and
and and mountain was taking pictures all
along this thing but the interesting
thing is they go then get serious and
they go up to malcolm's room and they're
talking and they're also in the room was
jimmy jimmy brown jim brown the great
football player
and um sam cook was there too the great
singer a change is going to come
change is going to come and and
at one point malcolm leaves the room
and cassius says to jimmy brown says you
know
i maybe leave you know this might be it
for
the last dance for me and malcolm okay
we may be forced apart
he didn't confide that to malcolm he
confronted it the jimmy brown and we all
know ultimately that
malcolm was assassinated but
by 1996
when muhammad ali
at the olympics in atlanta was carrying
the torch for the united states he had
become the most beloved athlete in the
united states
from a period
when people were rooting
for sunny listen
against him
because of his religious beliefs
his religious beliefs never changed he's
still a muslim to this day what changed
that caused muhammad ali to become so
beloved
he took controversial stand several
things but one is he took a
controversial stand on vietnam which was
incredibly unpopular when he took it
1966 or so but by the time after a few
years it became mainstream so he was
seen as kind of a martyr for the
anti-war cause
also
he became debilitated okay he lost that
sharp verbal gift he lost that
power that he once had
and
maybe a third thing is it might be it
may say something about the power of
american popular culture to absorb
dissidents uh you know we've we've made
wallpaper out of the you know
eldridge cleaver and the black one and
the black panthers so
we were able to absorb
all right if you have any questions now
is the time to raise your hand yes you
sir
uh first of all thank you both um i'm a
big fan of
yours um thank you for mr ross for being
here
i know when you approach a project where
you're writing something historical
there's a lot of research and it's an
investigative process and you probably
had some perspectives before um you
started writing this as you went through
the process and then at the conclusion
of it did you have any perspectives that
you felt were changed by the process of
actually going through about either
were you changed during the course of
writing this book was
your point of view on anything altered
as a result of the process of writing
this book
well first of all
yeah i we wrote acknowledgements
for the book all the people that have
helped us writing the book and the
research
and and and i realize now that there was
one person i didn't thank
and that was j edgar hoover
um
without j or hoover's obsession with
investigating every black man in america
that expressed a controversial opinion
uh we i wouldn't have had all these
wonderfully uh redacted documents to
look at
because whatever anything that was
taking place in the nation of islam
there could be four people four leaders
in the room
talking about important decisions
and one of them was working for the fbi
i have my guesses on which one it was
but i won't go into that
but
what surprised me is i thought
i knew
who muhammad ali was
and he turned out to be a much more
mercurial
person than i ever expected that that
you know somebody one person interviewed
talked about it he's figuring out
muhammad ali is like figuring out a
partner game okay
there's just so many different facets of
this personality to me was endlessly
interesting
anyone else
question just raise your hand here's
another
uh you would mention that uh muhammad
ali
was had a separatist point before he
came to the nation uh so when
when uh wd muhammad switched to uh
to more orthodox islam that would
embrace uh white people dozens too was
that
how what was that typical transition for
muhammad ali and like most in relation
to louis farrakhan was attempting to at
all attempted to join lewis paragon
being constituted nation
you mentioned that muhammad ali had
separatist views
before he joined the nation of islam
so when
elijah muhammad's son
wallace d mohammed
decided to take the nation
in a direction of orthodox islam
why did muhammad ali choose to go with
him
as opposed to going with louis farrakhan
i don't think he he had any problems
going that direction
in many ways he had always lived in an
integrated world
his first sponsoring group were white
his manager i mean his trainer
angelo dundee throughout his career was
white he had many white friends um and
so i i think he was actually more
comfortable and in in some ways he he
was moving the direction that malcolm
had started to move when malcolm was
assassinated so no
there was never any reservations that i
that i was able to ascertain
but he talked about the process of
writing this book this is as far as i
know the first book that you have had a
co-author on
um how was that process for you working
with the co-op actually i've worked on a
co-author with several books in my bed
it's okay
though
you probably have heard me give
interviews before i usually take all the
credit
no
i
love
if it's the right co-author it's a
little bit like a marriage okay if it's
a right wife it really works out well if
it's not the right wife okay
it doesn't work out as well um
no i like it because when you're writing
a book it's an intensely solitary
thing
and you know
even your family they pretend like
they're sort of interested in what
you're doing
but they're really not okay you know
they they may be able to take a minute
or two uh you know it's it's like
talking about you know listening to
other people talk about their children
you know
give me the brief version
um but when you have a co-author you're
both interested in it okay you go and
research when you go on a research trip
they can be really kind of boring i mean
you spend your time all day long in the
archive then you're sort of alone at
night but when you're going with
somebody else you're talking about it
you're working through problems together
and that my co-author johnny smith was
just a fabulous co-author and and
you know we
we learned to complete each other's
sentences you know trying to figure it
out trying to piece this puzzle together
so i recommend co-authors i think it's
great
how long did the process take for you
when did you
first conceive
after thinking about a book about
muhammad ali then deciding that it was
going to be a book about the
relationship between him and malcolm x
how long after that did it take for you
to get it all together
i would say
probably
from the time we really started hard
work because
academics
spend a lot of time just thinking about
not doing anything okay you know
drinking coffee i don't drink coffee but
i should drink coffee but you know but
once every maybe about two and a half
years
from the time maybe three years from the
time we really started to do hardcore
research until the book was finished
any other questions here you sir
um
i think what
i'm from the caribbean and i grew up at
a time when um
especially my father generation and
stuff like that those are the people who
got me interested in ali i i remember
that you know when he lost his fight
against you're describing my generation
yeah you might be a little bit older
than me but we are so so close we the
same generation but
um i remember when you lost the fight
there um they take me to
to see when he lost a fight against joe
lewis right these are men who are not
emotional people and practically you
could hear people crying but
that
so my my relationship with him goes back
a long time i like to believe that but
there are three interesting things that
you see seem to me to be talking about
here and one of them
is the issue of who is muhammad ali
right he's a very very
he's basically kind of i don't want to
overdo this now but he's basically like
jesus christ right he can
mix and match to all type of changes in
the society right
if you come to this oh that's all well
yes but you know
how do you think
in that multi-dimensional
flexible
uh
situation that he identity-wise facing
right at a time when african-americans
are massively protesting in the civil
rights movement right
um
you know demanding you know change etc
women are demanding change uh you know
um you have the beginning of the vietnam
war right what is interesting you didn't
touch on it is the fact that
uh
um
uh who i'm talking about um
the other black leader other important
black leader instead of malcolm x
right vietnam vietnam speech right
well ali ali reflects the vietnam speech
very quickly right right
i'm not doing this no vietnamese killed
me no yes misha i'm not going right
but all of this was was tremendously
controversial so how do you see
all of these changes right
reflect into this kind of a character
who himself is kind of trying to figure
out where he stands against all of these
multi-layer changes taking place and
maybe then the the complexity of try to
define who he is at ultimate
muhammad ali was a multi-faceted complex
man living in
multifaceted complex times
how did he negotiate his way
through those times
i'm not sure
they spent a lot of time
thinking about it
okay he just
moved forward okay
you know and
he he took every hurdle as it came um
he he's he's he's he's in in some ways
was a a paradoxical person he's a person
that you know kind of represents today
kind of peace and love and fellowship
and brotherhood but you know i know
people that have talked to him and
said you know he
he he was a wonderful person to be
around but he was never would never
really ask questions about somebody else
okay i mean you know he he he just kept
moving forward and
and it's almost as if he picked up
reflections from the society and and we
created the partially created the
muhammad ali that we wanted to believe
was there
i don't think he was working on it that
much but he took a major
financial hit
by refusing the draft he lost his career
for many many years what gave him the
strength and the fortitude to withstand
that
several things number one i don't think
money mattered to him at all
okay i you know he wasn't in anything
for money you know michael jordan
when he was asked to be involved in a
controversial political campaign you
know he said hey
republicans buy nikes too okay he didn't
want to do it
muhammad ali refused to be fenced in
money wasn't important to him therefore
after winning the heavyweight
championship the next day he gave a
famous to me a declaration of
independence speech where he says look
i don't have to be who you want me to be
i'm free to be who i want to be
you know
to me that resonates with we just went
through the super bowl and beyonce and
everybody's criticizing oh well why did
she sing that song why didn't she sing
uh you know put a ring on the finger or
something like that you're right you
know
that's my beyonce
it's it's pretty weak it's a pretty good
impression but you know it's you know to
me this is great to see that you know
that that she's saying hey i'm i you
pick me for the super bowl okay you want
me for your agenda fine i'm going to use
it for my agenda okay and if it costs me
an endorsement okay i'm only worth
a billion five instead of a billion six
so okay
i can live with it
you're not going to be who you want me
to be you have follow oh here's this
young lady
totally separate going back to when you
were
starting to write the book he said
originally you were going to write a
book about
were you going to write a book
with a co-author
no i was going to deal with the
co-author and this is an unusual where
you start a book and at first you see it
this way and then you know by the time
you you realize no this is the book that
i want to write that's how that's not
that unusual it's happened a few times
to me
but you were writing about a period
during which as you pointed out
there was a great deal of conflict
assassinations were taking place there
was a lot of violence and in the
relationship the deteriorating
relationship
between malcolm x and the nation of
islam it was a very scary time so i'm
wondering in writing the book the people
you talked to
about that period were there still
people who were reluctant to talk to you
about what went on during that period or
has enough time passed so that people
were willing to be frank and open
about everything that happened because a
lot happened most of the people that
were in any position to know what was
going on
are gone are gone
but for example captain sam
still around we talked with captain sam
and he was a wonderful interview and
he would still hold pretty hard views
towards malcolm i think would be safe to
say i mean it's uh
time hasn't softened all the edges
in this case did you attempt to
interview um minister louis farrakhan at
all uh you we we attempted but we were
unsuccessful yes the book does point out
that in very many ways
louis x's he was then called was chosen
by elijah muhammad in many ways to
replace malcolm x correct well and but
the main replacement in terms of as a
recruiting and that they used all the
time and muhammad speaks for newspaper
was
muhammad ali himself
you had a follow-up oh you had a
follow-up go ahead
what were uh
muhammad ali's experiences with
christianity growing up and did that
influence his decision to become a
member nation
he had a typical
southern black experience with
christianity his mother was a good
baptist i you know he went to church
no i don't think it did i think probably
his father influenced it uh and and his
experience influenced the separatism and
and that's what he really liked about is
this idea of separatism but
his
you couldn't have told it from his
upbringing pretty traditional
yes sir
uh
talking about did you use the foyer laws
to get your research
did you use foia laws to get any of your
information
uh some but most of the information most
of the
main files we looked at had already been
declassified for example you know elijah
muhammad's file malcolm x's file some of
the other lieutenant's files uh and also
police fouls in new york so most of them
have already been declassified and most
a lot of them you can get online the
hard thing about using those is that
they're so redacted
uh that unless
we really had a we knew where the two
characters were day by day
and that helped us to see when they were
close to each other and it it helped us
kind of provide a key to decipher what
the documents were saying because if you
look at an fbi document as you know
the dac did that you know five words the
doctor that
but we're able to get a great deal out
of them
johnny was a master at it we only have
time for one more question my caribbean
brother tried to make it three
two questions um
make them make them both brief then
uh the first one is um where obviously
mohammed was stopped fighting at the
very top point of his career i mean you
in many ways he lost the very best years
of
going to be even more inaudible
than it ended up being that's the first
thing the second thing obviously being
stopped by a white power structure at
that time who he was who he was the
challenging ibis of vietnam
did you see that play out in a way for
example in um towards uh how african
americans saw him how the black panthers
saw him et cetera et cetera do you see
that as radicalizing in a certain way
the um civil rights movement and black
people towards his white foreign
structure at that point in time we
didn't see that did you see muhammad
ali's actions having a radicalizing
effect
on the black power structure and i guess
the civil rights movement i i don't know
about radicalizing it was radicalized i
i see him as becoming he became the
patron saint
of
liberal
leftist causes there was a one great
image
and it was in a cover of esquire
magazine where they showed him and his
boxing gear
stretched out with aerostream uh
obviously a takeoff from the famous
painting of saint sebastian uh but you
know he was a martyr for the cause yes
and i'm afraid um that's gonna have to
about wrap it up what's your next book
jeff bush marco rubio
nicole i'm a trump man what can i say
no
something should be done i mean we talk
about celebrity uh you know and now
celebrities taking over politics uh
so so we'll see we'll see it's gonna be
a boxing match all right
um a few words about wmu as we wrap up
and randy gets ready to sign your books
for those who are not familiar we are
the npr news station wmu is in the
district of columbia but more
importantly we are your public radio
station in this region you can find us
anytime at 885 on your fm radio dial or
at wamu.org via the npr one app on your
smartphone and if anyone is interested
in talking about the station or radio
generally there are quite a few wamu
colleagues here in the audience they're
usually the ones with wine glasses
[Laughter]
um and if you work at wmu please raise
your hand
we'd be happy to chat
and again thank you all for coming out
tonight
i had a good time i would have paid for
this
[Applause]
thank you mandy thank you kojo thank you
all so so much for coming if you could
do us a favor help us by folding up your
chair placing against the bookcase on
the far wall please do come up say hello
get a book and have it signed thanks
everybody
[Music]
when i tune into it on the weekends
usually it's authors sharing their new
releases
watch
[Applause]
members of congress are reacting to the
death of muhammad ali today the boxing
champion died late yesterday at a
phoenix area hospital where he was being
treated for respiratory complications
over the last few days
arizona senator john mccain posted on
twitter that muhammad ali was an
incredible man whose passion for boxing
fairness and life benefited us all
virginia senator tim kaine says muhammad
ali was an inspiration worldwide his
contributions to sports and athletes
were invaluable
congressman john yarmuth of kentucky
where muhammad ali was born writes i am
just one of the many in louisville whose
heart aches for the loss of my friend
and yet our community is better for his
impact
and minnesota congressman keith ellison
has this to say on twitter muhammad ali
was much more than an athlete for me he
was an inspiration
muhammad ali was a recipient of the
presidential medal of freedom in 2005.
it's the highest honor given to a
civilian by the white house
here's a portion of that event which
begins with remarks from president
george w bush
only a few athletes are ever known as
the greatest in their sport
or in their time
but when you say
the greatest of all time is in the room
everyone knows who you mean
it's quite a claim to make
but as muhammad ali once said it's not
bragging if you can back it up
and this man backed it up
from the day he won the gold medal at
the 1960 olympic games
we all knew there was something special
about this young fighter from louisville
kentucky
and his record of 56-5 including 37
knockouts and 19 successful title
defenses hardly begins to tell the story
far into the future
fans and students of boxing will study
the films and some will even try to copy
his style
certain things defy imitation
the ali shuffle
the lightning jabs the total command of
the ring and above all the sheer guts
and determination he brought to every
fight
this is a man who once fought more than
10 rounds with a fractured jaw
and he fought to come to complete
exhaustion
and victory
in that legendary clash of greats in
manila
the real mystery i guess is how he
stayed so pretty
probably had to do with his beautiful
soul
he was a fierce fighter and he's a man
of peace
just like odessa and cassius clay senior
believe their son could be
across the world billions of people know
muhammad ali is a brave compassionate
and charming man
and the american people
are proud to call muhammad ali one of
our own
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
our country and our world have been
improved by the lives of the men and
women we honor today and now i ask the
military aide to read the citations
muhammad ali
one of the greatest athletes of all time
muhammad ali produced some of america's
most lasting sports memories
from winning the gold medal at the 1960
summer olympics to carrying the olympic
torch at the 1996 summer olympics
as the first three-time heavyweight
boxing champion of the world he thrilled
entertained and inspired us
his deep commitment to equal justice and
peace has touched people around the
world
the united states honors muhammad ali
for his lifetime of achievement and for
his principled service to mankind
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
and this statement today from president
obama and the first lady that in part
reads muhammad ali shook up the world
and the world is better for it we are
all better for it michelle and i send
our deepest condolences to his family
and we pray that the greatest fighter of
them all finally rests in peace
for security
three-time heavyweight boxing champion
muhammad ali has been buried in cave
hill cemetery
in his hometown of louisville kentucky
following the private graveside ceremony
a public memorial service was held
speakers included former president bill
clinton comedian billy crystal sports
commentator brian gumbel and members of
the family this is just over three hours
in the name of god most compassionate
most merciful we request that everyone
rise at the current time
stand up
to greet
the ali family
so
[Applause]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
so
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all praises due to god the lord of all
the worlds and now
please be seated ladies and gentlemen
in accordance with muslim tradition
and consistent with the wishes
of muhammad ali
may god have mercy on him
we begin this program
with a brief recitation
from the quran
the scripture of the muslims by hamza
abdul malik abdul malik is a young imam
of the midtown mosque in memphis
tennessee where he's spearheading a
neighborhood renewal effort in one of
the most blighted neighborhoods in
memphis and that effort is centered
around the mosque one of the few
african-american graduates of el essar
university he will share with us a few
verses from the quran
ladies and gentlemen hamza abdul malik
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
we
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
i
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i
my
so
my feet
and now with the recitat excuse me with
the translation
of those verses we would like to bring
to the stage
is a second generation daughter of
syrian immigrants
she's an excellent student
in her spare time
in recent years
she raises money
to provide medical supplies surgical
instruments instruments
and other forms of ref
of medical
assistance
for syrian refugees
fleeing from the horror of the current
conflict in that land and we pray that
almighty god brings it to a secession
soon
ladies and gentlemen ayah goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the name of god
the most gracious
the most merciful
truly those who say
our lord is god
and are upright
the angels will descend upon them saying
have neither fear
nor sadness
but rather rejoice in this paradise that
you have been promised
we are your allies in this lower life
and the hereafter
where you will have your heart's desire
and you'll have whatever you ask for
hospitably
from the one
most forgiving
most merciful
who is more beautiful in speech than the
one who invites to god and does
righteous works saying
truly i am submitted to god
for good and evil are not equal
repel ugliness with beauty and behold
the one between you in whom there was
enmity
is transformed into a warm friend
but no one arrives at the station
without great patience
and demands fortune
surah fusilat prostration
chapter 41 verses 30 to 35.
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i forgot to mention that she is a
louisvillian
a proud resident of this city
[Music]
oh god bless this day of ours
you are our protector what an excellent
protector
what an excellent
helper
honorable president bill william j
clinton
distinguished guest
viewing audience
on behalf of the ali family
and the city of louisville kentucky
the home
of the people's champ
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
we're dealing with time here folks
louisville kentucky admirably led by
mayor greg fisher
i would like to welcome you i give it up
for the mayor
[Music]
i would like to welcome you to this
memorial service
for the people's champ
muhammad
ali
at this time
we would like to introduce
our first speaker
dr revin
reverend
kevin w cosby
[Applause]
if
ward not for time since cosby rhymes
with ali we would say cosby cosby but
time doesn't permit
reverend cosby has served as senior
pastor of saint stephen church in
louisville kentucky
due greatly
to his practical and dynamic bible
teachings
his congregation has grown exponentially
over the long years of his ministry
reverend cosby combines passion
wit and intellect as the foundation of
an inspirational
and inspirational ministry
that has transformed the lives of
thousands of individuals reverend cosby
thank you
[Applause]
i looked in the dictionary for the word
fidelity
and it had two words
lonnie
ali
[Applause]
1967
nine months prior to his
assassination and martyrdom
dr martin luther king jr was interviewed
by merv griffin
on the merv griffin show
merv griffin asked
dr king
a relevant question
he said dr king
what has been
the greatest
effect and impact
that the civil rights struggle has had
on the negro
dr king paused and said
besides the dismantling
of barriers that prohibited
the negro from free access
the greatest and the most profound
effect
that the civil rights struggle had was
that it
infused in the negro something that the
negro
needed
all along
and that was a sense
of somebodiness
you will never be able to appreciate
what dr king meant when he said
the negro needed a sense of somebodiness
until you understand
the 300 and 6
350 years
of nobodiness
that was infused into the psyche
of people of color
every sacred document
in our history
every
hallowed institution
[Music]
conspired to convince
the african in america that when god
made the african
that god was guilty of creative
malfeasance
all of our sacrosanct documents
from the constitution said to the negro
that you're nobody
the constitution said that we were
three-fifths of a person
decisions by the supreme court like the
dred scott decision said to the negro to
the african that you had no rights
that whites were bound to respect
and even
francis scott key
in his writing of the star-spangled
banner we sang verse 1
but in verse 3
he celebrates slavery
by saying
no refuge can save
the harling and slave
from the sorrow of night
or the death of the grave
every institution from religion
to entertainment
from amos and andy
to jane and tarzan
infused in the psyche of the negro
that he was inferior
but something happened
to the depression generation and the
world war ii generation of african
americans
jackie robinson picked up his back
and hit a ball and
the brooklyn dodgers independent
joe lewis dismantles the pride
of aryan supremacy
by knocking out max smelling in
124 seconds
jesse lewis
runs in ambulatory speed
and wins four gold medals
rosa parks sits down on a bus in
montgomery in december of 1955
and a young
from boston university stands up and
takes the complex ideas of niebuhr and
tilik and dips it in chocolate so
big mama can understand it
and then from louisville
[Applause]
emerge the silver tongue poet
who took
the ethos
of somebodiness
to unheard of heights
before james brown said i'm black and
i'm proud
muhammad ali said i'm black and i'm
pretty
[Applause]
black and pretty was an oxymoron
blacks did not say pretty
the first black millionaire in this
country was not oprah
but it was madam c.j walker
[Applause]
who made products
in order to help black people escape
their africanity
but muhammad ali said
i'm proud i'm pretty
i'm glad of who i am
and when he said that that infused in
africans
a sense
of somebodiness
to extrapolate muhammad ali from the
times in which she lives
is what's called historic
presentism
it is to talk about george washington
and not talk about the american
revolution is to talk about
abraham lincoln and not talk about the
civil war it's to talk about franklin
delano roosevelt
and not talk about the depression
and world war ii
our brother muhammad ali was a product
of a difficult
time
and he dared
to love
black people
at a time when black people had a
problem loving themselves
he dared
he died to affirm
the beauty of blackness he dared
to affirm
the the power and the capacity of
african americans he dared
to love
america's most
unloved race
and he loved us all
and we loved him because he we knew he
loved us he loved us all
whether you lived in the suburbs or
whether you lived in the slums
whether you lived on the avenue or
whether you lived in an alley
whether you came from the penthouse or
whether you lived in the projects
whether you came from morehouse or
whether you had no house
whether you were
high yellow or boot black
muhammad ali
loved you
our city is known for two things
it is known for muhammad ali
it is known for the kentucky derby
we hope you will come back and visit our
city
the first
saturday in may
we hope you will place a bet on one of
the horses
but if you do please know the rules
what will happen is the horses will
start off in the starting gate
and then
the signal will be given they will run
in the mud for two minutes and the
winner
will then be led to the winner's circle
where a wreath of roses will be placed
around the horse's neck
we want you to make a bet but please
know the rules
you cannot
bet for the horse
once it's in the winner's circle
you have to bet for the horse
while it's still in the mud
[Applause]
and there are a lot of people
there are a lot of people who will bet
and have bet on muhammad ali
when he was in the winner's circle
but the masses bet on him while he was
still in the mud
[Applause]
kareem abdul-jabbar stood with him when
he was in the mud jim brown
stood with him when he was in the mud
bill russell stood with him
when he was in the mud howard cosell
stood with him when he was in the mud
[Applause]
now please don't mishear me
i am not saying that muhammad ali is the
property of black people
he is the property of all people
but while he is the property of all
people
let us never forget
that he is the product
of black people
in their struggle
to be free
[Applause]
i went looking for jesus
on a poor west end street
thinking
that i would find him as he walked
around with men and women with stumbling
feet
people who had their heads bowed low
because they were broken had nowhere to
go
but then i went looking for jesus way in
the sky thinking he would wear a robe
that would dazzle my eye
when suddenly jesus
came walking by with stumbling feet
because he'd been hanging with the poor
on a west end street
[Applause]
the muhammad i leave my childhood
had a shuffle but as he grew older
he walked with shuffling feet
and i would submit to you that he walked
with shuffling feet
not because of parkinson's disease
but he walked with shuffling feet
because he hanged out with the folk in
west louisville
who had shuffling feet
peace and god bless you
[Applause]
[Music]
yes yes yes
yes yes yes
don't give a teenager a telephone and
don't give a preacher a microphone
[Applause]
we like to we like to bring senator
orrin hatch to the stage now in his
seventh term
as utah senator one of utah's senators
he is the most senior republican
in the senate author of some of the most
far-reaching
legislation in recent
decades
senator hatch is a seasoned and
distinguished public servant
we are deeply honored
by his presence today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow reverend that was really good
it's hard for this poor old senator to
have to follow that is all i can say
well
ahead of the first fight with sonny
liston
muhammad ali stood before a crowded pack
of reporters
and told the world unapologetically who
he was
i'm the greatest
that's what he said
with this simple proclamation
paul took the pen of history and wrote
his own alley took the prince the pen of
history and wrote his own title
in the textbooks
he was not muhammad ali
the prize fighter
or even muhammad all
all the world champion
he was muhammad all the greatest
all these doubters dismissed this
declaration as mere braggadocio
but ali wasn't talking trash
he was speaking truth
and
he was in the world of boxing
he truly was
the greatest
[Applause]
[Music]
with the cutthroat quickness of a of a
street fighter
and the simple grace
of a ballerina
all he moved with achilles like
agility and punched with herculean
strength
but to assume that all these grace and
greatness stems solely from his athletic
prowess
is to see only half the man
all he was great not only as an
extraordinary fighter
he was a committed civil rights leader
an international diplomat
a forceful advocate of religious freedom
an effective emissary of islam
he was
something
he was caring as a father
a husband a brother
and a friend
indeed
it is as a personal friend that i
witnessed all these greatness for myself
i first met muhammad ali 28 years ago
almost of the day to this day
i was in my senate office an assistant
called in and said you have a visitor
outside
and i
was really surprised that it was none
other than the champion himself
the friendship we developed
i think was puzzling to many people
especially to those
who saw only our differences
i might say that
but where others saw a difference
ollie and i saw kinship
we were both dedicated to our families
and deeply devoted to our faiths
he took islam
and i to the church of jesus christ of
latter-day saints
we were both products of humble
backgrounds and hardscrabble youth
[Music]
all we grew up poor here in louisville
and i grew up poor in pittsburgh
true we were different in some ways but
our differences fortified our friendship
they did not define it
i saw greatness in all his ability to
look beyond the horizon
and our differences
to find common ground
this shared sensibility was the
foundation of a rich
and meaningful relationship
that i will forever treasure
one of my fondest memories of our
friendship
was that all lee joined me
in the salt lake uh
to go and listen to the salt lake mormon
tabernacle choir
i have to say it was the same mormon
tabernacle choir
all he you know loved music
and he enjoyed the choir's performance
but he seemed most excited to share his
own religious beliefs with those who
came to hear the christian hymns
all he attracted big big crowds that day
and the as he always did and eagerly
gave everyone
autographed pamphlets
explaining his uh muslim beliefs
hundreds of mormons lined up to grab all
these pamphlets and of course i took one
for myself
i respected his deeply held convictions
just as he respected mine
in our relationship it was anchored by
our different phase
only was open to goodness
in all of its diverse realities
and varieties
on another occasion i took ali to
primary children's hospital in salt lake
city
[Music]
we visited with down trodden children
who perhaps had never smiled a day in
their lifetime
until all he showed up
i only held those kids and looked into
their eyes
they would grin from ear to ear
these are kids that never smiled they
were so pained
the nurses were astounded
never before had they seen
someone who had
connected so immediately and profoundly
with these sick children
ali had a special way with kids as we
all know he may have been a tough
and tenacious man in the ring
but he was a compassionate
and tender around those that he loved
for all of his ferocity as a fighter
ollie was also a peacemaker
a particular radio host in utah berated
me constantly on the airwaves
week after week on one day the host
asked
[Music]
if i would arrange for ali to meet
utah's former middle middleweight
champion gene fulmer
for a joint interview
all the ollie agreed knowing the
appearance would could help me build
some good will
but he also was very interested in
meeting gene as well
it was an unforgettable experience
here were two champions face to face
reminiscing about
some of the best fights the world has
ever seen
and i have to say
and in the process
ali claimed
that
radio host
well he charmed the radio host so much
on my behalf
gently transforming a an unrepentant
antagonist into a respectful sparring
partner so dedicated was ali to our
friendship
that he joined me on the campaign trail
during several election cycles
he came to utah year after year to raise
funds
for a charity benefiting needy women
women in jeopardy
and families in our state
ali
didn't look at life through the binary
lens of republican democrat
so common today
he saw worthy causes
and shared humanity
in all his willingness to put principles
ahead of partisanship
he showed us all the path to greatness
and i'll never forget that greatness
nor will i ever forget him
[Music]
there were many faces to ali's greatness
his abilities as a boxer
his charisma as a public figure
his benevolence as a father and as a
friend
all of these made all the great
but was something else that made him
the greatest
ollie was the greatest because
as a debilitated yet unbroken champion
in his later years
he pointed us to a greatness beyond
ourselves
the greatness beyond even ali
he pointed us to the greatness
of god
[Applause]
[Music]
god raised up ollie to be the greatest
fighter in the world of all time
yet he allowed ollie to wrestle with
parkinson's disease
an inescapable reminder that we are all
mortal
and that we are all dependent on god's
grace
ali believed this himself he once told
me
god gave me this condition to remind me
always that i am human
then and that only he
is the greatest
ollie was an unsurpassed symbol of our
universal dependence on the divine
he was the greatest
because he reminded us all
who truly is the greatest
god our creator
i'm eternally grateful for my special
bond
with this special man
and for my friendship with his beloved
wife lonnie
who i love dearly
she's one of the great women in this
world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
she was dedicated to her companion to
the very end and boy i know it
i pray that all may rest peacefully and
that ali
will rest peacefully
in the presence of the greatest
of all
even our gods
i can bear testimony that i believe in
god
i believe
that we're here on earth for a reason
i believe that this
earth life
is a time for us to do what's right for
god
and for our fellow men and women
and i don't know that i've ever met
anybody
who did it any better
than my friend
muhammad ali
god bless you god bless the family
[Applause]
[Music]
next we would like to welcome father
monsignor father henry kreigle
to this stage father crygo has been
instrumental has been the pastor of
saint
patrick's parish in erie pennsylvania
who was ordained in 1970
and named a domestic prelate
with the title month senior by pope john
paul ii in 1991.
his wisdom scholarship
and spiritual guidance is a source of
solace
and guidance for catholics and members
of other faith communities
far far beyond his pennsylvania home
father
[Applause]
[Music]
let us pray
loving eternal god
as we gather today in prayer
we do so with an abiding sense of
gratitude
our gratitude knows no bounds
as we thank you for the gift of this
good and gentle man
muhammad ali opened our eyes to the evil
of racism
to the absurdity of war
he showed us with incredible patience
that a debilitating illness
need never diminish joy
and love in our lives
he chided our consciences
he awakened in us a deeper sense
of the need to respect one another
to set aside racial differences
the legendary fighter of all time
in reality taught us to heal
rather than to fight
to embrace rather than to turn away
to include rather than exclude
while proclaiming himself to be the
greatest
he showed us that his greatness lie in
his love and concern for others
most particularly the marginalized the
suffering the helpless the hopeless
your gift of him has enriched us
has made us better people
has created a more gentle world
we dare not return him to you today
without expressing our gratitude
for the gift of him
amen
[Applause]
next we will hear a few brief remarks
from dr timothy giannatti dr jianadi
is a professor of islamic studies at the
university of waterloo
in ontario canada
he is equally at home busying himself
with the affairs
of the muslim community as he is
sitting in the librarian
borrowing through books a true public
intellectual
dr giannatti is the initial and
principal islamic advisor
to the ali family
he has been instrumental in assuring
that the last days
of muhammad's life
his
burial his bathing is shrouding
and his burial today his funeral and
burial today all were in accordance
with the strictures
of muslim law
so now i'd like to bring to you
the person i affectionately call
brother
dr
imam timothy giannatti
[Applause]
so
[Music]
is
in the name of god who is the loving
nurturer of the creation
[Music]
and the ever compassionate and ever
merciful
i'd like to share a prayer today
and this is
a prayer adapted from
a traditional prayer of the prophet
muhammad al-islam
may god's place peace and blessings be
upon him
but before i do so i would just like to
say
to the family to lonnie to everyone here
that
[Music]
serving muhammad ali was has been one of
the greatest privileges
of my life
[Music]
oh god you who are the light of the
heavens and the earth
grant our brother muhammad
a light in his heart
a light in his earthly body now restored
to the earth
a light
in his grave
a light before him
as he journeys on to
you a light
in all that he has left behind
in this world
[Music]
a light to his right
and a light to his left
oh god increase him in light
grant him
light
a light in his deeds in this world and a
light in the hereafter
a light in the hearts of those whom he
loved
and a light in the eyes
of those who loved him
a light
in those whom he knocked down
[Music]
and the light
in those whom he lifted up
a light in his words which echo in our
hearts
a light in the lives of all those whom
he touched
a light in his
children and the light
in their mothers
a light in his grandchildren
[Music]
and a light
in his devoted wife lonnie
o lord increase your servant
in light
and give him light
embrace him
in light
and fill us all
with light
oh you who are the light of the heavens
and the earth
oh you who are the most merciful of all
those who show mercy
yeah
yahoo
[Applause]
[Music]
next we will hear
a few words from rabbi michael lerner
rabbi lerner is not only the rabbi of
bait
but also the editor of tikkun magazine
as the magazine's name suggests
rabbi lerner has dedicated his life
to working
to heal and repair
the world
rabbi lerner
is never afraid
of ruffling
a few feathers
so we ask him to be nice today
rabbi luna
we'll see about those feathers
[Music]
master of compassion god of compassion
send your blessings
to
muhammad ali
and send your blessings to all who mourn
for him
and send your blessings for all the
millions and millions of people who
mourn for him all over this planet
amen
i come here speaking as a representative
of american jews
and to say that american jews
played an important role of solidarity
with the african-american struggles in
this country
and that we today stand in solidarity
with islamic community in this country
and all around the world
[Music]
we will not tolerate
politicians
or anyone else
putting down muslims
and blaming muslims for a few people
[Music]
[Applause]
we know what it's like to be demeaned we
know what it's like to have some a few
people who act against the highest
visions of our tradition
to then be uh identified as the value of
the entire tradition
and one of the reasons that we in tikkun
magazine a magazine of liberal and
progressive jews but also an interfaith
magazine
have called upon the united states to
stand up to the uh to the part of the
israeli government that is oppressing
palestinians is that
is
that we as jews
understand that our commitment is to
recognize that god has created everyone
in god's image and that everyone is
equally precious and that means the
palestinian people as well as all other
people on the planet
[Applause]
i know the people of louisville have a
special relationship to muhammad ali and
i had a personal relationship in the in
the 60s when both of us were indicted by
the federal government and before our
various stands against the war in
vietnam
i want to say that
that although
he was
cheered on as
the heavyweight champion of the world
you know the truth is is that in all the
honor to him but heavyweight champions
of the world come and go and
sports heroes come and go there was
something about muhammad ali that was
different at the key moment when he had
that that recognition he used it to
stand up to an immoral war and say no i
won't go
[Applause]
and it's for that reason that tens of
millions of americans who don't
particularly care about boxing
about muhammad ali because he was a
person who was willing to risk a great
honor that he got and a great fame that
he got
to stand up for the beliefs that he had
to speak truth to power when the rest of
the people around him said no no you're
going to lose your championship and he
was it was taken away from him for five
years but he stood up and was willing to
take that kind of a risk because of that
kind of moral integrity
[Applause]
so i want to say how do we honor
muhammad ali
and the answer is the way to
honor muhammad ali is to be muhammad ali
today
that means us everyone here and everyone
listening
it's up to us to continue that ability
to speak truth to power
we must speak out refuse to follow the
path of conformity to the rules of the
game in life we must refuse to follow
the path of conformity tell the one
percent to own eighty percent of the
wealth of this country that it's time to
share that wealth
tell the politicians
who use violence worldwide and then
preach into non-violence to the
oppressed that it's time for them to end
their drone warfare and every other form
of warfare
to close our belly bases around the
world to bring the troops home tell
those who created mass incarceration
that is time to create a guaranteed
income for everyone in our society
[Applause]
tell judges to let out of prison the
many african-americans swept up
by the by racist police and imprisoned
by racist judges
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and many of them imprisoned today for
offenses like possessing marijuana that
white people get away with all the time
tell our elected officials to imprison
those who authorized torture and those
who ran the big banks and investment
companies that caused the economic
collapse of 2008.
tell the leaders of turkey to stop
killing the killing the kurds tell
israeli prime minister netanyahu that
the way to get security is for israel is
to stop the occupation of the west bank
and help create a palestinian state
[Applause]
tell the next president of the united
states that she
okay
tell the next president of the united
states that she should seek a
constitutional amendment to make all
national and state elections funded by
congress and the state legislatures and
all or other sources of money be banned
including money from corporations from
individuals all other money make it all
public funding
[Music]
tell her
that the way to achieve homeland
security
is not for us to try new ways of
domination the strategy of domination of
the world of the other to get security
has been tried for the class ten
thousand years and it doesn't work
the way to get security is for the
united states to become known as the
most generous and caring country in the
world not the most powerful
[Applause]
and we can start with a global and
domestic marshall plan to once and for
all end global and domestic poverty
homelessness hunger inadequate education
inadequate healthcare
[Applause]
so i want to
as chair of the interfaith network of
spiritual progressives by the way
spiritualprogressives.org come and join
us spiritualprogressives.org
i want to affirm our commitment to the
well-being of all muslims on this planet
as well as the people of all faiths and
secular humanists as well
we wish to pay honor to to muslims of
the world as they continue today the
fast of ramadan and join with them in
mourning the loss and celebrating life
of muhammad ali a great fighter for
justice and peace peace be upon him
peace be upon the prophet muhammad peace
be upon all of humanity and peace on all
of us amen
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
time time time is not on our site
after that speech
i have to edit my initial remarks
honorable first man
william j clinton
[Applause]
[Music]
chief sydney hill in 2002 sydney hill
was selected
or spiritual principal spiritual leader
of his people a true friend of the earth
and beloved
to all who know him
he is a leader whose spirituality is
coupled with a passionate pursuit of
justice
we are honored
that he has
come here today
to share a few words and a few thoughts
with us
chief hill
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is uh chairman stevens with us here
united nation
and more lines from the outer darker
nation
translation
he said
my relatives
it is my responsibility
to pick up the words for the houdini
the people of the long house
they wish you well
they want you to be
a peace of mind
now
this great darkness
that has happened to us
you must understand
that he who had gathered us here
that his road is straight
peacefully
he will arrive
at his land
our creator
it is the same
as you call him
allah
these were the words
and to the family
the relatives
and friends
of muhammad ali
muhammad ali was a leader
among men
and a champion of the people
[Applause]
he fought for the people of color
yet he was a man of peace and principle
a man of compassion
who used his great gifts for the common
good
his spirit
has a clear path to the creator
sydney hill
spiritual leader of the holy nosone
sixth nation iroquois confederation
on a darker nation
and myself
joaquison faith keeper turtle clan
underdog council of chiefs
have journeyed here today to add our
voice
to this congregation of world leaders
in honor of his work
and for the rights and dignity of people
of color
and the common man
he was always in support of the
indigenous people of this hemisphere
in our quest
for our inherent land rights
self-determination
identity
and collective rights
that include
the natural world
we know
we know what he was up against
because we've had
524 years
of survival training
ourselves
[Applause]
in 1978
a congressman from the state of
washington
put a bill into congress to terminate
our treaties
with the united states
and indian nations
walked from california
to washington dc
in protests
muhammad ali marched into washington
d.c with us
[Applause]
he was a free
independent spirit
he stood his ground with great courage
and conviction
and he paid a price
and this country did too
and we all did
values and principles
will determine one's destiny
and the principles of a nation will do
the same
poor people
do not have many options
and you fighters know what i'm talking
about
he said
that the ring
was ali's path to his destiny
he said he'd be heavyweight champion of
the world
and he was
three times
in this fourth time right here right now
[Applause]
on his journey in life
he lived and learned the hard way
he brought a light into this world
my world
our world
and that
light will shine a long
long time
[Applause]
peace brother
peace
and on behalf
of oshoni
my friend
ernie
and the indigenous people
everywhere
peace thank you
[Applause]
we introduced uh
chief hill he was joined his words were
translated by chief
oral lions chief oral oran lyons
was born into a traditional
indigenous family grew up on the native
reservations of upstate new york
in 1970 he became the chief and faith
keeper
of the turtle clan
of the ono dunga
nation
his scholarship stewardship and
leadership
is a source source of benefit
and great blessing
for all who know him
now we'd like to introduce rabbi joe
rooks rapport
rabbi rapport senior rabbi of the temple
here in louisville
where he has been a leader
in interfaith work
he has a passion for teaching youth
and in fact it is
his work with youth
that led him to cross paths with
muhammad ali
his religious leadership focuses on
compassion care
and working together
with all
to build
a better world
rabbi report
[Applause]
this is a reading
from our memorial prayers on yom kippur
our day of atonement
our most sacred day of the year
it was written many decades ago by rabbi
alvin fine
a civil rights and humanitarian leader
who could never have known when he
composed these words
that he was writing a eulogy for
muhammad ali
birth
is a beginning
and death
a destination
and life is a journey
from childhood to maturity and youth to
age
from innocence to awareness
and ignorance to knowing
from foolishness to discretion
and then perhaps to wisdom
from weakness to strength
and strength to weakness and often back
again
from health
to sickness
and back we pray to health again
from offense to forgiveness
from loneliness to love
from joy to gratitude
and pain to compassion
from grief to understanding
from fear to faith
from defeat to defeat to defeat
until looking backward or ahead we see
that victory lies not at some high place
along the way
but in having made the journey
stage by stage
a sacred pilgrimage
birth is a beginning
and death a destination
and life is a journey
the sacred pilgrimage to life
everlasting
we say words of prayer
and they remain words
until we encounter a person who embodies
these words
and makes them real
i've said these words many times before
at funerals and in memorial services
but never have i felt them come to life
and speak of a single shining soul
as i do today
muhammad ali was the heart of this city
the living breathing embodiment of the
greatest that we can be
he was our heart
and that heart beats here still
[Applause]
let me tell you a story you already know
it's one of those stories about ali
being gracious to the stranger that so
many of us have told
so many times and in so many ways
that we sometimes forget the lessons
that these stories were intended to
teach us
it's a story hana tells about her father
towards the end of their book the soul
of a butterfly
han is driving
her father to a bookstore
on one sunday to pick up some bibles and
qurans
for a project that he's working on
they pass an elderly man standing by the
road with a bible in one hand and his
thumb in the air with the other
they offer him a ride
and he thanks them saying that he's on
his way home from church
he'll needs to go a few miles down the
street
where he can pick up a cab
han asks where he lives
he doesn't want to trouble them or go
out of their way
he has no idea who's sitting in the
front seat of this car
until muhammad ali turns around and says
it's no trouble at all
we're just on our way to a bookstore to
buy some bibles and qurans
once a man gets over meeting the
greatest of all time
he insists that he has three bibles in
his house
and he'd be pleased to give them to ali
in appreciation for the ride
ali thanks him but says he wants to pay
for the bibles
the man says no the bibles were meant as
a gift
i'll ali asked him what he does for a
living and it turns out that the man's
had a stroke and he's been forced into
retirement
ali then tries to hand him a big pile of
money for the bibles
but the man refuses
and this is where things get interesting
[Music]
ali says
take the money man i'm trying to get
into heaven
and the man replies
so am i
ali is not taking no for an answer
he says
if you don't take the money i might not
get in
and the man replies if i do take your
money i might not get in
they arrive at his home and the man
invites him in to meet his wife of 30
years
he gives ali the bibles
ali slips the money under a napkin on
the kitchen table
they're about to leave
and hannah gives the man
her phone number and tells him to call
him to call her if he ever needs a ride
home from church again
sitting in the car
ali turns to his daughter and asks
would you really go out of your way and
pick him up drive him all the way home
and she says yes
and with tears in his eyes
he says
that's me
in you
he says
you're on the road to heaven
therein
lies ali's greatness
in his ability to see within himself
something greater
and in his ability to inspire others to
see such greatness reside within
themselves
there will never be another greatest
like muhammad ali
but we together
can now embody a measure of his kindness
and his compassion
we can say each of us in our hearts
there's a little bit of ali in me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this week
we have mourned the loss and celebrated
the life
of a louisville legend and a citizen of
the world
and of all the words and in all the ways
the most powerful moments have always
been made in the voices of young people
repeated in prayer services enchanted in
the streets
i am ali
i
am ali
i am not the fighter that ali was
and i may not have the courage which he
never lacked
and i am definitely not as pretty
but in my heart
and in my hope
and in my prayers
i am muhammad ali
[Applause]
when we say that
in our hearts
when we live that in our lives
then we together can build a legacy
worthy of the greatest of all time
so say that now with me
in your heart and in this room
i am ali
[Applause]
[Music]
you know one of the amazing things that
we've witnessed during our
during our time here in louisville has
been just so many stories of common
ordinary people
there's folks on the street working in
the hotels the restaurants
virtually everyone has a story
concerning how muhammad ali
touched their lives he came to my fourth
grade class
he helped me out in this or that way
he came to visit me when i was sick just
on and on and on and collectively
those experiences
they
they become synergetic they become
greater than the individual
parts
and when we roll through the streets of
the city today i've witnessed something
i've never ever witnessed in my life
[Applause]
[Music]
and i don't think i will ever witness
again
i witness the power
in our muslim tradition we call it
it might be loosely translated as
sainthood i witnessed the power of
sainthood
[Music]
general venerable
otsumi
[Music]
is a member of the
nippon zan
miyohoji a japanese buddhist order
dedicated to working for world peace
through the practice
of walking peace pilgrimages
anti-nuclear weapon pilgrimages
and the construction of peace pagodas
all over the globe
he will be joined on stage
by sister denise
lathan
another member of the order and together
they will share
a traditional
chant
with us
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yo
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
now we will listen
to a reading
by
ambassador shabazz
ambassador ta'ala shabazz is the eldest
of six daughters born to al-hajj
she proudly
shares that she is inspired
by her parents
their parents
and those before them
through the descending
generations
the former prime minister of belize
recognized her as a key ambassador on
international cultural affairs
and project development and in 2002
appointed her as ambassador
at large
powerful and elegant
we invite ambassador shahbaz
[Music]
to read and share
and inspire us
[Applause]
[Music]
may peace be on
all of us
as this is a homegoing
celebration
i find myself balanced between that of
celebration
and depletion
[Music]
loss
and somehow another
my breathing capacity
has been weakened this past week
so i ask all of you gathered
and afar
to please
muster up and transmit a bit of your
care
to me
[Music]
in the memory
of muhammad ali
thank you all
and more as the globe centers at this
very moment amidst the holy month
of ramadan where every two hours there's
a time zone
praying and including muhammad ali and
his family and their thoughts
amidst that
are the prayers of all faiths all those
touched even those that don't claim a
religion are feeling something right now
in honor
of the family and the memory
of their father
husband
in the spirit of my parents
malcolm x shabazz and dr eddie shabazz
[Music]
[Applause]
in the presence of my five younger
sisters
our children
and our grandchildren
i would like to first honor
his beloved wife
my sister lonnie ali
[Music]
[Applause]
for all the strengths that you know and
that resonate
beyond
sometimes you do need a little help
no matter how magnificent you are
and indeed those that were with him that
loved him his family members
sustained that
his nine children and i will name them
miriam rashida jamila
muhammad junior
kalila mia hana
laila and assad
as well as their mothers
and the third generation of ali
grandchildren who accompany them
[Applause]
to his only brother
rahman
to his extraordinary
example of a best friend howard bingham
[Music]
[Applause]
and to his sister-in-law
marilyn roose
for all the grief
that i am depleted by
and others of feeling
[Music]
by his transition
there is none
comparable to yours and i know that
on this day
and those to come
as you redefine your waking days
with a life without him here presently
very different
photos memories
all the things that we have
on him that keep him going
he touched you differently and that has
to be honored and recognized
never forsaken
just know that when you are the
descendant of in the presence of someone
whose life was filled with principle
that the seed is in you so that you have
to cultivate that responsibly as well
[Applause]
this moment is very meaningful for me
[Music]
to have been amongst those chosen and
blessed by muhammad himself
and affirmed by his wife lonnie
to take part
by sharing a prose a statement
during this homegoing ceremony
while he and i had a treasured
relationship
the genesis of this love
was through the love for my father
muhammad ali
was the last of a fraternity of amazing
men bequeathed to me directly by my dad
somewhere between me turning 18 19 or
20.
they all seemed to find me
somehow
guided by an oath or a promise to my dad
long after him leaving this earth
to search for me
and they did
each one remaining in my life until
joining the rest of the heavens beloved
summit of fearless humanitarians
this included muhammad ali
whom my dad loved as a little brother 16
years as junior
and his entrusted friend
there was a double take when i came upon
him a once childhood
pursed child
and now looking right into his face and
you know how he is you know he gives you
that little dare like is that you
[Music]
from the very moment
we found one another it was as if no
time had passed at all despite all of
the presumptions of division
despite all the efforts of separation
despite all of the organized
distancing
we dove right into all of the unrequited
yet stated and duly acknowledged spaces
we could explore and uncover
privately
we cried out loud
his belt
his grief
for having not spoken to my dad before
he left
and then just as loudly we'd laugh
about the best of stories and some that
can't be repeated he was really funny
what was significant as brothers for my
father and ali
was their ability to discuss openly
anything
or factors of life
namely the true meaning as men with
great responsibilities
bestowed to them of how to make an
equitable difference in the lives of
others
a unifying topic was faith
an ecumenical faith respect for faith
all faiths
even if belonging to one specific
religion or none
the root of such being the gift of faith
itself
so in his own words he wrote
we all
have the same god
we just serve him differently
rivers
lakes ponds
streams
oceans
all have different names but
they all contain water
so do religions have different names and
yet
they all contain truth
truth expressed in different ways and
forms and times
it doesn't matter whether you're a
muslim a christian or a jew
when you believe in god you should
believe all people are part of one
family
[Music]
[Applause]
for if you love god you can't love only
some of his children
his words
and certainly ideals shared by both men
love is a mighty thing
devotion is a mighty thing and truth
always reigns
having muhammad ali in my life somehow
sustained my dad's breath for me
just a little while longer
51 years longer
until now
[Music]
[Music]
i am forever grateful
that our union on this earth together
allowed for me a continuum
of shared understanding
preserved
confidentialities
and the comfort of living in his
hometown of louisville kentucky for the
past six years
that was not a plan
and mostly for the gift of knowing and
loving his wife and children forever
forward
as my own family know
that as the last of the fraternity
reaches
the heavens
my heart is rendered everlongingly for
that tribe
tribe of purpose
tribe of significance tribe of
confidence tribe of character
tribe of duty
tribe of faith
tribe of service
we must make sure that the principle of
men and women
like muhammad ali and others
whom dedicated their very being to
assure that you get to recognize your
own glory
is sustained and passed on
like that olympic torch
my dad would often state when concluding
or parting from another
may we meet again
in the light of understanding
and i say to you with the light of that
compass by any means
necessary
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen representing the
president of the united states and mrs
obama miss valerie jarrett
[Music]
good afternoon
on behalf of president obama and mrs
obama
i wish to express to you their deepest
regret
that they couldn't be with us here today
as we celebrate
the extraordinary life of muhammad ali
i first met muhammad ali over 45 years
ago through his friendship with my uncle
jean double
and he my uncle would be so touched that
his son gene is a pallbearer here today
thank you lonnie
because of my family connection the
president and first lady
asked me if i would read
this tribute to you
penned by president obama
it was 1980
an epic career was in its twilight
everybody knew it
probably including the champ himself
ali went into one of his final fights an
underdog
all of the smart money was on the new
champ
larry holmes
and in in the end the oddsmakers were
right
a few hours later at 4 00 am after the
loss
after the fans had gone home and the
sports writers were writing their final
take
a sports writer asked a restroom
attendant
if he'd bet on the fight
the man
black and getting on in years
said he'd put his money on ali
the writer asked why
why the man said why because he's
muhammad ali
that's why
he said mr i'm 72 years old
and i owe the man for giving me my
dignity
[Applause]
talani and the ali family
president clinton and an arena full of
distinguished guests you are amazing
the man we celebrate today is not just a
boxer
or a poet
or an agitator or a man of peace
he was not just a muslim or a black man
or a louisville kid though i know you
wish that was it louisville this
wonderful city
he wasn't even just the greatest of all
time
he was muhammad ali
the hole far greater than the sum of its
parts
he was bigger brighter and more original
and influential than just about anyone
of his era
[Applause]
you couldn't have made him up and yes he
was pretty too
he had fans in every city every village
every ghetto on the planet
he was spattered by foreign heads of
states
the beatles
british invasion took a detour to come
to him
it seemed sometimes that the champ was
simply too big for america
but i actually think that the world
flocked to him in wonder
precisely because as he once put it
muhammad ali was america
brash defiant pioneering
joyful
never tired always game to test the odds
he was our most basic freedoms
religion
speech spirit
he embodied our ability to invent
ourselves
his life spoke to our original sin of
slavery and discrimination
and the journey he traveled helped to
shock our consciousness
and lead us on a roundabout path
towards salvation
and like america he was always
very much a work in progress
we do him a disservice to gauze up his
story
to
to talk only of floating like
butterflies and stinging like bees
ali was a radical even in a radical of
times a loud and proud
and unbashably black voice in a jim crow
world
[Applause]
his jabs knocked some sense into us
yes they did pushing us to expand our
imagination
and bring others into our understanding
now there were times when he swung a bit
wildly that's right
wound up and accidentally may have
wronged the wrong opponent as he was the
first to admit
but through all his triumphs and
failures
ali seemed to achieve the sort of
enlightenment
and inner peace
that we are all striving towards
in the 60s when other young men his age
were leaving the country to avoid avoid
war or jail
he was asked why he didn't join them
he got angry he said he'd never leave
his people in his words are here
the millions struggling for freedom and
justice and equality and i can do a lot
of help in jail or not
right here in america
[Applause]
he'd have everything stripped from him
his titles his standing his money his
passion very nearly his freedom
but ali still chose america
i imagine he knew
that only here in this country
could he win it all back
so he chose to help perfect a union
where a descendant of slaves can become
the king of the world
[Applause]
and in the process in the process
lend some dignity to all of us
maids porters
students
an elderly bathroom attendant
and help inspire a young
mixed kid
with a funny name to have the audacity
to believe he could be anything
even the president of the united states
[Applause]
muhammad ali was america muhammad ali
will always be
america
what a man
what a spirit
what a joyous
mightful champion
god bless the greatness
of ali
god bless his family
and god bless this nation we love thank
you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
loni ali
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
aye salam
peace be upon you
you know i said something to matt lauer
yesterday
that i firmly believe muhammad had
something to do with all of this
and i think we are right
thank you all for being here to share
in this final farewell to muhammad
on behalf of the ali family let me first
recognize our principal
celebrant imam zayat shakir
and also dr timothy giannatti
[Applause]
we thank you for your dedication to
helping us fulfill muhammad's desire
that the ceremonies of this past week
reflect the traditions of his islamic
faith
and as a family we thank the millions of
people
who through the miracle of social media
inspired by their love for muhammad have
reached out to us with their prayers
the messages have come in every language
from every corner of the globe
from wherever you are watching
know that we have been humbled
by your heartfelt expressions of love
it is only fitting that we gather in a
city
to which muhammad always returned after
his great triumphs
a city that has grown as muhammad has
grown
muhammad never stopped loving louisville
and we know that louisville loves
muhammad
we cannot forget a louisville police
officer
joe espy martin
who embraced
a young 12 year old boy
in distress when his bicycle was stolen
[Applause]
[Music]
joe martin handed young cassius clec
clay
sorry for tripping over that last word
clay the keys to a future in boxing he
could scarcely have imagined
america must never forget
that when a cop and an inner city kid
talk to each other
then
miracles can happen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
struggled with parkinson's in a meeting
that included his closest advisors
muhammad indicated that when the end
came for him
when his he wanted us to use his life
and his death as a teaching moment for
young people for his country and for the
world
in effect he wanted us to remind people
who were suffering
that he had seen the face of injustice
that he grew up in a segregation and
that during his early life he was not
free to be who he wanted to be
but he never became embittered enough to
quit or to engage in violence
it was a time
[Applause]
it was a time when a young black boy his
age
could be hung from a tree
emma teal in money mississippi in 1955
whose admitted killers went free
it was a time when muhammad's friends
men that he admired like brother malcolm
dr king
were gunned down
and nelson mandela imprisoned for what
they believed in
[Applause]
for his part muhammad faced federal
prosecution
he was stripped of his title and his
license to box and he was sentenced to
prison
but he would not be intimidated so as to
abandon his principles and his values
[Applause]
muhammad wants young people of every
background to see his life as proof
that adversity can make you stronger
it cannot rob you of the power to dream
and to reach your dreams
we built the muhammad ali center and
that is the essence of the ali center
message
[Applause]
muhammad wants us to see the face of his
religion al-islam true islam
as the face of love
it was his religion that caused him to
turn away from war and violence
for his religion he was prepared to
sacrifice all that he had and all that
he was to protect his soul
and follow the teachings of prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
[Applause]
so even in death muhammad has something
to say
he is saying that his faith required
that he take the more difficult road
it is far more difficult to be to
sacrifice oneself in the name of peace
than to take up arms in pursuit of
violence
[Applause]
[Music]
you know all of his life muhammad was
fascinated by travel
he was childlike in his encounter with
new surroundings and new people
he took his world championship fights to
the ends of the earth
from the south pacific to europe to the
belgian congo
and of course with muhammad he believed
it was his duty
to let everyone see him in person
because after all he was the greatest of
all time
the boy from grand avenue in louisville
louisville kentucky
grew in wisdom from his
discovered something new
that the world really wasn't black and
white at all
it was filled with many shades of rich
colors languages and religions
and as he moved with ease around the
world the rich and powerful were drawn
to him
but he was drawn to the poor and the
forgotten
muhammad fell in love with the masses
and they fell in love with him
in the diversity of men and their faith
muhammad saw the presence of god
he was captivated by the work of the
dalai lama
by mother teresa and church workers who
gave their lives to protect the poor
when his mother died he arranged for
multiple faiths to be represented at her
funeral
and he wanted the same for himself
we are especially grateful for the
presence of the diverse faith leaders
here today and i would like to ask them
to stand once more and be
[Applause]
thank you very recognized
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know as i reflect on the life of my
husband
it's easy to see his most obvious
talents
his majesty in the ring as he danced
under those lights
enshrined him as a champion for the ages
less obvious was his extraordinary sense
of timing
his knack for being in the right place
at the race at the right time
seemed to be ordained by a higher power
even though surrounded by jim crow he
was born into a family with two parents
that nurtured and encouraged him
he was placed on the path of his dreams
by a white cop
and he had teachers who understood his
dreams and wanted him to succeed
the olympic gold medal came
and the world started to take notice
a group of successful businessmen in
louisville
called the louisville sponsoring group
saw his potential
and helped him build a runway to launch
his career
his timing was impeccable as he burst
into the national stage
justice television was hungry for a star
to change the face of sports
you know if muhammad didn't like the
rules he rewrote them
his religion his name his beliefs were
his to fashion
no matter what the cost
the timing of his actions coincided with
a broader shift in cultural attitudes
across america
particularly on college campuses
when he challenged the u s government on
the draft
his chance of success was slim to none
that the timing of his decision
converged with a rising tide of
discontent
on the war
public opinion shifted in his direction
followed by a unanimous supreme court
ruling
in a stunning reversal of
of fortunes
he was free to return to the ring
when he traveled to central africa to
reclaim his title from george foreman
none of the sports writers thought he
could win in fact most of them feared
for his life
but in what the africans call the
miracle at 4 am
he became a champion once more
[Music]
and as the years passed and though
slowed by parkinson's
muhammad was compelled by his faith to
use his name and his notoriety to
support the victims of poverty and
strife
he served as a u.n messenger of peace
and traveled to places like warren torn
afghanistan
he campaigned as an advocate for
reducing the yoke of third world debt
he stunned the world when he secured the
release of 15 hostages from iraq
[Music]
as his voice grew softer
his message took on greater meaning
he came full circle with the people of
his country
when he lit a torch that seemed to
create new light in the 1996 olympics
[Music]
muhammad always knew instinctively the
road he needed to travel
his friends know what i mean when i say
he lived in the moment he neither
dwelled in the past nor harbored anxiety
about the future
muhammad
loved to laugh and he loved to play
practical jokes on just about everybody
he was sure footed in his self-awareness
secured his faith and he did not fear
death
yet his timing is once again pointy
his passing and his meaning for our time
should not be overlooked
as we face uncertainty in a world and
divisions at home
as to who we are as a people
muhammad's life provides useful guidance
muhammad was not one to give up on the
power of understanding the boundless
possibilities of love
and the strength of our diversity
he counted among his friends people of
all political persuasions
saw truth in all faiths and
the nobility of all
races as witnessed here today
muhammad may have challenged his
government
but he never ran from it or from america
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he loved this country and he understood
the hard choices that are born of
freedom
i think he saw a nation's soul measured
by the soul of its people
for his part he saw the good soul in
everyone
and if you were one of the lucky ones to
have met him you know what i meant
he awoke every morning thinking about
his own salvation and he would often say
i just want to get to heaven and i've
got to do a lot of good deeds to get
there
and i think muhammad's hope is that his
life provides
some guidance on how we might achieve
for all people what we aspire for
ourselves and our families thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen miriam ali
[Applause]
peace be with you everyone here
and on behalf of the ali family
i just want to say thank you to
louisville kentucky
all the love you've shown us in our
lives has been
unbelievable
also i want to thank the entire globe my
father was loved all over
the processional today was overwhelming
but it was so beautiful
i just want to say we love you just like
you love us thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
as you know my father loved poetry he
was always rhyming and promoting his
fights and he had poems of the heart
spiritual poems and
you know forms to promote and i just
wrote a piece for him in honor of him
on behalf of uh my sisters and brothers
and everyone who loves my father
it's called thank you our dear father
my heart
was sore
when your spirit soared
your physical body is no more
but my mind tells different tales of all
that you taught me
your family and the masses
most importantly
the belief in god who created humanity
to thrive in equality
you fought for a purpose to uphold the
principle that we as a people
have divine human rights
staring right into the eyes of
oppression you proclaim your beautiful
complexion
your god-given skills
your independent will
and the freedom of your faith
as your daughter
i am grateful for all of our
conversations about men women in
relationships
guiding me to first
have a loving relationship with
refusing anyone to chip away in my
esteem
and expect the respect of a queen
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you our dear father
for asking us to think about our purpose
and showing us the beauty of service to
others
we marveled at your sincere love for
people as you treated all who approached
you with dignity
whether they were rich or poor
your kindness was unconditional
never perceiving anyone as beneath you
so many have shared personal stories
about what you have meant to them
as you have exemplified values and
qualities that have enhanced their lives
if i had every dollar for every story i
could paper the sky
your family is so proud of the legacy
you left behind
but i hope
that the history of you
can help turn the tide of self-hate and
violence because we are overwhelmed with
moments of silence for tragic deaths
[Applause]
here on the soil
american soil
in the middle east or anywhere else in
this world
we crave for peace
the peace that you rest in now
we will forever cherish the 74 years you
graced this earth
you will be greatly missed
but now
we send you off in celebration
a blown kiss and prayers
as you enter your final round
god's last boxing bell was sound
in heaven i love you
we all love you
thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen rashida ali walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i am we are so honored that you have
packed
this room with your love thank you all
[Applause]
thank you so much for being here today
to celebrate
our father
you are the greatest father to us
and it was god's will
to take you home
your family will try our best to make
you proud
and carry on your legacy of giving and
love
you have inspired us
and the world
to be the best version of ourselves
may you live in paradise
free
from suffering
you shook up the world in life
now you're shaking up the world in death
[Applause]
daddy's looking at us now writing saying
i told you i was the greatest
no one compares to you daddy
you once said
i know where i'm going and i know the
truth and i don't have to be what you
want me to be
i'm free to be who i am
[Applause]
now you are free
to be with your creator
we love you so much daddy
until we meet again
fly butterfly
fly
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
hello
my name is ali dinacola i was born on
muhammad ali's birthday it was named
after him
he used to call me the little greatest
we can all learn from muhammad example
of kindness and understanding
[Music]
when muhammad was asked how he would
like to be remembered he said
i like to i like for them to say
he took a few cups of love
he took one tablespoon of patience
one teaspoon of generosity
one pint of kindness
he took one quart of laughter
one pinch of concern and then he mixed
willingness with happiness
he added lots of faith and he stirred it
up well
that he spread it over a span of a
lifetime
and he served it to each and every
deserving person he met thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen natasha
[Music]
before i begin
i would just like to say that i am truly
humbled and honored to be here
and i would like to thank the muhammad
ali center and the ali family
for giving me the opportunity to speak
and to echo the voice that muhammad has
given me
[Music]
so let me tell you a story
about a man
a man
who refused to believe that reality was
limitation to achieve the impossible
a man
who once reached up through the pages of
a textbook
and touched the heart
of an eight-year-old girl
whose reflection of herself
mirrored those who cannot see past the
color of her skin
but instead of drawing on that pain from
the distorted reality
she found
strength
just as this man did
when he stood tall in the face of
pelting rain and shouted i am the
disturbance
in the sea of your complacency and i
will never stop shaking your waves
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and his voice
echoed through hers
through mine
and she picked up the rocks that were
thrown at her
and she threw them back with a voice so
powerful
that it turned all the pain that she had
faced in her life
into strength and tenacity
and now
that eight-year-old girl stands before
you
to tell you
that ali's cry still shakes these waves
today
[Applause]
that we are to find strength in our
identities
whether we are black
or white
or asian or hispanic
lgbt
disabled or able-bodied
muslim
jewish
hindu or christian
his cry represents those who have not
been heard and invalidates the idea that
we are to be conformed to one normative
standard
that
is what it means to defeat the
impossible
because impossible is not a fact
impossible is an opinion
impossible is nothing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when i look into this crowd i smile
i smile to recognize
that he is not really gone
he lives in you
and he lives in me
and he lives in every person that he has
touched in every corner of this world
[Applause]
[Music]
reality was never a limitation for ali
for us
just as every punch his opponents threw
impossible is never enough to knock us
down because we are ali
we are greater than the rocks or the
punches that we throw at each other
we have the ability to empower and
inspire and to connect and to unify and
that will live on forever
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so let me tell you a story about a man
his name is
muhammad ali
he is
the greatest of all time
[Applause]
he is from louisville kentucky and he
lives in each and every one of us
and his story
is far from over thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
ladies and gentlemen
john ramsey
first of all on behalf of my fellow
louisvillians to the ali family we offer
our condolences
our heartfelt prayers
and for lonnie ali a very special prayer
we know that muhammad was blessed with
many gifts but none more precious than
lani ali and we thank you so much
[Music]
you know
i've got to tell you louisville when i
was in the procession today and i saw
the tens of thousands of people and all
the warmth and the love
and the respect
that was shown for muhammad i got to
tell you my heart swelled with pride
i know he was watching from above and i
know he absolutely loved it
yeah
but i don't think he'd be surprised
i i think muhammad would say
louisville kentucky the greatest city of
old times i'm feeling good man
[Music]
i'll tell you what how can we lose with
the stuff we use
i'm i'm feeling so good i think i'm
gonna make a comeback and change my name
back to walnut street that's how good i
feel
you know
[Applause]
for me
i always felt connected to muhammad even
before i had met him you know maybe it
was the fact that i was a louisville boy
maybe it's the fact that i love the
louisville cardinals
like muhammad
you know
but as our relationship evolved i found
that a lot of people
felt this personal connection with
muhammad
and that's part of the ali magic
you know initially for a lot of men my
age and certainly myself it was the
athlete that i was attracted to
i mean
that kind of size that kind of speed
agility that grace not only made him the
heavyweight champion of the world three
times
but it made him sports illustrated
sportsman of the century
the ap athlete of the century
certainly it made him the athlete a
once-in-a-lifetime athlete but i would
argue
that the combination
of compassion kindness
love and the ability to lift us up made
him a once in a lifetime person
[Applause]
you know muhammad was blessed with many
gifts as i said
and he was a wise and faithful steward
of those gifts
it's many stories about muhammad but
there's a couple that really to me
encapsulate what he was all about
i remember um back in 2000 i made a trip
to the summer olympics with muhammad
and one day he decided we would go see a
boxing match
and
i remember
we're ringside the american winds 15 000
people are chanting usa usa
and i thought this is my olympic moment
you know i was filled with patriotic
pride
the boxer came down from the ring he
took the obligatory picture with
muhammad the fist to chin shot
hundreds of photographers from around
the world were taking pictures you know
thousands of people cheering for
muhammad in this victorious fighter
and then muhammad leaned down to me
whispered in my ear i said i want to see
the loser
say excuse me
i want to see the loser
so
i motioned over to an olympic official i
said you know muhammad wants to see the
loser can we go to the losing locker
room
and we get to the losing locker room and
there's not tens of thousands of people
there's not any photographers they're
just a kid in the corner on a stool he's
got a towel around his neck
he's got a bloody mouse under his eye
this has got to be the lowest point of
his athletic career at the very least
felt like he let down his country he's
defeated
and the vibe in that room was literally
the lowest of low
but then when muhammad walks in this kid
recognizes him instantly
and in broken english he says muhammad
ali
and muhammad started dancing show me
what you got man show me and muhammad
starts throwing out jabs and this kid
starts ducking and smiling muhammad
grabs him in a bear hug he said i saw
what you did out there man you look good
man you're moving good you can be a
champion man you don't give up
and i remember
it warmed my heart how he took this kid
from here
to here in an instant
and
[Applause]
and i remember i got in the car and i
said to muhammad i said muhammad i try
to be a nice guy but i've got to tell
you i was caught up in the moment i
didn't give that losing fighter a second
thought i said muhammad
you're the greatest mohammed said tell
me something i don't already know
[Music]
and
but what i don't want people to forget
no doubt to me he is the finest example
of a human that i've ever seen the
finest example
of a great human being that i've ever
seen of the kindness that a human
possesses that was muhammad ali but
don't forget about this man muhammad was
the coolest cat in the room
i mean
he was good looking he had charm he had
charisma
he had swagger before he knew what
swagger was
i mean
i remember
went to uh when his about 25 years ago
he came in town to visit his mother and
he wanted to go to outback steakhouse
had a friend there was a big muhammad
fan so we come in and at the time here
in louisville there was a fireman's
convention and all of these guys had
their engine numbers on their shirt and
sure enough i'd seen this scene a
million times man these guys line up for
an autograph and i say to muhammad i
said muhammad if you'd like i'll play
the bad guy you know i'll tell them to
let you eat and you can sign autographs
later muhammad would have none of it
he's like no i'll sign between bites so
he's
taking bites of his food and he's
signing this one guy walks up and you
can tell he's a big fan i mean he knew
muhammad he was scared to death
all this adrenaline flowing he said
champ he said i saw the stance you made
in the civil rights movement i saw your
stance against the vietnam war he said
i've got to tell you champ you're my
hero he said i've got a picture of you
at the firehouse you're my hero muhammad
instantly he wanted to change the
channel
so he said to the guy he said
you know you you the real hero jumping
in fire saving lives saving babies
putting your life on the line he said
man
you the real hero
and the fireman responds real quickly i
mean he knew all the nicknames he said
man but you you fought the bear sonny
listen
he's no he says you fought the rabbit
floyd patterson you fought big george
foreman you smile you fought smoking
joel frazier muhammad interrupted him
real quick and he goes yeah but joe
wasn't really smoking
[Applause]
and
and i said muhammad that's a good line
he goes you're right write that down
but
it wasn't all about signing autographs
and kissing babies
you know if there was a village that
needed food
in a third world country muhammad was on
plane will travel with check if there
was a conflict and he could be part of a
resolution again muhammad will travel
aslani had mentioned if there were
hostages to be released muhammad was a
man of action
one of my favorite quotes and i think
it's right here in your program
muhammad
said service to others is the rent you
pay for your room here on earth
and i just want to say champ
your rent is paid in full
your rent is paid in full
your rent is paid in full
[Applause]
[Music]
you know
[Music]
and in fact i think he's paid it forward
because he has taught us to love rather
than to hate to look for commonalities
rather than differences
and so therefore i think he's really
paid it forward for all of us
so
as we all know now
you know the fight is over but i'm here
to tell you
the decision is in
and it is unanimous
because of muhammad ali we all win the
world wins thank you so much muhammad
[Applause]
it is time for a man of peace
to rest in peace and thank you so very
much
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen billy crystal
[Applause]
thank you ladies and gentlemen uh we're
at the halfway point
i was clean-shaven when this started
dear lonnie family friends
mr president
members of the clergy all these amazing
people here in louisville
today
this outpouring of love and respect
proves that 35 years
after he stopped fighting
he is still the champion of the world
last week
when we heard the news
time stopped
there was no war there were no
terrorists no global catastrophes the
world stopped
took a deep breath
inside
since then my mind has been racing
through my relationship with this
amazing man which is now
42 years that i know him every moment i
can think of is cherished and while
others can tell you of his
accomplishments he wanted me to speak
and tell you of some personal moments
that we had together i met him in 1974 i
was just getting started as a stand-up
comedian and struggling but i had one
good routine
it was a three-minute conversation
between howard cosell
muhammad ali where i would imitate both
of them
ali had just defeated george foreman and
regained the heavyweight title sport
magazine
made him the man of the year and dick
shap a wonderful writer and a great man
was the editor for sport
and he was going to host this televised
dinner honoring muhammad ali so dick
called my agent looking for a comedian
who did some sports material as fate
would have it
that comedian was not available and she
wisely said
it's destiny man
and she wisely said listen i got this
young kid
and he does this great imitation of
alien cosette would be perfect for us i
don't know why but dick said okay
i'll try him
if he thinks i can cut him out of the
show
i couldn't believe it my first time on
television and it would be with ali
i rather the plaza hotel the event was
jammed i met mr shap who would later
become a part of my family and he said
well how should i introduce you nobody
knows who you are
and i said
just say one of ali's closest and
dearest friends
and my thought was
i'll get right to the microphone go into
my howard coselle and i'll be fine and
then i nervously move into the jammed
ballroom
and that's when i saw him for the first
time in person
it's very hard to describe
how much he meant to me
you had to live in his time
it's great to look at clips and it's
amazing that we have them but to live
in his time
watching his fights
is experiencing the genius of his talent
was absolutely extraordinary every one
of his fights
was an aura of a super bowl he did
things nobody would do he predicted the
round that he would knock somebody out
and then he would do it
he was funny
he was beautiful he was the most perfect
athlete you ever saw and those were his
own words
[Applause]
but he was so much more than a fighter
as time went on with bobby kennedy gone
martin luther king gone malcolm x gone
who was that to relate to when vietnam
exploded in our face
there were millions of young men my age
eligible for the draft for war that we
didn't believe in all of us huddled on
the conveyor belt that was rapidly
feeding the war machine but it was ali
who stood up for us by standing up for
himself
and after he was stripped of the title
after he was stripped of the title and
the right to fight anywhere in the world
he gave speeches at colleges and on
television that totally reached me he
seemed as comfortable talking to kings
and queens as the lost and unrequited
he never lost his sense of humor even as
he lost everything else he was always
himself
willing to give up everything for what
he believed in and this passionate
rhetoric
about the life and plight of black
people in our country resonated strongly
in my house
i grew up on a house that was dedicated
to civil rights
my father was a producer of jazz
conscience in new york city and was one
of the first to integrate bands in the
40s and 50s
jazz musicians referred to my dad as the
branch ricky of jazz
my uncle
and my family
jewish people produce strange fruit
billy holliday's classic song describing
the lynching of african americans in
this country
and so i felt him and now there he was
just a few feet from me i couldn't stop
looking at him and he seemed to like
glow and he was like in slow motion his
amazing face smiling and laughing
i was seated a few seats from him
on the dais and in the room all of these
athletes in their individual sports
great ones
gino marchetti of the baltimore colts
frank o'hara to the steelers archie
griffin who had won the heisman from
ohio state literary legends neil simon
george clinton all on the dais fawning
over ali who then looked at me
with an expression that seemed to say
[Music]
what is joel gray doing here
mr shap introduced me as one of our
least closest and dearest friends
two people clapped
my wife and the agent
i rose ali's still staring at me i
passed right behind him got to the
podium
went right into the coast cell hello
everyone howard cosell coming to you
live from zaire some would pronounce it
there they're wrong
[Applause]
it got big laughs
and then
i went into the ali
everybody's talking about george foreman
i want to talk about george foreman
george foreman was ugly he's just so
slow george was slow i come on
and then i rope a dope a robot george
and i'm still fast at 33 years of age
i'm so fast i can turn up the lights be
in my bed before the room gets dark
[Music]
[Applause]
howard i'm announcing tonight that i got
new religious beliefs from now on i want
to be known as izzy iskowitz
i am now an orthodox jew is it yes i am
the greatest of all time
the audience exploded see no one had
ever done him before and here he was a
white kid from long island imitating the
greatest of all time
and he was loving it
when i was done
he gave me this big bear hug and he
whispered in my ear
you're my little brother
which is what he always called me
until the last time that i saw him
we were always there for each other if
he needed me for something i was there
he came to anything i asked him to do
most memorable
he was an honorary chairman for a dinner
and a very important event where i was
being honored by the hebrew university
in jerusalem he did all of this
promotion for it he came to the dinner
he sat with my family the entire evening
he took photographs with everybody the
most famous muslim man in the world
honoring his jewish friend
and
because he was there because he was
there we raised a great deal of money
and i was able to to use it to endow the
university in jerusalem was something
that i told him about
and it was something that he loved the
theory of
and it thrives to this day
it's called peace through the performing
arts
it's a theater group where israeli arab
and palestinian actors writers and
directors all work together in peace
creating original works of art
and that doesn't happen without him
i had so many
so many funny unusual moments with him i
sat next to him at howard cosell's
funeral
a very somber day to be sure
closed casket was on the stage muhammad
and i was sitting somewhere over there
next to each other
and he quietly whispered to me
little brother
do you think he's wearing his hair piece
[Applause]
so i said
i don't think so
well then how will god recognize him
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so i said champ
once he opens his mouth god will know
so we started laughing
it was a muffled left at first but then
we couldn't contain ourselves here we
were
at a funeral
me with muhammad ali left like two
little kids who heard something dirty in
church you know we're just laughing and
laughing
and then he looked at me and he
whispered
howard was a good man
one time he asked me
if i would like to run with him one
morning
do world work with him i said well
that'd be amazing where do you run he
said i run at this country club
and i run on a golf course early in the
morning it's very private nobody bothers
me we'll have a great time
i said champ
i can't run there that the club has a
reputation for being restricted well
they're stood to me
they don't allow jews there they don't
have any jewish members
he was incensed
i'm a black muslim and they let me run
there
little brother i'm never going to run
there again
and he didn't
my favorite memory
my favorite member happens was 1979.
he had just retired and there was a
retirement party at the forum los
angeles for muhammad and 20 000 of his
closest friends in los angeles
i performed a piece that i had created
the the imitation had grown into a life
story it's called 15 rounds
and i play him from the age of 18
until he's 36 ready for the rematch with
leon spinks i posted it on the internet
last week footage that nobody had ever
seen before of me portraying ali doing
his life for him
all those years ago in 1979
there were 20 000 people there
but i was doing it only for him
it's one of my favorite performances
that i've ever done in my life i sort of
got lost in him i i i didn't even know
where i was
at the end of the performance and
suddenly i'm backstage with another
heavyweight champion richard pryor
and pryor is holding on to me crying and
then i see ali coming
and he's got a full head of steam he's
looking only at me and he nudged mr
pryor aside and he whispered in my ear
with a big bear hug
little brother
you made my life better than i was
but didn't he make all of our lives a
little bit better than they were
[Applause]
that
[Applause]
that my friends is my history with a man
and i've labored to come up with a way
to describe the legend
he was a tremendous bolt of lightning
created by mother nature out of thin air
a fantastic combination of power
and beauty
we've seen still photographs of
lightning bolts at the moment of impact
ferocious and its strength magnificent
in this elegance and at the moment of
impact it lights up everything around it
so you can see everything clearly
muhammad ali struck us in the middle of
america's darkest night in the heart of
its most threatening gathering storm his
power toppled the mightiest of foes and
his intense light shined on america and
we were able to see clearly
injustice
inequality poverty pride
self-realization
courage laughter love
joy and religious freedom for all
ali forced us to take a look at
ourselves this brash young man who
thrilled us angered us confused and
challenged us
ultimately became
a silent messenger of peace
who told us that life is best when you
build bridges between people
not walls
my friends
[Music]
my friends only once in a thousand years
or so
do we get to hear a mozart or see a
picasso
read a shakespeare
ali was one of them
and yet at his heart
he was still a kid from louisville who
ran with the gods and walked with the
crippled and smiled at the foolishness
of it all
he is gone but he will never die
he was my big brother
thank you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen bryant gumbel
[Applause]
[Music]
the great maya angelou
who was herself no stranger to fame
wrote that ultimately people will forget
what you said
and people will forget what you did
but that no one will ever forget how you
made them feel
as applied to muhammad ali
the march of time may one day diminish
his boasts and his poetry
maybe even his butterflies and beads
it may even one day dull the memories of
the thriller in manila
and the rumble in the jungle
[Music]
but i doubt any of us will ever forget
how muhammad ali made us feel
i'm not talking about
how proud
he made you feel with his exploits
or how special he made you feel
when you were privileged enough
to be in his company
i'm talking about how he gripped our
hearts
and our souls
and our conscience
and made our fights his fights
for decades
people like me
who were once young semi-gifted and
black
will never forget what he freed within
us
some of us like him took pride in being
black bold and brash
and because we were so unapologetic
we were in the eyes of many
way too uppity
we were way too arrogant
yet we reveled in being like him
by stretching society's boundaries as he
did
he gave us levels of strength and
courage
we didn't even know we had
but ali's impact was not limited
to those of a certain race
or of a certain religion
or of a certain mindset
the greatness of this man
for the ages
was that he was in fact a man
for all ages
has any man ever scripted a greater ark
to his life
what does it say of a man
any man
that he can go from being viewed
as one of his country's most polarizing
figures
to arguably
its most beloved
[Applause]
and to do so without changing his nature
or for a second compromising his
principles
yeah you know
there were great causes there were great
national movements there were huge
divisions
that afforded ali unusual opportunities
to symbolize our struggles
but harry truman had it right
when he said men make history
and not the other way around
or as lauryn hill so nicely put it
consequence is no coincidence
befitting his stature as the goat
muhammad ali never shied away from a
fight
he fought not just the biggest and
baddest men of his day
inside the ropes
but outside the ring he also went
toe-to-toe with an array of critics
a seemingly endless succession of
societal norms
the architects of a vile immoral war
the u.s government
he even fought
ultimately to his detriment
the limitations of father time
strictly speaking fighting is what he
did
but he broadened that definition by
sharing his struggles with us
and by viewing our struggles as his
and so it was that at various times he
accepted and led battles
on behalf of his race
in support of his generation
in defense of his religious beliefs
and ultimately
in spite of his disease
i happen to have been overseas
working in norway
this past week
my buddy matt called
told me the champ had been taken to the
hospital
but this time it was really serious
right away i called lonnie
who was as always
a pillar of strength
and as we discussed the medical details
the doctor's views
and the ugly realities of mortality
lonnie said
bryant
the world still needs him
and indeed it does
the world needs a champion
who always worked to bridge the economic
[Music]
and social divides to threaten a nation
that he dearly loved
the world needs a champion
but always symbolize the best of islam
to offset the hatred born of fear
and the world needs a champion who
believed in fairness and inclusion
for
all
hating people because of their color is
wrong ali said
and it doesn't matter which color does
the hating
it's just plain wrong
yeah we do need muhammad ali now
we need the strength
and the hope
the compassion and the conviction
that he always demonstrated
but this time our beloved champion is
down
and for once he'll not get up
not this time
not ever again
let me close with a quick personal story
50 years ago
muhammad ali defeated george chavallo
in toronto canada
the very next day
he showed up
in my hyde park neighborhood
on the south side of chicago
as ali got out of a car in the driveway
at the home of elijah muhammad
[Music]
i happened to be next door
shooting hoops in a friend's backyard
i of course quickly ran to the fence
and for the first time in my life
[Music]
i shook the champ's hand
i was 17
[Music]
i was awestruck
and then i thought he was the greatest
now half a century
and a lifetime of experiences later
i am still awestruck
and i'm convinced more than ever
that muhammad ali's the greatest
[Applause]
[Music]
to be standing here
by virtue of his and lonnie's request
[Music]
it's mine
the honor that ali has done me
today as he goes to his grave
is one that i will take to mind god
bless you jim
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the 42nd president
of the united states the honorable
william jefferson clinton
thank you
[Music]
i can just hear
muhammad saying now
[Music]
well i thought i should be eulogized by
at least one president
and by making you last in a long long
long long line
i guarantee you a standing ovation
i'm trying to think of what has been
left unsaid
[Music]
first lonnie
[Music]
i thank you and the members
of the family for
telling me that he actually
as brian said picked us all to speak and
given me a chance to come here
i thank you for what you did to make the
second half of his life greater than the
first
[Music]
i thank you for
the
muhammad ali center
[Music]
and what it has come to represent to so
many people
[Music]
here's what i'd like to say i spend a
lot of time now
as i get older and older and older
trying to figure out
what makes people tick
how do they turn out the way they are
how do some people
refuse to become victims and
rise from every defeat
[Music]
we've all seen the beautiful
pictures of
the home muhammad ali was a boy in
and people
visiting and driving by
i think he decided
something i hope every young person here
will decide
[Music]
i think he decided very young
to write his own
life story
[Music]
i think he decided
before he
could possibly have worked it all out
and before fate and time
could work their will on him
he decided that he would not be
ever
disempowered
he decided that not his race nor his
place
now the expectations of others positive
negatives or otherwise
would
strip from him
the power
to write his own story
he decided first to use these stunning
gifts
his
strength and speed in the ring
his wit in way with words and
managing the public
and his mind and heart
to figure out at a fairly young age
who he was
[Music]
what he believed
and how to live with the consequences
of acting
on what he believed
a lot of people make it to steps one and
two
and still just can't quite manage
living with the consequences
of what he believes
for the longest time in spite of all the
wonderful things that have been said
here
i remember thinking when i was a kid
this guy is so smart
and he never got credit for being as
smart
as he was
and then
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't think he ever got the credit for
being
until later
as wise as he was
in the end besides being a lot of fun to
be around and basically
a universal soldier for our common
humanity
i will always think of muhammad as a
truly free
man
of faith
and
being a man of faith
[Music]
he realized
he would never be in full control of his
life
something like parkinson's could come
along
[Music]
but being free
he realized that life still was open to
choices
it is the choices
that muhammad ali made
that have brought us all here today
in honor and love
and
[Music]
the only other thing i'd like to say i
think we all need to really really think
about
is that the first part of his life
was dominated
by the triumph of his truly unique gifts
we should never forget them we should
never
stop looking at the movies we should
thank will smith for making his movie we
should all be
[Music]
thrilled it was a thing of
duty
but the second part of his life was more
important
because he refused to be imprisoned
by a disease that kept him hamstrung
longer than mantle mandela was kept in
prison in south africa
that is
in the second half of his life
he perfected gifts
that we all have
every single
solitary one of us
have
gifts of mind and heart
it shows that he found a way
to release them
in ways large and small
i never forget i asked lonnie she
remembered
the time when they were still living in
michigan and
i gave a speech in southwest michigan
there's an economic club there and it's
sort of a ritual when a president leaves
office
and you have to get reacclimated nobody
plays a song when you walk in a room
anymore
you don't really know what you're
supposed to do
and this club here there it's called the
economic club i think this house is
they're used to acting like you still
deserve to listen to and you've got to
get reacclimated so they came to dinner
and they sat with me at this dinner
and he knew
somehow he knew
that i was
a little off my feet that night
i was trying to imagine how to make this
new life
and so he told me
a really bad joke
and he told us so well and he laughed so
hard
that i totally got over it and had a
great time
he had that feel about
you know you
there's no textbook for that knowing
where somebody else is in their head
picking up the body language
then
lonnie
and muhammad got me to come here when we
have the dedication to the muhammad ali
center
and i was trying to be incredibly
old gray-haired elder statesman
dignified
i got to elevate this guy so i'm saying
all this
stuff in very high tone
language and mohammed sneaks up behind
me and puts his fingers up
finally after all the years that we had
been friends
my enduring image of him
is like a little reel in three shots
the boxer i thrilled to as a boy
the man i watched take the last steps to
like the olympic flame when i was
president
and
[Music]
i'll never forget it i was sitting there
in atlanta
but then we knew each other by then i
felt
i had some sense of what he was living
with and i was still weeping like a baby
seeing his hand shake and his leg shake
and knowing by god he was going to make
those last few steps
no matter what it took
the flame would be lit the fight would
be won
the spirit would be a thunder i knew it
would happen
[Music]
and
then this
[Music]
the children whose lives he touched
the young people he inspired
it's the most important thing of all
so i ask you to remember that
we all have an ollie story
it's the gifts we all have
that should be most honored today
because he released them to the world
never wasting a day
that the rest of us could see anyway
feeling sorry for himself that he had
parkinson's
knowing that more than three decades of
his life would be circumscribed in ways
[Music]
that would be chilling to the naked eye
but with the free spirit
it made his life bigger not smaller
because other people all of us
unlettered unschooled
in the unleashing said well would you
look at that
look at that
may not be able to run across a ring
anymore may not be able to dodge
everybody and exhaust everybody anymore
and he's bigger than ever
because he is a free man
of faith
sharing the gifts we all have
we should honor him by letting our gifts
go
among the world
as he did god bless you
my friend go in peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
huh
there will be time for that
but right now is a time for silence so
will everyone rise
and observe
[Music]
a period of silence reflect on what
the champ meant to you
as the ali family exits
right
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
good job
ladies and gentlemen thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
i appreciate it
be seated be seated the program is not
over we're trying to create space for
the family to be able to exit in peace
please
be seated
we need we want to make prayer i want to
share something
before we close the program
so please be seated
[Music]
as we remove move towards the end of the
program which will occur in a couple of
minutes
i will be remiss
if i didn't say the following
indeed
as we all know and anyone who lives
within a ghetto or barrio
here in the united states that indeed
there are violent
racist
reckless
policemen
that's a fact
but there also are policemen and women
who are dedicated professionals
who are compassionate
who have great
concern for their communities
and i can say with all honesty and
openness
during my past week here in louisville
kentucky or past five days
myself my wife dr giannatti everyone
that i've spoken to has commented
on the professionalism
the the
dignity
of
the policemen here and women in
louisville kentucky
that we've interacted with
[Music]
and i'm sure there are bad apples here
too
but as they say one bad apple doesn't
spoil the whole bunch
now
they asked me to make a prayer to close
this service
but reverend cosby threw down the
gauntlet
with that west end poem
so
i'm going to have to respond
this poem
was written in muhammad ali's house
and muhammad ali was the first one to
hear this poem
and i'm glad mike tyson left
it's two parts part one is ali the
fighter
he floated like a butterfly and stained
like a bee
the greatest fighter this world is yet
to see his opponents agree on one thing
they all got it right in the ring with
ali your life was in danger that night
had he lived during the time of jack
johnson joe lewis martian or max
smelling his superiority over all of the
former would be telling had he fought
tyson or holyfield at the height of his
career
on the list of heavyweight champions
their names would not appear if reindeer
could box he would afford donner and
blitzen if presidents could fight he
would have richard nixon for his right
was filled with power and his left was
relentless he beat people so bad he have
to engage in active acts of repentance
so when you discuss who was the greatest
heavyweight of all time to mention any
name other than ali's is a crying
[Applause]
then part two part two is ali the man
with the grace of a butterfly and and
the tenacity of a bee
he struck many a blow against injustice
and in dignity
and inequality coming of age during a
time of legal secret segregation
he came to embody the highest values of
the nation standing up for the truth
defying the war-mongering throng he
declared i ain't got no quarrel with
them vietcong he would not take up the
gun he refused to pull the trigger he
quipped ain't no viet cong ever called
me [ __ ]
knowing when to attack and when to
retreat
he brought an entire nation to his feet
not to cheer for his exploits going down
in the ring but to fall right in line
with malcolm and king
willing to give up his title the money
the lights he dedicated himself to a
higher fight the fight for truth and
justice to liberate lands occupied by
the highest court in the land his case
would not be denied with a heart made of
gold and a spirit to match he was all he
was able to rebuild his life almost
starting from scratch with the tongue
with the torch of love
and the flame of good
he lit the fire of hope in the hearts of
many boys and girls in the hood
not knowing the word i can't he was
never def deterred and because of his
the example many a dream was not
deferred
on
on the heart of every life he touched
he left an indelible stamp
and he will always be known
as the people's champion
[Applause]
[Music]
now
we have to make the prayer
muhammad ali's spirit
his body is down
but his spirit is up
and it will stay up as long as we keep
it up
and we keep it up as long as we live
with the grace and dignity he lived with
as long as we love with the passion he
loved with
as long as we share and care and give
with the bounded boundless generosity he
exemplified
so god as we leave this hall as we
depart from this august gathering
may we be blessed
to love as he loved
to live as he lived
to share as he shared
to care as he cared
to the extent of our various capacities
and to float
as freely
as he floated
god bless
and blessings and peace upon muhammad
good evening
[Music]
that's a look at some of the events book
tv will be covering this week
many of these events are open to the
public look for them to air in the near
future on book tv on c-span 2.
hey good evening
thank you for coming i am carrie rod i'm
the programming coordinator for st louis
county library and i'm very pleased to
present tonight's program with acclaimed
sports historian lee montville i'd like
to thank our presenting sponsor
maryville university and our bookseller
barnes and noble the team from the
chesterfield barnes noble has the books
for sale in the back of the room please
do consider buying the book tonight
purchasing the book helps support this
author series and help us bring more
great authors to st louis
lee will sign copies at this table after
the talk we just line you up by row and
get it going very efficiently
so tonight's event is presented by the
buzz westfall favorite author series
this program was started in 2004 and
presents authors of politics history and
sports
you can visit the program for a list of
the businesses and organizations that
sponsor the westfall series our next
westfall event will be next month no
next tuesday may 23rd we're going to
host our fixed first fiction writer in
the westfall series when jeff shara will
be here he is a
writer who writes sort of military
histories it's all history based but
they're sort of novelizations of
historical events and this book is
called the frozen hours and is about the
korean war
but on to tonight's program
lee montville is a former columnist at
the boston globe and a former senior
writer for sports illustrated he's
written new york times best-selling
biographies of such iconic and
fascinating sports figures as babe ruth
ted williams evel knievel and dale
earnhardt
tonight he will share his new biography
of one of the most celebrated and
controversial athletes of the 20th
century muhammad ali which is very
appropriately titled sting like a bee
montville narrows his focus to a
somewhat overlooked period of ali's life
his struggle as a conscientious draft
objector during the tumultuous vietnam
era and the subsequent legal battle that
took him all the way to the supreme
court
masterfully researched and told with
great suspense staying like a bee is an
inspiring account of the highs and lows
of an exceptional individual and never
fails to capture the charisma and
complexity of muhammad ali please help
me welcome lee monfil
[Applause]
thank you for that nice introduction um
it's nice to be in st louis uh i
celebrated i bought a new pair of pants
for this
from
nautica discount
outlet and the last time i bought a new
pair of pants to come to one of these i
gave the whole talk and i walked out and
i saw again along the side of the pants
there was a long plastic thing that said
32 by 30 32 by 30 32 830 and so i i was
very careful in uh taking the pants and
straightening things out um
muhammad ali that this should be like
the greatest book talk ever the greatest
book talk of all time because we're
talking about muhammad ali
you say there's a million books on
muhammad ali out there and why should
there be another book and that's a very
good question why is this guy writing
this book
the last book i wrote was was about evil
knievel
and i finished that and we were talking
what i should do next with my publisher
and i think most writers want to do
sort of that obscure story that nobody
knows sort of the seabiscuit kind of
thing
where america all of a sudden discovers
this great story and and falls in love
with it and so i i proposed doing a book
about
a guy named will mcdonough who was a
writer at the boston globe when i was
there
he he had some
mob connections and things like that and
told great stories and he was probably
the most charismatic guy i knew and my
editor said
well could you write out about a 25-page
proposal on this and i did i wrote out
the 25 page proposal
and he turned it down in about five
seconds and he said you need to to write
about some iconic athlete so i wrote a
list of iconic athletes you know and i
wrote
i don't know johnny united bill russell
uh
you know walter pate and they all seem
to have been done they were all they
were all books on those guys and then i
put down muhammad ali and i said that's
the most iconic guy of all i mean he's
the most iconic athlete that's ever
been in the united states been in the
world
and i said maybe there's something in
there
and that the time period i came up with
on the the last big book on muhammad ali
uh
was was written by by the uh
the editor of the new yorker um
david remnick and it was written in 1997
and it covered the time in ali's life
from when he was born in louisville
until he won the world title and fought
sunny liston
and uh
it it it ended right there and i said
well what if i take the time period
that that went from there and when he
had the trouble with the
with the draft board and the united
states government and uh and kind of go
with that
and and i said that to my editor and and
i gave him the the proposed title you
know muhammad ali versus the united
states of america
and he said could you write me two
paragraphs on that and so i wrote the
two paragraphs and the next day he
called up and said we got a deal we're
going to do this
so that's how i'm doing it and
and i found as i got into it there were
a couple of great reasons to be doing it
um i'm 18 months younger than muhammad
ali was and so
i was going through
the same stuff with the draft and the
vietnam war in the 60s and i got married
around the same time as him and his
draft problems came up around the time
my draft problems came up and uh
so that that that i really hooked in on
that that the vietnam war kind of
changed a lot of lives just about
everybody i'd say my age kind of
was affected somehow i mean i knew guys
that got married to stay out of the
draft i knew guys who
started careers in education when they
had no
reason to be in education and they've
been in education all their lives
because of the draft because you get a
deferment
i myself i would have gone i graduated
from the university of connecticut
i would have gone to paris or somewhere
like that and kind of bummed around for
a while but you really couldn't do that
so i went to uh 15 different national
guard outfits and you know said gee i'd
love to go there and i found some outfit
that actually needed somebody and i
wound up in
in fort jackson and the first time i
flew on an airplane was from fort
jackson to st louis um to go to fort
leonard wood
and we hitch we hitchhiked once to st
louis from from fort leonard wood we
stayed in some kid's room at uh the
washington university and then we went
to hitchhike back and we got stranded in
rala missouri
we we stood by the exit there for six
hours waiting for somebody to pick us up
and finally a guy came he had a truck
that that only had that third gear was
stripped and he he kind of chugged over
and he picked us up and he took us home
and i promised to god that i would i
would for from that moment on that i
would always pick up every hitchhiker
that i saw
but i i kind of broke that promise i
think and i'm sorry god
so
the draft affected everyone and muhammad
ali
when he first
the first thing that happened with
muhammad ali was in 1964 right when we
when he was fighting sunny listen um he
was called up to to go for his draft
physical at the age of 18.
and he went for the the physical and the
mental test and he flunked the mental
test
he uh he he really couldn't read very
well and and uh couldn't write very well
and and math was was probably he was
dyslexic i i think
and uh so he flunked the the mental test
and then he flunked it again and he had
a score of like 16 on the test
and and uh that that was underneath the
barrier plus then he got married so he
was out in two different things he was
four rough and he was married
well then he he fought sunny listen a
second time and he got divorced he had
joined the nation of islam and and he
got divorced because his wife wouldn't
conform to the the nation of islam she
wouldn't dress like that and wouldn't
follow the religion
and so he now is eligible that way and
vietnam was just chewing up people
and so they they dropped they dropped
the test and so now his 16 passed the
test instead of flunk the test and uh he
was called in to to be in the service
and uh
he was called into he was changed to 1a
and that happened that happened in 1966
and uh
i'll kind of read you what he said
when that happened
um
when he said
you can edit out this part where he
looks for the uh looks for the thing in
the book
um
when he when he when he was reclassified
1a and the reporters all stood around
outside outside he was he had gone into
training to fight
he was going to fight ernie terrell in
chicago
and he was in miami beach when he found
out and he came out in front of this
house where he was he was living and
reporters put put on the cameras and
stuff and he said he said this he said
i can't understand how they can do this
to me
why be anxious to take me a man who pays
the salary of at least two hundred
thousand men a year two hundred thousand
men you here i can't understand out of
all the baseball players all the
football players all the basketball
players why seek out me who's the
world's only heavyweight champion
why are they so anxious to pay me 80
dollars a month me who in two fights for
six who in two fights pays for six new
jet planes i'm fighting for the
government every day i'm laying my life
on the line for the government every day
nine out of ten soldiers would want not
want to be in my place in the ring it's
too dangerous
for two years the army told everybody i
was a nut and i was ashamed and now they
decide i'm a wise man they embarrassed
my parents everybody was asking them
questions asking me asking them if i was
a nut even my ex-wife was ashamed yeah
it bothered me a bit now without ever
testing testing me to see if i'm wiser
or worser than before they decide i can
go in the army so he said all that stuff
and more and
the next day
he gave that the quote that became
famous or infamous around the country
was i i i don't have any quarrel with
those viet cong
and that kind of seemed to be
at the time
you know when the the war was was just
kind of picking up it almost seemed
seditious you know that uh
that he was he was like align himself
with the enemy and uh
his his popularity kind of just went
down in a minute and uh the fight with
ernie terrell was canceled in chicago
and and and a whole bunch of stuff he
took a big public relations hit
and the reason
he objected to the war
was because he was a member of the
nation of islam it that was his his
total reason he was a true believer in
in the nation of islam
and the nation of islam was sort of an
offshoot of islam with um
with a different
a different kind of theology on the side
of of the white devils and and
oppressing the the black man and uh
and and
just a different theology and the the
idea was why should a black man fight in
the white man's war the honorable elijah
muhammad who is the head of the nation
of islam um he had served four years in
jail during world war ii and a bunch of
members of the religion that had served
time in jail for not going to korea
and
muhammad ali was was in that line in
his religious thinking
and so he applied for conscientious
objector status
which which entailed a bunch of things
he he had a lawyer named edward jacko
who had been been a big lawyer for
malcolm x um in in the nation of islam
up in harlem he was called jaco the
giant killer because he had beaten the
government on a bunch of things
and uh
they filed a thing for conscientious
objector
and as part of that he had to go see a
special judge
and they brought in a retired judge this
is part of the the apparatus for
applying as a conscious anxious objector
they brought in a retired judge to talk
um to decide
whether or not he should be a
conscientious objector and this was
ali's one time that he he could
really state his case and the guy here
was 65 years old his name was lawrence
grauman
and he was in louisville kentucky and he
wasn't known as a a big civil rights guy
at all you know he was kind of a country
club guy in louisville um
and
he you wouldn't think he would ali would
have much of a chance
and
he had a new lawyer now a a guy named
hayden covington who had been a defender
of the jehovah's witnesses for a long
time
and hayden covington had been the most
successful lawyer
ever to to to appeal cases to the u.s
supreme court he had gotten a lot of
jehovah's witnesses
out of serving in the army and there had
been a lot of cases about jehovah's
witnesses refusing to
to say the pledge of allegiance and
stand and salute the flag and things
like that
so they they went they went before this
judge grauman ali stated his case the
fbi presented a file and judge brauman
went off to decide on this
and after about three weeks judge
grauman decided that ali should be a
conscientious objector and he filed his
thing with the justice department and it
was a non-binding decision and the
justice department
said well that's very nice which what
judge grauman said but
we think you draft word 47 really should
consider muhammad ali 1a and he should
be drafted so the justice department
overrode what he said uh what judge
grauman said and a way we went for this
whole thing
where eventually
ellie uh was was called for induction
into the army in in houston and he
refused to step forward
and
that caused him to
every every state that started starting
with the new york athletic commission
every state kind of rescinded his
heavyweight championship
and uh and and took it away and the the
justice department um had his passport
suspended so he couldn't go anywhere
else in the world to fight so he was out
of a job
and
a three and a half year
period started then
he got married again to a 17 year old
girl belinda boyd who was a member of
the nation of islam had kind of had
grown up in the nation of islam school
and and her parents were friends with
the honorable elijah muhammad and
she probably knew more about the
religion than anybody and the two of
them kind of went off to figure out life
and he was making no money he had spent
all his money and he wound up doing
these college college campus things
where he went around to colleges and uh
presented his case to the college kids
and uh
he wasn't
he he wasn't
part of the the draft board
apparatus he in the the great protests
of going against the draft he was
protesting mostly for himself he wasn't
with the kids that were burning their
draft cards he wasn't with the the
berrigan brothers and the p and the
priests who were going in and pouring
cows blood on on the draft records and
all of that stuff
he was off kind of protesting on his on
his own uh
on his own route and he wasn't a civil
rights guy either he was the the nation
of islam believed belief was separation
not integration and uh he he once said
if he if he voted if he could vote he
would have voted for george wallace that
uh
he wanted a segregated
society where were um the black man
would have they they'd give them a state
or something or a couple states and and
and it would be almost a separate
country
and uh
so he
he in fact you know he he would uh
he would call the people that were
marching
under under the
reverend martin luther king
he would say what are you doing this
isn't this isn't a thing you should be
doing that
if people don't watch it you shouldn't
be trying to force yourself upon him he
said we should go off in a different
direction so he he
he had a very different uh
viewpoint than than
than
he had later in life i think
and he was very controversial
and
the funny thing happened is he was doing
all these college dates and and a couple
years went by 1968 came along
where everything went crazy that was
maybe the craziest year going when uh
martin luther king was assassinated
robert kennedy was assassinated there
was that convention with the
with with mayor daley in chicago there
were riots in 110 cities in america um
just a whole bunch of stuff i mean a guy
tried to assassinate andy warhol um
stuff was just going on everywhere and
muhammad ali just didn't seem
that controversial anymore and as the
war had had ground along more and more
kids
had convinced their parents that maybe
this wasn't the greatest war in the
world for them to be involved in and had
had
kind of rebelled against the thing and
slowly but surely
the national perception of muhammad ali
had become much different and
when he finally
got to the end of 68 and 16 there's a
great thing he was on uh he was on
firing line with william f buckley i
don't know if anybody remembers that
show
you know william f buckley was the area
erudite guy with the big words and the
whole thing and he was arguing with
muhammad ali muhammad ali was very good
against him i mean he he had he'd gone
off and uh
and perfected his rap you know and and
in all these college things and arguing
with college kids and uh
and uh
he was very good in that show and
different things along those lines ken
he showed up on more and more on johnny
carson and merv griffin and the mike
douglas show and and he became more
mainstream he appeared in a play
on broadway
and slowly but surely the idea came that
maybe he should be back fighting
and
a guy in new york a young civil rights
lawyer
named michael meltzner he had kind of
filed a whole thing in new york to get
his license back because
he said ali was really you know he
really hadn't been convicted of anything
he was still in the appeals process how
could he lose his job for something that
he hadn't con been convicted for that
wasn't an
american kind of thing
and so that had gone on and another guy
had tried to to get him a license in
atlanta georgia where in georgia it
wasn't the state boxing commission that
that
licensed fights it was the city boxing
commission so under the nose of of
lester maddox
the probably the
the the most segregationist
governor in america
uh they
they they pushed through the thing in
atlanta and he signed to fight jerry
quarry as his comeback fight and he he
fought jerry quarry in 1970
and then uh new york thing had opened up
and he fought
he fought oscar he beat jerry quarry in
three rounds cut him up pretty bad and
they stopped the fight and then he
fought oscar bonavena in madison square
garden
and
that that fight went the distance 12
rounds
and he won the decision
and then
he signed to fight joe frazier the fight
that had been
building and building and building
frazier had become the champion in
absentia and ali
considered himself to be the people's
champion and
it it got built up and it was probably
the biggest sports event in the in in
20th century america you know it was
just huge each fighter got five million
dollars which was an unbelievable amount
of money uh at that time and uh jack
kent cook who was the owner of the
washington redskins and whatever he was
the one that put up the 10 million
dollars
and
they fought and uh
and ali
for some reason this fight of his life
this comeback fight of his his
his uh
of his life
really didn't didn't train that hard for
it he wound up spending most of his
training time talking to reporters and
hanging around and and doing stuff in
the meantime frasier was grinding away
and grinding away and grinding away and
ali's wife told him she said you're
going to lose to this guy i don't even
want to sit i don't even want to sit in
the good seats i'm going to sit away in
the bad seats because you
and sure enough
frazier just ground away and ground away
and in the 14th round knocked ali down
and uh
and frazier won the fight he wanted won
a decision
and
about two months later
the case finally came before the supreme
court it had gone to the supreme court
once and the supreme court had refused
to rule on it which would which would
have sent ali to jail
but a second thing came up about about
wiretapping
and the fbi had wiretapped
some of the constant conversations of
muhammad ali
just five of them without his knowledge
and so that brought him back for another
chance to go through the courts and and
go to the supreme court and reach the
supreme court
and the supreme court decided uh judge
thurgood marshall recused himself
because he had been part of the justice
department prosecuting ali
way back when all this started before he
became a supreme court justice so it was
eight
eight judges were voting and the vote
was five to three
that ali
was convicted and and he was going to go
away he was going to go away for five
years after the joe frazier fight
and then
judge john harlan was given the the job
of writing up this majority opinion that
muhammad ali was going to go away
and
he of course assigned his his his uh
his like his interns his his law clerks
to to write the opinion and the law
clerks really were get they were part of
the young people who had you know
changed the mind about muhammad ali
and they
figured out a way to convince john
harland that
that muhammad ali really should have got
a deferment you know as a conscientious
objector way back there in the beginning
when the justice department had had
turned over what lawrence graum and the
judge the judge had ruled
so john harland to his credit kind of
believed the clerks and he went back to
the supreme court and he said
i changed my vote so now it's four to
four
and and it's a tie and muhammad ali
still would go to jail with a tie
but one of the other justices parter
stewart said
what kind of decision is that people in
america will look at this famous guy
this famous case and say
oh my god the court can't make up his
mind and he still has to go to jail so
they set about kind of looking for a way
to get him out of the to to
to to change the vote and and to get him
off the hook and they found some wording
in the justice department's decision on
lawrence grauman's thing that it kind of
seemed contradictory so they all voted
eight to nothing and ali was off the
hook and
he was off into the world and that's the
whole time period that's covered in the
book um it kind of ends right there and
as we know that there was a whole bunch
of his life that was lived afterwards uh
i i had had problems
figuring out what the introduction was
to this book i i was doing it for a
couple years and i tried out a few
introductions and i i couldn't do it
and then ali died and
and there was such a outpouring of
emotion it was like
like gandhi had died or mother teresa
had died and and you know the funeral
was shown live on television and and uh
you know billy crystal and all these
people were talking and
and and it was all it was all great
stuff
but it it kind of
you didn't see
where the edge was what was going on at
the time what where the friction was
what was what was happening and i said
well that's what my book is showing what
the edge was and what the friction was
um
ellie at the end of his career you know
he became sick and and
and it he just for the last half of his
life
was more of an inspirational figure than
anything and he he did some wonderful
stuff
and uh i think
a lot of qualities were assigned to him
that he that he had in the second half
of his life that maybe he didn't have in
the first half when he was a much more
controversial guy and uh he's a
fascinating guy and i think he'll
forever be the the most interesting
athlete and iconic guy
that that we've ever seen
anybody want to ask them questions about
uh i have a microphone for the questions
so talk about muhammad ali or
evel knievel or anybody else that i've
written books about
how were the uh funds provided for his
defense all the years that he was not
boxing and just lecturing
well
yeah that's that's a good question that
the jehovah's witness
uh the jehovah's witness lawyer hayden
covington um he quit because they were
stiffening them for the money and
that's why he wound up doing a civil
rights attorney from atlanta um named
charles morgan who had been he'd been
involved in a whole bunch of civil
rights things there um since the the
birmingham march and the bombing of the
church in in birmingham he became
involved and then at the end the legal
defense fund um
which which helped in civil rights cases
kind of did a pro bono and and
and charles
morgan did it pro bono and and the guy
the the the guy who who did the work in
the in the new york knew to get his
license back in new york he did that pro
bono he was a legal defense fund guy too
can you address the rumors that have
persisted about ali not stepping forward
to be sworn in because he feared for his
life
under the threat of perhaps being killed
by
members of the nation of islam if he
went and
and uh
there was there's one thing
in a in a book about sugar ray robinson
sugar ray robinson talked about ellie
coming to to see him um
at the lowe's midtown motor and
well
the night before he was going to fight
zara foley and saying that he was
terrified and everything but
but he truly i i don't i don't buy it i
i think he truly believed in the nation
of islam and was very strong in in the
nation of islam and
you know for sure there were some tough
guys in the nation of islam i mean
they
they did kill malcolm x
malcolm x and
and and
they
they did some things to kareem
abdul-jabbar also um
but i i i think he was just a true
believer i really do he
you know he he went to
when he when he got the olympic gold
medal
he he was backed by by this group in
louisville
of 11 white businessmen and they hired
angelo dundee to be his trainer and they
sent him down to miami florida
and
it was all good angela was a great
trainer but angelo went home at at you
know at five o'clock every night and
here was this 18 year old kid down there
trying to figure out and make
connections in life and and meet people
and and do things and and that's
when when he he fell enthralled with
with the nation of islam it became it
really became his life
you know
so i i don't think he was afraid
um
you never talked to him never
well i i covered his last but i covered
five fights of his but they were after
this time period but but no for the book
no he was kind of out of it um
and so talk about the uh
uh
the direct research and who i mean you
had a lot of uh
newspaper accounts and things but what
about uh direct interviews and things
you talked a lot with his wife at the
time belinda boyd
her name now is kalila camacho ali and
and she
she had a good point she said
that ali always
uh the narrative ali controlled the
narrative to his life better than
anybody controlled the narrative because
people would just listen to ali and he
would give him so many great quotes
they'd never go talk to anybody and
they'd never hear anything else from
anybody else and
she was very interesting she was kind of
tough on him because because their life
ended badly um
with his womanizing and that i mean
there's a famous scene where
where
the thriller in manila
she was home with the kids in chicago
and he was with veronica porsche who was
his girlfriend and they went to see
imelda marcos or
ferdinand marcos and he he said your
wife is just a beautiful woman and ellie
said thank you very much and belinda saw
this in chicago and she went right to
the airport and got on a plane and flew
right to manila and came to the hotel
room and
raised raised a huge ruckus and then
turned around and came and got back on
the same plane that she had flown they
were refueling the plane and she came
back to the chicago and uh
and that was kind of the end of the
the end of their marriage
so
she she had interesting things to say
[Music]
other questions
oh i got sure
the rest of his wife
no the um that's uh that the nation of
islam once the honorable elijah muhammad
passed away
um his son
his son
changed the nation of islam
over to to to like a sunni muslim
kind of
part of islam
and
and ali went with that and the reverend
louis farrakhan about three or four
years later
reinstituted the nation of islam and
when he broke with the
uh
elijah muhammad's son
so now he he became just a a a
a for lack of better words a normal
muslim for for the rest of his life
um
which was which is what happened with
with malcolm x that's where malcolm x
got in trouble with the nation of islam
because
he had become a regular
muslim and not a member of the nation of
islam
yes sir
it was uh uh political
and ali
always friends that they maintain their
friendship that you could see when they
would be interviewing doing
when he would be interviewed by for sale
yeah i mean
i think they were friends but i think it
was a business relationship too you know
i mean i think i think they both got a
lot out of it from
from each of their perspectives you know
howard howard afforded him a a stage to
to work on and he afforded howard a
stage to work on
i i think they were friendly but i i
don't think they they went out to dinner
a lot uh
you know uh
he ellie was walking out
was walking out of uh
one of his court dates with one of his
lawyers and uh
we said to he said
to to
a reporter he said i don't have any
white friends and reporters said well
right here your lawyer is a
a white man is he your friend he said
he's my lawyer he's not my friend you
know so i
um i i think that yeah yeah they were
friendly but i
you know i
they didn't they didn't go over to each
other's house all the time
yes sir
i was just secure the abc studio that
fight between him and frazier was that
legitimate
you never knew with him you know um
early on
early on when he when he came back when
he came back from the olympics he
thought he you know the streets were
going to be paved with gold and he would
uh
he he would just just
start to fight and and it'd be sellouts
and people would go crazy but it you
know he had to fight a whole bunch of
people that that most sports fans didn't
know about to kind of build up a record
and he wasn't getting crowds at all
and uh what he did he he met gorgeous
george who was the wrestler um and and
gorgeous george's whole thing was aren't
i pretty aren't i good looking and and
he had blonde peroxide hair
and he threw out bobby pins and he had
he had a valet that would spray perfume
on him and things like that and gorgeous
george would just pack these arenas and
people would go crazy and ali looked at
it and he said
well that's how you do it you know if
you're a villain you get people to come
out and that's he he kind of added that
to his act and that that was what he he
did with sunny liston and and you know
the bear i'm gonna beat the bear and you
know he just
he made himself into a villain but which
was all well and good but then when the
draft thing came up he became
the villain plus you know because he
he had said these these things that
that most of america didn't didn't like
at the time you know it
you know
you wonder if ali were around today in
his in his prime what would it be like
you know and i say
if if you look at colin kaepernick
you know and you say
people had a lot of problems with colin
kaepernick they would have had 10 times
the problems with muhammad ali you know
colin kaepernick wasn't doing anything
he just wouldn't stand for the national
anthem
um
you know he was just protesting and so
he he would have he would be a very
controversial guy today in this
situation
yes sir
did you need a research discover was he
ever reimbursed financially
for
for his loss of employment during that
time after his case was ruled upon
favorably and then
to parliament and
was there any other precedent set with
this for any other conscience
conscientious objector cases that
followed or maybe uh his case said a
precedent for
the answers are no and no um
the first no is uh
in a way though he was reimbursed and
that
everything was so big when he came back
you know if if he hadn't gone away for
the three years
would he and frazier have gotten five
million dollars a piece to fight each
other you know that that's what made
that whole thing him him coming from the
desert you know and frasier being here
and and just colliding you know it was i
remember watching that fight i went i i
live in boston and i went to this uh
there was a nightclub uh
caesars monticello framingham
massachusetts and the whole place i took
my wife and she was young and we were
there it was 9 million guys and they
were all half drunk and the whole place
went crazy and tiny tim had walked in
and everybody tiny tim tiny tim and uh
it was just a crazy time that was that
was a you know frank sinatra took
pictures for life magazine you know
stuff that uh
that oh and it was oh and there were no
there were no precedents you know if if
muhammad ali were just another guy
it he kind of got celebrity justice in
the first part you know singled out
because because he was because because
of things he had said and so he was kind
of singled out in
classified 1a and and eligible for the
draft but at the end he got saved with
celebrity justice because you know his
his reputation was such so
it's it's an odd thing the the the way
it all went and if if he had been
another guy
he would have been you know either in
the service or in leavenworth i think
you know he he had legal he he had
lawyers to back him up
any more questions all right i'll come
over with the microphone so it's on the
recording um i remember his his later
years and how
weak he looked from i guess parkinson's
disease did he ever talk about that and
whether
how boxing had affected the rest of his
life
well i mean you know i it's an easy
it's an easy
pop medicine kind of thing to say that
boxing is what happened you know i mean
the rope-a-dope and all that were
where he was just letting people pound
on him um and the cumulative effects of
all the things i you know that the
moment where he lit the torch in 1996
and atlanta was was a huge
huge iconic moment you know
janet evans gives him the
the torch and he he's you know and i i
think
america watched it with a whole with a
whole bunch of different emotions going
on you know and part of it i think is
guilt you know that you got so much
enjoyment from this guy and
he was so interesting
with all the the way he talked and the
way he acted and and the thoughts he he
made you think
and and
you kind of you kind of
led him to this in a way because you you
cheered him on as a boxer and stuff so i
i think there was some guilt and
and and some
definite devotion you know he he
certainly
he certainly what while he wasn't
part of the anti-war movement per se
and he wasn't part of the civil rights
movement per se he certainly got a lot
of people talking about that stuff and
people
people kind of
used him as a model to to
for act for action you know to to stand
up to the government to to to kind of go
for your rights i i you know
in the end that's that that's what his
image was
uh in your research
uh did you ever come across anything on
joe frazier being in the service or
having served in the service
no joe fraser joe frazier had a lot of
kids real early
um you know and and that kind of kept
him out um
but
but he always he was always very
patriotic you know like uh
like five or six days after after the
the fight
in 1971 where he beat ali the one time
he he was in the white house with nixon
um next and and ellie said that ali
before the fight ali said that he said
joe frazier will be there with nixon he
said nixon won't have anything to do
with me and that was part of ali's
rap about the whole thing
i was at the airport here several years
many years ago and a flight from atlanta
came in
and guess who came off the plane
and we locked eyes just very briefly and
without even thinking about it my hand
went out to him and he put his hand out
to me we shook hands i think
i just met the most famous guy i'll
probably ever meet
he was very friendly he wasn't put
offish or anything like that he was a
fan he had a great curiosity about
people i think you know and i think that
that overrode a whole lot of stuff you
know he was very pleasant very glib
my my big memory of the first fight i
covered
covered him was in uh when he fought
chuck webner there's a movie just kind
of came out about chuck webner and i was
young and i went and it was at richfield
ohio right outside cleveland
it was 45 minutes from cleveland so i
rented a car i was there for the boston
globe and i rented a car
and so i drove out to the weigh-in the
day before the fight and i didn't know
that the media mostly got on a bus and
went out and then they got taken back on
the bus so i drove out in the car
and after the weigh-in everybody got on
the bus but i was still there and i said
well maybe i should go to muhammad ali's
dressing room and check it out maybe i
could get something different
and so i went and
i went in and there was no security
nothing and i went in and there were
maybe i don't know seven or eight people
in there and he was stretched out on a a
rubbing table and his his back was kind
of up against the wall
and uh billy eckstein the singer um that
old black magic
james brown the singer papa got a brand
new bag he was there and uh red fox was
there and red fox was telling dirty
jokes and red fox is from saint louis i
guess and red file he was telling the
the best dirty jokes i've ever heard in
my life and he would tell and and
everybody's sides were just splitting
you know and tears were in their eyes
and and
and we'd all be kind of and ellie would
say tell another one and red flags
should tell another one it was even more
dirty and even better than the last one
and it was like a moment
you know i i i just in that moment i
kept saying i wish they could this could
go on forever you know maybe james brown
will start singing maybe somebody else
will come in and the whole thing but i i
kind of i kind of peeled out of there
you know i was this little howdy duty
guy standing there and and i kind of
peeled out of there and i went over to
chuck webner's dress room and chuck and
his wife were there and they were all by
themselves and
and we talked and it was nice and that
there's a famous the famous quote from
chuck weber before the fight he bought
his he bought his wife a
flimsy negligee
and he said i want you to wear this
tonight when you go to bed with the
heavyweight champion of the world so he
goes and he fights and he he puts up a
credible thing they base rocky on on
chuck webner's fight against muhammad
ali but he gets caught up and he goes to
the hospital and stitched up and it's 3
30 4 o'clock in the morning he gets back
and his wife is sitting there and she's
got the negligee on and she says
well is he coming down here or am i
going to go to his room
i was
interested in your comment paraphrase it
ali was the
most iconic athlete of i guess u.s
history i think you said and you've
written about ruth and ted williams and
and a number of others
so
quickly who who who else do you list is
iconic
and
is there are there any quick answers
response why ali is number one
and then a side of that what would what
were your impressions and did you
respect evil
okay one
um
what do you think ellie was ellie was
global i mean that that's the difference
you know babe ruth was was semi-global
but but ellie was global you know and
and
uh
everybody knew how he he was probably
one of the i don't know
four most known people in the world when
when he was going on right up there with
presidents and so he was the biggest
i iconic i i don't know i mean we all
know all those people you know that the
famous athletes um
you know
i suppose iconic is is touch to your age
too you know what you know if you say
johnny unitas maybe that says you're a
certain age or if you say
you know walter payton or or jim brown
or you know but i mean all those people
are iconic in their own respects and
evil knievel no evil knievel was a bad
guy he uh
you know there's a lot of talk about
narcissism today
he he he was a narcissistic guy with big
hair so i don't know you know
how you want to relate that to our
present situation
you want to take one or two more
yep anybody else
i was just curious to know if layla
alley is the daughter of belinda boyd or
someone else no layla was
layla was later laila was later after uh
after uh
after with veronica porsche
and he he had some children too that
that weren't with any of his wives he
he
he did a lot a lot to propagate the
future of america
all right is there one more question or
should we sign some books
well thank you so much
okay again the book is for sale in the
back of the room from barnes noble and
lee will be right here at this table and
we'll get you guys some books
[Music]
book tv recently visited catholic
southern festival of books this is book
tv's live coverage you'll hear from many
authors throughout the weekend including
national book award final patricia bell
scott and nancy mclean
talk radio show host eric erickson
best-selling author liza mundy and many
others for a complete schedule visit
booktv.org
or follow along on our social media
sites we're on facebook twitter and
instagram
book tv
now we're kicking off today's coverage
of author talks with biographer jonathan
igg on the life and politics of muhammad
ali this is live coverage on book tv on
c-span 2.
okay good morning everyone uh thank you
for coming this morning and welcome to
the
29th southern festival of books my name
is andrew marinus and it's my great
pleasure to have the opportunity to
introduce jonathan i
this morning
an author that i really really admire
i've been reading his work
for years and he's here this morning to
talk about his new book his biography of
muhammad ali i understand this is only
his third stop on his tour so that's
quite an honor for us
here in nashville uh before jonathan
speaks i've been asked to mention a few
things first the book festival of course
is free but if you would like to
contribute to the cause you can do that
at the headquarters for the book
festival outside or online
and also remind you that after his
remarks jonathan will be heading over to
the signing tent which is next to the
parnassus tent out on the main plaza and
so you can have him sign your book over
there
jonathan's regard is one of the
country's
top writers of narrative non-fiction
which is my favorite style
fantastic author
in addition to writing four best-selling
books
including two that i've read on lou
gehrig and jackie robinson
jonathan has written for the new york
times the new yorker esquire in the
washington post and today he's a
contributing writer for the wall street
journal
his biography of muhammad ali is
one of the most anticipated books of the
fall and if you have checked out any of
the reviews it's
probably the most highly rated uh book
of the fall as well
and there's always a natural connection
i don't know if i'm if you're planning
to mention either of these points but i
wanted to say
that muhammad ali's widow lonnie is a
vanderbilt graduate
and if you ever had a chance to meet
coach ed temple the legendary coach of
the tsu tiger bells he always used to
tell the story of after the rome
1960 olympics the summer olympics
uh where cassius clay was smitten with
wilma rudolph
after those olympics uh cassius clay
would come down to nashville in his pink
convertible cadillac looking for wilma
and so jonathan out if you drove down
from chicago in a pink cadillac or if
you flew down but we're really excited
to have you in nashville thank you for
coming
[Applause]
thank you very much it's really thrilled
to be here and um you know what muhammad
ali used to say every time he was
introduced like that he'd say andrew
thank you for the introduction you're
not as dumb as you look
now i don't do that i wouldn't do that i
um you know there's a lot of things that
muhammad ali could get away with that i
couldn't we and and we don't really have
that much in common as you might notice
from looking at me although we both have
unbelievably fast jab um do you want to
see it
you want to see it again
that's an ali joke um but you know it's
important as a biographer to to
recognize that you
do not have that much in common with
your subject usually and the job of a
biographer
is to understand that subject as best
you can often from a distance and that
means
really paying attention to the facts
doing your research i did
about 600 interviews for this book with
more than 200 individuals i say 600
interviews 200 individuals because i
interviewed many of them over and over
i did i counted the number of times ali
was punched i used i worked with status
statisticians to do that i worked with
speech scientists to look at how those
punches affected his speech rate i dove
as deeply into this life as i could
because the biographer's job is to help
you understand that person's life and
how that life was shaped
and to understand how that life shaped
us as a country as a people and with ali
one of the most interesting one of the
most important men of the 20th century i
would argue
it was a huge responsibility that i felt
and the other really important
piece that a biographer has to always
keep in mind is empathy you have to try
to empathize with your subject that
doesn't mean you have to always
celebrate him doesn't mean you have to
always excuse him the job is not to
glorify not to pretty him up he was
pretty enough to begin with not
necessarily to knock him down either but
to always try to have empathy for your
subject
so i'd like to talk a little bit about
that process what i learned along the
way and the challenge really that i
faced dick gregory the great comedian
and social activist who just passed away
um said to me when i interviewed him
he's one of my first interviews he said
there's no point in you writing this
book white boy as he said to me there's
no point in writing this book if you're
not going to be able to explain to me
and explain to your readers how a black
kid growing up in jim crow louisville
felt like he could be special what made
him think he could go around calling
himself the greatest of all time
when america said he was inferior that
he was a second-class citizen and the
laws
not just the people around him but the
laws said so too
you're going to understand you're going
to have to make me and help your readers
understand what made this kid think he
could be different
and that felt like a great challenge to
me as i began this quest of
four and a half years getting to know
ali
trying to meet ali of course i began
this while he was still alive and i'd
like to take you on that journey a
little bit one of the first things i did
was
interview some of the people who knew
him best especially some of the older
folks
in the beginning of the process it's a
balance of reading a lot of old material
and interviewing people who might take
some time to get to know some people who
might not be around that much longer i
began with ali's second wife who
happened to come through chicago a lot
i'm gonna uh
this is uh she was known as belinda she
was 17 years old when she married ali
she now goes by kalila ali and she came
to chicago a lot she was here this night
for a movie premiere she she grew up in
chicago now lives in florida and
i showed up this movie premiere and i
said i'm writing muhammad ali's
biography
and i'd like to talk to you
and she looks at me like who are you and
who gave you permission to write ali's
biography
and um the answer of course is nobody
and um but i'd like for you to talk to
me anyway
and and and again
the sense of responsibility that a
biographer feels like i'm taking this
guy's life in my hands he didn't ask me
to
um but i'm going for it anyway and i i
explained to kalila that i just really
wanted to do this right i wanted to give
him the kind of biography that he
deserves
not another love fest not another book
that just makes him out to be a saint
but something that really shows how
important he was and who he really was
and i need you you were married to him
for 10 years 10 of the most interesting
years of his life from the vietnam
protest through
the all of the joe frazier fights i need
you to tell me what it was like to be
married to this man and she said okay
well how much are you gonna pay me
uh i got that a lot um in the boxing
world this is um
ali's brother rahman i called him up a
few times he wouldn't answer wouldn't
talk to me finally i said rockman just
one question i just had one question for
you he said i'm not talking to you
unless you pay me i said i have one
question i just want to know what your
dog's name was just tell me the name of
the dog thousand dollars he said
i said was that your dog's name thousand
no no thousand dollars i'm not going to
tell you my dog's name unless you give
me a thousand dollars um
i said i'm not i don't pay for
interviews rockman but i was i'm very
persistent um you can ask my wife um in
boxing they say you're fighting above
your weight when you uh when you're
fighting my wife is a really impressive
woman the fact that she would go out
with me tells you how persistent i am
and and that's what rachman and khalila
would find out eventually um as i set
out on this quest to understand ali's
life and um
this is the home where ali grew up ali
and rachman ali rachman told me that um
i'll used to stand in a little crack
between the houses there on the right
and um and challenge rockmon to throw
rocks at him see if he could hit him so
there's not much room to dodge i
measured it um 72 inches between the two
houses because i wanted to write you
know the view out ali's bedroom window
was the next house over 72 inches away
um
and he would stand in that crack and
have challenge his brother to throw
rocks at him and some people would say
that's one of the reasons he became so
quick avoiding punches i also learned
from ali's wife that that ollie was
dyslexic
and was never able to read well in
school and that's one of the reasons why
he became a class clown
i also learned that his father was
abusive alcoholic um
running running around with a lot of
women um ali came from from difficult
circumstances he was not poor this was
actually a you know a fairly
middle-class neighborhood compared to
most boxers who came out of poverty
this was a block where he grew up with
school teachers and principals and
lawyers and doctors and undertakers all
african-american of course but
nevertheless
he saw opportunities around him
and he saw his biggest opportunity to
escape from this and to find a way out
when he was 12 years old how many people
know the story of ollie's stolen bicycle
most people have heard that ali stole it
had his bicycle stolen this happens to
be one of those those great legends that
turns out to be true so often when when
i dive into these things you know pee
wee reese did not put his arm around
jackie robinson in 1947. this turns out
to be true ollie's riding his bicycle
one day a 50 schwinn big deal
um and it starts to rain he ducks into
an auditorium to escape from the rain
and he comes out and his bicycle's gone
he goes looking for a police officer he
finds one in the basement of a gym and
tells him his bike's been stolen and
he's going to beat up whoever took it
and the police officer says well do you
know how to fight
and ali who's catches clay at this time
says no but i'm i'm tough
and the police officer says well why
don't you come learn to box
and ollie begins boxing and falls in
love with it
absolutely
transfixed just by the sights in the gym
not just the heavy bags and the speed
bags
but something else really important
there were black kids and white kids
fighting in the ring together
there were black kids punching white
kids you did not do that in america
in the 1950s you didn't if you did it
you didn't get you got in trouble you
know you could be arrested for far less
than that
and ali saw this and you know it just
began to rewire his brain in in crazy
ways like what else can i do what else
can i get away with and he begins taking
boxing very seriously um there's another
myth how many people heard this one that
ollie used to race the bus to school
um
so one of the things i learned from from
robert carro the great lbj biographer is
that you always ask what was it like to
be in the room with your subject and you
ask it over and over until the subject's
sick of hearing it what was it like to
be in the room so i would ask
ali's classmates what was it like to be
on that bus when ollie was racing
and i asked it over and over three four
different people and it wasn't making
sense to me like i couldn't quite
picture it and one of the guys something
that bugged me was that when his friend
owen sidgraves told me that it was a
city bus and they paid 10 cents to ride
to get to school
and that after one day i it hit me
i called owen i said you said it was a
city bus right
doesn't a city bus stop a lot
like almost every block
and he said yeah
so ali was racing the bus but it kept
stopping right
and he said yeah and plus we we we got
off a chestnut and transferred
and he'd wait with us for the next bus
so was he really racing the bus mr
sidgraves i asked
he said no of course not he was just
trying to entertain us he was trying to
remind us all that he was a big shot
boxer
and he wanted to be famous he didn't
really want to be faster than the buzz
and this is one of those key moments for
a biographer where you start to say okay
i get this guy now
he wants to box he wants to become great
but he also just really wants attention
and now i'm starting to get to know ali
a little bit
this is the gym where he trained
where he found joe martin in the
basement he not only would train there
but when he got done he'd go to another
gym and train
joe martin by the way was a white police
officer so here's a white police officer
who's not arresting black people he's
helping black kids something new again
rewiring kind of the brain of what he's
been taught growing up but he also finds
a black trainer and when he's done
training with joe martin he's working so
hard he goes and trains with fred stoner
in another gym and by 1960 by the time
he's only a senior in high school he's
the olympic lightweight champion
he comes back to central high school and
he's a hero he's the toast of the town
they he's failing almost every class in
part because he's disliked second part
because he's out boxing all the time
but they decide to pass him the
principal of the school says someday
this kid's going to be famous and i
don't want to be remembered as the
principal who flunked
the champ
and
he discovers that he just loves
attention at the olympics in 1960 which
is described beautifully in david
marinis book
ali becomes the mayor of the olympic
village everybody from every country
wants their picture taken with this guy
because he just has such charm such
charisma and he realizes that being
outspoken being loudmouthed his first
nickname is the louisville lip
that it's good for his career it's
getting him more attention it's getting
him bigger fights it's making him more
money and he loves money too he talks
all the time about how many cadillacs
he's going to own and how all the
different
shades of the rainbow and
this
attitude standing up and making himself
known making himself heard is helping
him get bigger fights by 1964
he gets his first shot at the
heavyweight championship against this
guy
sunny liston
the biggest baddest meanest man on earth
heavyweight champion who's knocked out
his last opponents in a matter of
seconds
and
ali is perhaps more unpopular than sunny
listens listen has a criminal record
his his autobiography is called the
champ no one wanted he's a he's a very
unpopular man ali is more unpopular
because a black kid
being so unsportsmanlike bragging about
himself all the time
is is just seen as repulsive to to most
white americans
and
and people are actually rooting for
sunny listen which liston is not used to
that's a new one for him um
and it's seen that this is the end of
ali's career there's no way he can beat
sunny liston listen is so bad but
ali has something that listen isn't
prepared for and that's this incredible
speed perhaps learned from from dodging
those rocks but also just something
that's that is given as a gift to him he
is so fast that he boxes like heavy
weights are not supposed to box heavy
weights is supposed to keep their hands
up they're supposed to hit hard and
they're supposed to duck the punches but
ali is so quick that he can just
move out of the way and these punches
glance off or miss him altogether
opponents sometimes are just so
frustrated that they that they that they
can't get near him and that's exactly
what happens to liston you see him
throwing these giant punches looking for
that early knockout and ollie's gone
before the punch is halfway through the
air and then the next thing you know
this is that left jab almost as fast as
mine is um is popping listed in the face
and and liston is getting tired he's
getting mad the matter he gets the
harder he swings the more he misses
and by the by the fifth or sixth round
you can see it listen is is gone he has
no chance and he doesn't get off the
stool at the end of the sixth round he
gives up the heavyweight championship
without even being knocked down without
even being knocked out
because
muhammad cash's clay is too much for him
and what happens after the fight
ali
announces
that he is no longer he's the champion
he's the king of the world
he says i i i told you i told you i'm
the greatest and by the way i'm now a
member of the nation of islam
i'm not a christian
christianity was a religion forced upon
me
on my people when during slavery the
name cassius clay is a slave name it
might as well be a brand that was seared
onto my flesh i don't have to do that
anymore and he makes this unbelievably
important pronouncement that changes the
world
and and changes um
the way people not only see black
athletes but black people all over
because he says i don't have to do what
you tell me to do i don't have to say
what you tell me to say i don't have to
be what you want me to be i'm free
and in 1964 those are fighting words
and if he was unpopular before for being
unsportsmanlike
he's way more unpopular now and
soon after he announces that he's
changing his name from cassius clay to
muhammad ali a name given to him by the
founder of the nation of islam elijah
muhammad you'll notice in almost every
picture of ali from the 60s and 70s that
rachman his brother
was named rudy uh at the time is is is
somewhere in the picture rudy is always
hanging around his big brother um
and that's elijah muhammad in the middle
um
ali joins this group that is considered
by the american government a threat to
democracy this is a radical group this
is not orthodox islam this is a group
that believes that black people in
america are never going to be treated
equally there's no point
in wasting your time on the civil rights
movement there's no point in discussing
integration the only way is for black
people to forge their own way out to
build their own businesses
to improve their lives improve their
health and eventually
start their own country and they will
america will be forced to give
a segment of the united states to the
nation of islam for black people to go
and start their own country and ali
grew up hearing something similar from
his father who also was not a big fan of
integration also thought that black
people were never going to be treated
equally and told ali you're never going
to be rich you're never going to be
anything because of the color of your
skin just get used to it
and ali
believed what his father said but he was
not prepared to get used to it he
believed because
he was different because he was
a boxer because he had this platform
that america had to listen to what he
said that
he could fight that and joining the
nation of islam gave him a platform by
which to do that something else dick
gregory pointed out to me that i had
never thought about is that
when other black leaders in this country
spoke when elijah muhammad spoke or
malcolm x or martin luther king their
words were filtered by the white media
the new york times decided which quotes
to use cbs news decided which clip to
use but when muhammad ali stood in the
center of the ring and said i am the
greatest i talked to allah allah told me
that i was going to win this fight and
all praise is due to elijah muhammad the
whole world heard that and nobody could
edit him and that gave ali a very
special kind of a platform and that
helps explain why he thought he could
fight
when a lot of other black athletes were
forced to accept
the deal the deal being that you did
your job you performed your sport and
you kept your mouth shut
something that black athletes are being
told today
but ali didn't just think he had to
accept that and
he paid for it he refused to fight in
vietnam
he was convicted of draft evasion
first he said i just don't want to go
you know it's interesting to watch him
evolve on this we think of him now as
being
this conscientious objector and this
pacifist but at first he said take my
tax dollars and go buy all the bomber
jets and tanks you want i'm making a lot
of money i just don't want to go then he
said
well this war is not fair to black
people black people are dying in
disproportionate numbers over there and
we're not even treated as equals in our
own country why should we fight for a
country that teach that treats us like
second class citizens and then he said
it's against my religion so he evolved
as many people who were opposed to the
vietnam war evolved but he paid a huge
price for it convicted sentenced to five
years in prison
banned from boxing for three and a half
years
and
loses millions of dollars in
endorsements and fight revenue
finally after three and a half years out
of the ring he gets his chance to come
back
and this is really
i think in many ways the key moment in
ali's
career as an athlete
he comes back against joe frazier the
fight of the century the only time the
two undefeated heavyweights have squared
off in the ring two undefeated
heavyweight champions have squared off
in the ring
and by now it's 1971 our views on
vietnam have changed
most americans feel like the war was a
mistake we see that ali paid for his
convictions he suffered
and he was willing to to take that he
was willing to sacrifice for his beliefs
whether you agreed with him or not you
had to respect that
and then he gets put on his rear end
by joe frazier in the 14th round just
this vicious left hook
and he was up in a second and a half he
said later that he was unconscious on
the way down and the ground woke him up
he bounces right back up he finishes
that fight
he loses and he's got to start fighting
his way back
to a rematch with frasier to a shot at
the heavyweight championship and this is
when i think you start to see americans
beginning to show some respect for ali
because he's his toughness is now not in
question it used to be they thought he
was so quick and so pretty and so
talkative that he couldn't really fight
and he wasn't a true champ but now
people begin to admire his his his
tenacity of nothing else they still may
not agree with his political opinions
and it's the 70s now the civil rights
movement has moved off the streets and
into the courts
ali is becoming a popular figure he's on
johnny carson all the time so here's
this guy who said he hated white people
that white people were the blue-eyed
devils
and he's still saying stuff like that
but he's also joking around with johnny
carson and he has this
ability to charm us it's almost
impossible to hate the guy you know his
high school girlfriend said you could
not be in a bad mood around ali and even
people who went into the room thinking
that this is a draft dodging traitor
mf
and
they couldn't resist the guy he was just
so likable and when he when he starts
fighting his way back
you know
stanley crouch the writer said that ali
in the 60s was a was a was a grizzly
bear he's wild he's untamed he's unc
he's dangerous by the 70s he's more like
a circus bear he's still dangerous but
he's but he's fun and he's entertaining
and then in the last act of his of his
life which i'm going to talk about a
little bit more crowd said he's like a
teddy bear we all just want to embrace
him and i want us to think about why
that's the case um
he gets his shot at the heavyweight
championship again
fighting george foreman in zaire of all
places this becomes
the fight for black pride this is the
fight to declare who's the really the
biggest toughest black man on earth and
it's fought don king pulls off this
bizarre spectacle in zaire under this
dictator nobody's ever seen anything
like this and ali is is a much slower
fighter now you know i mentioned that i
counted all the punches that he took
over the course of his career i count
that i calculate that he probably took
about 200 000 punches if you include his
amateur fights his sparring sessions but
by this point in his career he's
actually training to take those punches
he's having his sparring partners just
hit him as much as they can because he
believes he can build up resistance and
nobody can knock him out if he builds up
resistance like calluses you know you
just take enough punches and you'll be
immune to a knockout and he lets george
foreman the strongest man in heavy in
the heavyweight
um
in heavyweight boxing just pound away at
him until foreman's arms start to get
tired and then ollie begins to fight
back
um foreman told me just off the cuff
here um that he believes he was drugged
before that fight
by his own manager
and he also told me that
he gave 25 000 cash to the referee to
make sure it was a fair fight and he
found out later that ali's people gave
um more than 25 000
so i i called ali's manager and i said
george says that he gave 25 to the ref
and you guys gave more and his manager
said that's ridiculous that's the
stupidest thing i ever heard we only
gave him ten thousand
um
take it for what you
what you believe um but he beats george
foreman he becomes the heavyweight
champion again and elijah muhammad calls
him and says you've done it all you're
the champion again it's time to retire
devote the rest of your life to your
religion to your family
um he's after this fight he divorces
khalilah he marries another woman
veronica
it's time to stop but ali can't stop he
keeps boxing and in those last
years he fights another six years he
keeps getting slower and slower he keeps
taking more and more punches and you can
see the effect it's having on him he
begins to ask his friends do you think
this is this is hurting me do you think
i'm getting brain damage you can hear if
you just go on youtube and watch his
speech watch just watch some of his his
videos you can see how much his speech
is slowing down how he's beginning to
slur his words but he's also a celebrity
and he loves it he can't get enough of
it he likes hanging around with sonny
and cher he likes doing the tv shows he
likes the entourage he likes just like
he did when he was a little boy he just
loves the attention
he can't get enough of it
so this goes on he continues to fight
continues um into the early eighties
finally in 1981
he uh a 1980 he fights larry holmes and
takes a terrible beating and fights one
more time trevor berbick loses again
loses his last two fights not the way at
all he wants to go out but
um
he gets a third act
in the in the late 80s early 90s we
forget about ali
um he disappears really you can hire him
for three thousand dollars to come to
your used car dealership and sign
autographs and he loves to do it he he
always just loved being around people he
would if he was bored he'd just go stand
in the middle of an intersection and see
how long it would take for people to
notice him
and then he'd invite some people from
the intersection to go out to lunch and
maybe go out to dinner after that and
maybe come to his next fight he just he
couldn't get enough of people if he was
if he couldn't sleep he'd
tell us he'd call for a taxi and go to a
hospital and just visit people in the
hospital these things that nobody ever
knew about he didn't call attention to
himself he just loved people but he
disappeared and he was depressed and
then in 1996 how many people remember
watching this on tv it was the most
amazing thing i've ever seen because
nobody knows who's going to light the
olympic torch in atlanta
and there's rumors that might be evander
holyfield is from atlanta other rumors
going around ali's name isn't mentioned
and then the torch goes up the steps and
it's handed off to somebody who's behind
a partition and he emerges in this white
tracksuit
and the crowd doesn't roar
the crowd doesn't applaud it
it's silent and then you hear an audible
gasp
it's ali
and then the chance starts to go up ali
ali ali and it's as if we've
rediscovered him we've forgotten him and
we've forgiven
all of the horrible things he said all
even those of us who thought he was a
traitor for his stance on vietnam you
have to admit this guy
he took his punches and there he is his
hand is shaking that he can't quite
light the torch it looks like he's going
to set himself on fire the the flame
keeps wicking up toward his arm and
we're worried that he's not going to be
able to pull it off and he gets the
thing lit
and the crowd begins to roar and it's in
that moment that ali is really
rediscovered and it's in that moment
almost i mean the next day you can just
see from the press coverage
that he becomes the teddy bear we want
to put our arms around him
but i would argue that we don't really
want to remember him as the teddy bear
we want to remember him
for his for the warrior that he was
and it's it's great that we that he was
willing to do this and let us see him
suffering and to let us see
what this disease what parkinson's and
what all these punches had done to him
but that's not who he really was that's
not why he matters today so one of the
things of course that i needed to do in
working on this book was not only to
interview his wives and his brother and
all of his friends and his fighters who
we faced in the rainbows to try to meet
ali
i've been working on this thing like i
said for you know more than three years
before he passed away so several times i
went to fundraisers where he was
supposed to appear and and he was ill he
didn't quite he didn't make it that time
but i met his wife at a couple of these
things and and i told her that i was
working on this and i told her the same
thing that i told ali's
friends and family that why they should
talk to me
for free um because i was taking this
seriously i wanted this to be the book
that ali's grandchildren and great
grandchildren children would read not to
just see how wonderful he was but to see
how much he mattered and why
and and
ali's wife lonnie said to me yes you
know that's that's great i'm glad you're
doing that you should come meet him so i
got back after one of these events where
ali hadn't been there and i wrote him a
letter wrote lanie a letter saying how
nice it was to meet her and my daughter
asked who's five at the time asked if
she could write a letter to muhammad
and uh i said yeah sure here's a piece
of paper she asked me how to spell
muhammad and she did the rest of it
herself she wrote dear muhammad my daddy
really loves you do you love my daddy
love lola
and i think that's so sweet and it's
also really gonna work like it's
lonnie can't resist this uh so i stuck
it in the envelope and and lonnie called
and said you should come
bring lola when you come visit muhammad
loves children so i said oh well just so
happens we're going to be in phoenix in
a few weeks can we come visit um
and she said yeah sure as long as it's
not it's not an interview you're not
coming with a tape recorder cameras i
said no no i just i want to meet him i'm
spending five years of my life
practically and i'm gonna spend the rest
of my life talking about him i want to
meet the man
so lola and i went to phoenix and we
went to his house and um
he wasn't feeling well that day and he
didn't come out of his room we didn't
get to meet him
and we spent time with lonnie and it was
really nice and um she loved my daughter
a lot more than she liked me
which is which is good and then a few
months later i found out he was going to
be in louisville ali was going to be
there for an award ceremony i went down
to louisville i hung out with someone
with his with ali's brother and with
some of his childhood friends and i was
so nervous you know what am i going to
ask him what am i going to say to him if
i get a chance to meet him
and i decided to go for a run on the
route that ali used to run
um i'm a big runner and you know and i
thought i'm running along these streets
where ali used to run and i'm thinking
how ridiculous is this okay empathy is
important
um i'm trying to understand ali but i
really think me
this little guy 60 some odd years later
running in ali's footsteps is gonna
actually learn anything about what it
was like to be ali what it was like to
be a black kid growing up in jim crow
louisville
it's preposterous
um and then so when i thought okay now i
know what i'm gonna ask him it came to
me while i was running that day
if i get to meet him i know what i'm
going to say
and i went to the event that night and
ollie was there he was sitting at a
table with lonnie and one of ali's
friends grabbed me and said come on we
got to go meet him before anybody else
gets there we ran over to his table
and lonnie introduced me to muhammad and
i leaned over and i put my hand on his
arm and i looked in him looked him in
the eyes and i said my name is jonathan
eigen i'm writing your biography i know
you didn't ask me to but it's an
unbelievable privilege and i'm trying so
hard to do it right
and i just wanted to know if anything
you wanted to say
and he didn't answer
he looked at me and i think he knew what
i was saying lonnie told me later he
knew who i was and what i and what i
said but he didn't answer
and that was hard for me um but i think
it was in a way a good thing because
it's my book
it was his life
he lived it
and he told us every day
why he mattered and what he was trying
to do he told us from the minute he
knocked out
sonny even if he defeated sonny listen
he didn't knock him out but he told us
every step of the way
i'm here to say
that a black man can call himself the
greatest i'm here to say that i don't
have to do what white society or anybody
else tells me to do
i'm here to say that we have a right we
have a responsibility to fight for what
we believe in in this country
he did all those things he showed us
every day of his life and
i think when you do those things
as ali did when you stand up to power
when you get knocked down and you get
back on your feet
that's when you earn the right to call
yourself the greatest of all time
thank you very much
[Applause]
uh thank you jonathan i think this is
the ultimate treat for us as readers to
have such a fascinating subject and a
brilliant writer come together so thank
you again for coming to nashville and if
you'd like to ask a question because we
are on c-span today if you can come over
to the microphone here you can line up
at that microphone to ask your question
of jonathan we have about
10 or 15 minutes for questions to come
on over and then again after
jonathan has answered the questions
we'll be heading over to the tent to
sign copies of his book thanks again
yeah the question i have is i admire ali
and one of the stories about
muhammad ali
was after he won the olympics
he that he threw his gold medal into the
river and i've read that but i don't
know if that's true or not have you
discovered anything about that yeah so
the good news is the bicycle myth turned
out to be true
the gold medal myth
probably not so the story goes and it
first appears in ollie's autobiography
that he was uh back from the olympics
and he was wearing his olympic medal he
wore it everywhere he
just obviously wanted to show it off he
slept with it on um and
he was in a restaurant and couldn't get
served and according to his
autobiography a motor a white motorcycle
gang chased him out of the restaurant
and as he was fleeing
going across the the bridge of the ohio
river he threw it into the river in
frustration and in protest that even a
gold medal doesn't earn you service at
one of these restaurants when his book
was published
somebody asked him about that and all he
said what are you talking about
he said what's in the book he said well
i didn't read the book what are you
talking about um
and
i asked ali's brother about it and he
said no he definitely lost the medal and
he was frantic for days searching for it
you know where could it be
you know he barely took it off how could
he have lost it but um rockman and
several other people some of the kids
who knew ali at that time and said he
definitely just lost it so i think
that's one of those myths that doesn't
turn out to be true unfortunately i
could make one comment i'm a vietnam
veteran
and
at the time
i was also involved in the civil rights
movement and i did find that the
majority of the people drafted were
those of us who were involved in the
civil rights movement in blacks my unit
was mostly black so there's a basis for
his belief that
the government was out to stop that
civil rights movement at the time that's
interesting there's no certainly no
question that that black americans were
were serving and dying in
disproportionate numbers to white
americans if you saw the ken burns
documentary they went into that quite a
bit
morning jonathan
my name is stacey harris i'm a published
author as well and when you spoke about
wanting to really capture his essence
and so forth and be really
sure that you were
getting
getting it expressing things the way
that they actually were and debunking
the myths and so forth um i'm in the
process right now of ghostwriting a book
and so i've got that same obligation but
even a little more of finding their
voice
what i'm wondering is before
uh when you started asking questions and
they were asking how much money
before that had you ever considered an
authorized biography or did you want to
be totally free and so forth that's a
great question you know when i started
working on the book and ali's family and
his lawyers found out that i was doing
this one of his lawyers called and asked
if i'd be willing to make this an
authorized project in exchange they
would give me
access to the family and access to ali
and they would take half the money too
but that's that wasn't really the issue
for me it was the question of what kind
of book i wanted to write and if you're
writing an authorized book you're
subject to your partner
and and their wishes for the book and
they may not want certain things in
there
ali was really clear about the fact that
he was not a saint
late in life he talked about it a lot he
said that there was a tallying angel who
was
watching everything he did and keeping
track of all the good things and the bad
things and that if he had more good
things than bad things he'd go to heaven
um but he said he did a lot of bad
things and he needed to make up for
those in the second part of his life
and he believed that he had a chance to
do that and and and worked very hard
with acts of charity with acts of
diplomacy but he was not a saint and i
thought it was really important that
this book show the man in full um i
didn't want to write a book where i had
my hands tied in any way um and and so i
never even considered the the idea of
doing an authorized book with the with
the ali management team
yes sir uh good morning so you're the
author of icons and sports um
jackie robinson and lou gehrig what was
your love affair with uh muhammad ali
what what made you want to
write that book um you know i'm really
interested in in stories of rebels i
mean i also wrote a book about the
inventors of the birth control pill who
were real rebels um and um
i was a huge ali fan as a kid you know i
had this poster on the ceiling of my
room and i was thinking about why he
seemed to me so different from all my
other sports heroes you know he was at a
different level than you know
terry bradshaw or o.j simpson um he was
like almost like a superhero because
first of all he was in an individual
sport and which ali loved he always said
he would never bother playing football
there's too many guys on the field he
wouldn't get enough attention um
and
plus he had to wear a helmet no he could
see how pretty he was um
but ali almost seemed like a superhero
because he was transcending the sport he
was a this unbelievable entertainer who
was um so witty you know you think about
his his his engagements with um howard
cosell and he was a tv star he could
have been
had his own variety show
he was also this unbelievably important
political figure who was taking stands
that were making page news so he always
seemed like something more than a sports
figure to me and um i've never really
been interested in writing just a
straight sports book i'm interested in
sports books that tell us something
about who we are as a country and ollie
just seemed like the best possible story
i mean um i to me it was like
the greatest opportunity
of my life to be able to tell that story
i was just so thrilled that i got the
chance thank you sure
good morning i was wondering what you
learned about the relationship between
muhammad ali and howard cosell
yeah cosell i mentioned they were a
great partnership
and i think in some ways they were
really it really was a business
partnership that they recognized they
were good for each other
kosel was really one of the first
journalists to accept ali's name change
and to say he can be whatever religion
he wants maybe because kosel was jewish
but you think about it we didn't tell
hollywood actors that they couldn't
change their names we didn't tell you
know jewish people that they couldn't
drop their long jewish-sounding names
and come up with more american-sounding
ones so why should we tell ali that he
can't change his name for his new
religion right it's it was hypocrisy and
it was racism
but um kosel
saw past that it was one of the few in
the beginning and um and ali recognized
that being on tv with cosell and
clowning around with him showed his warm
and human side too so it was really good
for both of their careers i don't think
they were super best friends i don't
think they dined at one another's homes
but i think they they had a real mutual
professional admiration
can i get you to comment on the uh
i find it real odd when i read the
muhammad ali obituaries
that we praised him for
his resistance for his courage
and then
what six
later a
year when did he die
june of 16. okay so six months later
three months later we're dealing with or
my math is off a year later
we're dealing with kneeling football
players
and the national anthem
and it just seems like
ali's legacy is just evaporated
that's it's a good question and a good
point a troubling one because you're
right you'd think that we would have
learned something that ali
sacrificed and showed that athletes
black athletes in particular
should be entitled to be more than
athletes that they're entitled to their
political opinions same as all americans
and yet here we have
at the nfl we have a president saying
that
they should just do their jobs and keep
their mouths shut and you know we're
running into a lot of the same issues
and it's just i think it's sad and it
just shows how some deeply ingrained
some of these these racial attitudes
are hi uh thanks for coming to nashville
to talk to us i've been reading the book
and it's it's amazing the writing's so
good i've read so many of these stories
so many times and they're still you've
brought them back to life they're all
interesting even though i've heard so
many of them before um and i think
that's a real testament uh to the book
and and your talent writing it
my question is um
a lot of the books that i think are
really well known about ali remnick's
king of the war king the world uh
hauser's biography obviously
and even recently bro blood brothers uh
these are all written by white men and
now jonathan ike has a new biography out
what do you think it says about ali that
kind of the the most intense uh or most
well-known uh books about him are all
written by white men why why do why
aren't people from the black community
writing books about him you know i i
don't really know um and i can't speak
for why somebody isn't writing a book
but i would say gerald earley's
collection on ali is superb there are a
couple of others
written by african-american athlete
writers that are that are wonderful too
um
i don't know why
but i think ali was just somebody who
appealed to a lot of people and appealed
to a lot of sports writers back in the
time he was fighting at the time that
time um you've had very few
african-american sports writers covering
boxing for the daily press that might
have been a factor so if you look at who
is in the press pit who was covering
the fights in zaire and in manila it's
almost all white writers
that doesn't excuse it but that's
probably has something to do with it
thank you sure
last question i'm afraid
and then i'll be signing books
afterwards uh yeah i just wanted to know
if there what you learned about uh i
understood that i think up until maybe
his death joe frazier had uh
really disheartened by
um during those fights um
you know ali would obviously do what he
did and his promotion and everything but
frazier i think thought he took it too
far and went and referenced him as a
gorilla
and um
i thought that frazier died bitter about
that and i was wondering if you found
out that that relationship was ever
rectified in any way yeah that's one of
those things that ali was not proud of
and one of the things that really um the
tallying angel probably gave him some
bad scores for joe frazier was really
kind to ali especially when ali was out
of boxing
lent him money and offered to help him
find work and when ali returned to the
ring he was really brutal and merciless
toward frasier called him an uncle tom
really tried to humiliate him and and it
hurt joe it hurt joe's whole family his
his son said he was you know taunted at
school
because your daddy's an uncle tom and
and it was strange because ali always um
treated his white opponents better than
he treated his black opponents so i'm
not sure i can explain that behavior um
and it's a shame that nobody ever said
to him if somebody in ollie's entourage
that said you know back off of joe it's
not funny anymore it's not you know i
think ollie thought it would give him an
edge in the ring that he'd have a
psychological edge if he could get under
the skin of his opponents but um he
later apologized to joe late in life but
i got the impression from joe's response
that maybe it was too little too late
so
thank you very much for being here it's
really been a pleasure it's a great book
festival
thank you so much
[Music]
and you've been listening to biographer
jonathan i talk about the life and
politics of muhammad ali now we'll be
back in just a few minutes with more
live coverage from the southern festival
of books in nashville
[Music]
[Music]
next from purdue university biographers
talk about their subjects and political
history
they include sammy davis jr jim and
tammy faye baker
and muhammad ali
this talk was part of a two-day
conference called remaking american
political history
welcome and thank you for attending our
session
on this beautiful friday afternoon i
will have to compete with the outdoors
and hopefully we'll convince you that
you've made the right choice
hanging out with us to talk about media
and biography
and political history between the four
of us we have written at least 17
biographies and that it might be more
than that i was losing count because
randy roberts has written so many we've
written more than half of our total
number i think
um so we have a lot of experience in the
genre we've obviously been drawn to it
and have a an affinity for it in some
way or another
so before we begin let me introduce the
panelists
and as i introduced each of you if you
could just spend a minute or two
telling
the audience what was it that drew you
to biography and and
what is it you love about the genre so
first we have larry maslin he's a
professor in the graduate acting program
at new york university's tisch school of
the arts with an affiliation in the
graduate musical theater writing program
and is particularly interested in the
history of broadway and of comedy he has
written biographies of composer richard
rogers and playwright george s kaufman
in addition to several other books
his most recent biographical work is the
documentary film sammy davis jr i gotta
be me so larry tell us what has drawn
you to biography hi um well i may be a
little uh
different from from the rest of the
panel my
venue is really entertainment so
obviously in entertainment you're
dealing with the public persona of
performers what they sang what they
danced what they acted and then of
course what happens off stage or behind
the curtain is equally fascinating as
you try to
make some sense out of what a performer
did publicly with what were his or her
motivations what was the context of
their time
what trends and tastes changed in my
case particularly american entertainment
to make them in favor or out of favor so
i guess i've always been interested in
that dialectic between on stage and off
stage and
hopefully when
we talk a little more about sammy davis
jr that's particularly persuasive
okay thank you
john wigger is a professor of the
history department at the university of
missouri columbia he is interested in
religious history
particularly methodism
he was also
on my committee when i took my
comprehensive exams and when i wrote my
dissertation so i'm glad that i'm asking
you the questions this time
he has written biographies on minister
francis asbury and most recently ptl the
rise and fall of jimmy jim and tammy
faye baker's evangelical empire so john
could you tell us a little bit about
your
yeah thanks emily and uh um thanks for
organizing this and putting it all
together you still owe me a paper right
that's not true no no way
[Laughter]
so thanks you know i don't really think
of myself uh as a biographer i've never
really thought of it that way um in my
mind i don't research or really write
any differently when i'm doing biography
versus anything else
historical non-fiction
i think the advantage that biography has
is that it lends itself to a good story
well told
you can reach a broad audience with an
engaging story that
has a lot of human drama in it and
that's that's not a bad thing
and i think that's what sort of drew me
to
writing what turns out to be biography
emily said i
wrote a book a few years ago on francis
asbury
a guy who i think is endlessly
fascinating and important it was a big
dense book and nobody read it
and i sat back after doing that and i
thought this is a lot of work
if i'm going to do this i'm going to
write about topics that i care about
that i think are important but that it
will draw in an audience and that's when
i did the jim and tammy book and uh
yeah sure enough i think your mic is off
okay sorry
so do i need to start over and do this
all over again
you just edit it out that's good
um so uh yeah thank you
all right thank you
and randy roberts is a professor in the
history department at purdue university
he is particularly interested in
african-american and sports history
randy has written biographies of mike
tyson john wayne charles lindbergh joe
lewis jack dempsey jack johnson ronald
reagan
bear bryant and joe namath and a team
biography of the pittsburgh steelers
his most recent biographical works are
blood brothers the fatal friendship of
malcolm x and muhammad ali
and a season in the sun the rise of
mickey mantle so randy could you tell us
a little bit about your interest in this
genre yes i
you know
this fits perfectly for me the kind of
the political history and and uh
biography popular culture because i've
always seen myself as working in at the
intersection between political history
between political culture and popular
culture and so
i i write about
performers like you uh actors
athletes but you know i i've never been
really interested in writing a book
about an athlete who's just an athlete
or an actor who was just an actor but
somehow they have to engage in a in a
wider political culture somebody like
for example john wayne or muhammad ali
clearly became iconic and and you could
tell a person's politics if i talk to
somebody and talk to him about john
wayne
their attitudes on john wayne will tell
usually tell me a great deal about their
politics or their attitudes on muhammad
ali will
talk do the same thing you know i
brought a
a quote in here i was looking okay how
can i tie these things together how can
i type paul text because this is a
political conference uh with with
biography of popular culture so i did
find on
a boxing quote uh that that i wanted to
read to you
and it was it it was two-ton tony to
golento the sage of orange new jersey i
don't know if anybody's ever heard of
galento or not uh but he was a roly-poly
boxer fought joe lewis but before he
fought joe lewis he fought a guy named
abe feldman down in miami on george
washington's birthday and so he's trying
to build up the fight a little bit and
and he also wants to you know say
something about american history say
something about american politics say
you know
engage with the
with with the crucial questions of his
day and so this is the quote
now
supposedly this quote is true
but
it came from a journalist so we'll see
uh
he said he's trying to say something
about george washington and build up the
fight at the same time
he said it is time it is high time that
the south came to know and love
washington as we know and love him north
of the equator
why can't we forget the civil war and
its petty grudges washington may have
freed the slaves but remember he also
invented the lightning rod
let the north and south clasp the hand
of friendship on hold hickory's birthday
and try to get there early so anybody
who can conflate george washington
abraham lincoln andrew jackson and
benjamin franklin you know it is truly
the sage of orange new jersey
and i have more on biography but maybe
we can get to it as we go along
okay
and i am emily raymond i'm a professor
in the history department at virginia
commonwealth university and my area of
focus up until now i'm shifting a little
bit but has been hollywood and politics
and i've written biographies on charlton
heston
and most recently a group biography
about black celebrities in the civil
rights movement
called stars for freedom
and
i didn't really think of myself as going
into the biography genre either
i really wanted to write about charlton
heston because this was my dissertation
topic
and
he
it was when he was the president of the
national rifle association
but i also knew that he had been
involved in democratic administrations
and in the civil rights movement before
he came to the gun cause and to
supporting republican candidates so i
was really fascinated about his
evolution and about
what that said about american political
culture so i started with that and then
my next book
i had no intention of being a biography
it was going to just very generally be
about celebrities in the civil rights
movement
but the more i looked at it the more it
became very clear that there were about
six who were really leading figures
in the civil rights movement and they
deserved to be recognized you know as
the earliest most consistent
most effective celebrity supporters so
then i decided to turn it into
a group biography with this kind of
leading six at the forefront
and now my next book is going to be a
dual biography so i i've come to really
love the genre because it's such a great
way to look at these really fascinating
people
in american political culture
and the dynamic they bring to
making change in particular
and
so that's sort of my spiel on biography
i suppose but i guess one thing to point
out is that i feel like biography has a
lot more
uh variety than most people think a lot
of people think biography is just a book
about
one person
but randy's book blood brothers is about
malcolm x and muhammad ali about their
relationship
john wigger's book on ptl is about
jim and tammy fay
and then of course stars for freedom as
a group biography so it doesn't just
have to be about
one person
and what i wanted to ask you all is what
other way
can there be more by more variety to
biography than
the
then might first meet the eye
um can i pitch in yes because i'm
closest so just two quick things i'm
also a documentarian so half of my work
has been non-fiction
publications and half my work has been
film so obviously on film if you're
doing say sammy davis jr
you have a whole different
canvas to work on
and you can you can kind of obviously
use performances in juxtaposition to
other performances as a way of creating
some kind of tension
when you do that the other thing is i
worked on a companion book to another
six-hour documentary series i did for
pbs called make them laugh the funny
business of america and essentially it
was american comedy from chaplain to
golly who did we end with then sarah
silverman i think was the most recent
person we used and and the the director
and i realized that if you were going to
do a film i did a companion book and i
wrote the the documentary episodes but
if you were going to go okay here's
american comedy let's start in 19
whatever 1906 s a picture is for charlie
chaplin um buster keaton oh here's
howard lloyd there's mae west that your
first hour would be entirely silent and
in black and white and people would stop
watching
um so that really forced us to rethink
about how we wanted to what kind of
taxonomy we wanted to create in terms of
ganging uh biographical figures together
so we went through it we realized that
in america there were six great comedic
archetypes there were situation comedies
there were geeks and nerds there were
wise guys there were there was political
satire there were physical comedians and
each generation seemed to churn out
their own version of that uh in a way
that really reflected the demographics
of america the changing demographics of
america so one way we were able to do
that is like an episode with someone for
wise guys and i forgot what it is why is
god the wise guys episode
you know is groucho but not the marx
brothers uh but then red fox who took on
that tradition or eddie murphy who took
on that tradition
and the freddie prinz and so on and so
forth so there was a way of maybe
rethinking certain categories in group
biography that would give it a little
more spark and and uh rather than simply
uh doing things chronologically they
were chronologically but within a
completely different rubric and i think
that was really exciting to work on for
us
yeah that's a really interesting way to
bring
variety to the genre any other thoughts
from you too
what was the question again
about bringing
just
having there's more variety to biography
than i think first meets the eye people
tend to think of it as being about one
person and you just sort of
chronologically go through their life
and then that's it
that's the formula but
what other formulas have maybe you tried
and have worked that that you like well
i think i think that dual biography is
is is an interesting approach you know
certainly the one that i used with uh
with with muhammad ali and malcolm x in
in the book that i wrote with johnny
smith on blood brothers um
there's
there
you you write books at the number of the
books i've done have been not a full
biography but looking at a person in a
particular at a particular time
a crucial time in their life um
i know i've done the full biography and
if you do somebody say like john wayne
a person's life is not interesting all
the time okay you know it's just one
it's a fact and it's not it's not
crucial at
one time and so to take one segment of
it what you feel might be the most
crucial period in their life and then to
dig deeper and to tell a wider story
than you could if you do the full you
know beginning to end biography
is is a way to approach it and that's
what you do with mickey mantle's
in that biography it's the rise yes it's
the rise of mickey mantle
and it ends in 56 and 56 first many more
years yeah yeah you know mickey mantle
before 1956 he was kind of a failure he
came
if he could have been a failure
a failure in terms of expectations he
came up to the yankees and in spring
training i mean he was hitting the ball
over the moon when they were playing
during the the day time uh if you can
hit the ball over a moon in the day
uh anyway it
and everybody said
yogi bear all the players on the team
casey stengel the coach this guy is he's
going to be the next dimaggio he's going
to be the next babe ruth he's going to
be the next lou gehrig and so everybody
expected him to perform immediately like
gary did like dimaggio did like ruth did
they were great from the time they put
on yankees uniforms but mickey would
show signs of brilliance signs of
greatness but then
he would get injured he wouldn't hit in
the clutch uh fans by 55 they were
booing him he tended to be kind of
sultry he got mad he wouldn't talk he
was uncommutative and then in 1956 he
has this enormous breakout season where
he wins a triple crown and and then he
becomes the mickey mantle of legend
and then that's where you're in the book
that's where we end the book yes
so to the extent i think of what i've
done as biographies i think of them more
as group biographies
and
the reason to do biography in that sense
is just to pull the interesting people
out when they're interesting
um
there are certain times when and so in
the ptl story when jim and tammy are the
most interesting people in the room so
to speak but there are times when
they're not and so other people come to
the fore in the story and again i think
the the one advantage of biography is it
allows you to
to weave a narrative that's coherent
that people can follow that's
interesting
but it's not just to tell the story of
someone's life it's it's to make larger
points if you will to to to to draw out
a story that um transcends them even if
they're at the center of it for a large
part of the time
well and one of the i think most common
critiques i've heard about biography
that's well it's just one guy you know
it's just one person you know what can
it
so from that standpoint people feel that
perhaps it doesn't have the same
intellectual heft as perhaps a study of
i don't know voting patterns you know
and
from a certain time period
so yeah how would you respond to that
that that critique that well it's just
one person
i don't think you can make it's tough to
make that a generic statement because
not all it also people become
interesting
in different
times forward in other words we look
back on people there's a whole and
certainly in the theater there's a uh
when we did the broadway documentary
there were people who were fascinating
in their time and then lost to history
performance like at the water is a great
african-american performer who's most
highly paid entertainer in new york city
or may west who was arrested and and
sent to rikers for violating decency
acts and and they faded away and then
all of a sudden the world changes and
their stories become interesting again
because they have what i think a little
bit what you're saying i think a great
biography has what i call velcro
that that you can kind of
move forward in terms of history and it
will start to pick up a person's life in
a way and when we worked on the sammy
davis junior documentary it was it was
shocking to me as someone who knew him
my whole life
he was a venn diagram he was the man who
knew
on one level uh ethel waters and bill
robinson and michael jackson uh john f
kennedy martin luther king archie bunker
and eddie cantor i mean and just his
intersection of lives was tremendous so
that he his life was revelatory of the
times in which he lived and i think
that's what you always look for
yeah and
stanley davis jr in terms of
intellectual challenge he was one of the
most challenging subjects i've ever come
across because he was contradictory
and he was
just someone i really had to wrestle
with to try to figure out how to to
characterize him and the way you do it
in the film is by giving him
like these different categories you know
activists
i forget with the other one yeah
activist singer
impressionist
hipster so he did try to categorize the
chronology of his life
in in the
in the guises that he took on or felt
that he had to take on or society thrust
upon him in his life and i think you
know again entertainment is a little bit
like sports but i don't i mean you're
still if you're an entertainer you're
choosing what songs you're singing or
what plays you're going to act in and
those have tremendous external
circumstances you either you know hit
the ball out of the ballpark i guess or
you don't
so you're again looking at these things
uh going on simultaneously but
in terms of a performer you're always
looking at the choices they make what
are they choosing to portray what are
they choosing to be about because that
is such a vacuum of the times in which
they live and looking back on it i mean
we have we have footage i hope you come
see the screening at 3 30 a footage of
sammy davis when he was five years old
tap dancing and then we have footage of
him three months before he died tap
dancing so within that bracket you can
accomplish i think an awful lot if
you're clever about how you put those
things together
and john i would say repeat the jim and
tammy faye baker book it's not just
about jim and tammy faye right
no it's not it's really about the the
entire
organization event
yeah yeah
and
to the weightiness of biography if your
sources are good i don't see where
it suffers uh in comparison to any other
kind of non-fiction writing um if your
sources are good then then you can tell
a rich story
i think
political history
oftentimes is the history of the
aggregate okay it's history as aggregate
uh biography is history as individuals
but you know there's a
there's an excitement biography there's
a joy to biography you know if i can
tell
one story of a biographer i like i
brought one of his books here he's a guy
by the name of richard holmes has
anybody ever heard of richard holmes in
here
richard holmes
it was is an english biographer
uh of the of romance of the romantic
period he did a big thick book on
shelley a two-volume biography of
coldridge
those sorts but when in 1964
when he was
about 19 years old
he read a book travels with a donkey
through the seven
by robert louis stevenson okay this is
robert lewis stevenson before
he he became famous with what kidnapped
and dr jekyll and treasurer island and
all those books
and so
he read this book and robert louis
stevenson's took this trip with a donkey
through the savanne region of france
which is kind of an appalachian region
of france
and and he was intrigued by the book he
was intrigued by the biography of of
robert louis stevenson at the time
robert lou stevenson was
moving towards his mid late 20s he
hadn't written anything great he had
scottish real strict
calvinist parents like when are you
going to get a job when are you going to
do something with your life and maybe
richard holmes felt the same way that
you know
he was asking what is he going to do he
wants to be a poet is there a life in
poetry
all all the kind of angst that a 19 year
old would have robert lewis stevenson
was going through a love problem uh
relationship problem you know maybe
holmes was i don't know but anyway he
decided to reproduce this trip
sand donkey no donkey but a wide brim
you know very stylish hat okay floppy
hat and uh
and and so he starts off he's sleeping
under the stars and what have you and um
he crosses over a bridge
into langonia a place called langonia
small little village
and it's it's around dusk the shops are
closing up he can smell garlic he can
smell the crushed fruit from the stalls
children are coming out and playing
people are taking walks and he has this
overwhelming urge
overwhelming premonition he's going to
meet robert louis stevenson
okay and and i mean he's serious i you
know this was the 1960s who what else
brought that on i don't know uh but
he has this premonition and he starts
pacing the streets and looking into the
cafes and looking into the to the
saloons and the hotels and he's looking
for him
and then he's by the river by the bridge
and then he looks downstream and he sees
another bridge uh it's it's it's a
bridge that is is crumbled
be covered doesn't go doesn't span the
river anymore it's washed out and he
realizes that's the bridge that robert
louis stevenson came in to langonia
through and it kind of acts as a
metaphor for what we do as a biographer
we're trying to reach those subjects
we're trying to talk with those subjects
uh we're we're trying to you know we're
interrogating people that are no longer
alive in many cases uh you so we talk to
friends if they're recently departed or
if they're still around we read the
sources but it becomes a kind of a
consuming uh an all-consuming
conversation with people
that aren't that it's a one-way
conversation except sometimes i'm not
sure it is a one-way conversation
something and everybody maybe you people
will see other biographers virtually
every biographer i've ever talked to
something coincidentally has happened
you know there they're someplace and
some documents show up that they have no
reason are there they seem to stumble
across something and it seems like it it
shouldn't happen but it does happen so
i'm convinced that there may be a
two-way conversation you're shaking your
head no is that that that
well yes so um one of the things about
sammy davis jr in particular talking
about sources is when he died in in uh
in 89 he left the biggest
he owed more money to the irs than any
individual in american history up to
that point well outstanding which meant
that all of his stuff was locked up
and we made because it was pbs they made
some
lawyers heirs whatever and finally his
adoptive son said
uh
you know
my dad had two storage lockers in
berkeley in burbank do you want to come
see them
and we'll say we're getting on a flight
right now we're we'll be there in
six hours don't go anywhere and and sure
enough sammy who was a rat pack no pun
intended pack rat no pun intended was
kept everything he was a photographer
you know
all this stuff that was like that was
like you know el dorado for us um
and
we were
doing all that and the next day we were
flying to las vegas to interview jerry
lewis
and i'm sure you all know this but if
you've ever gone through any kind of
scrapbook or whatever and then you have
yellowed paper and stuff
it leaves a detritus on the ground and
after two days in these storage lockers
with fluorescent lighting and drinking
endless cups of coffee it's time to back
up
and the floor was like a ticker tape
parade there was so much
of this little
detritus on the floor and all of a
sudden i was picking stuff up and there
was this card
and it said ciro's on it and that's not
the real card siros was big nightclub
where sammy made his big breakthrough in
1951 and jerry lewis was in the audience
and it was the kind of thing you'd find
on a table and i opened it up and these
were jerry lewis's notes
the night he saw sammy davis jr
saying you you're talking a fake british
accent that doesn't make any sense you
treat your father and uncle like they're
props they're not this is the way you
should address the audience and the next
day we took it and we were able to say
to jerry lewis
have you seen this in in whatever it was
60 68 no i haven't and that allowed him
to talk about that he said i remember it
like it was yesterday and we then we
found a film of sammy saying jerry lewis
came to see me at cyros and he gave me
this advice and it changed my life so
you know exactly what you're saying this
sort of golden ticket was actually just
lying there on the floor and it showed
us the way to go forward and maybe sammy
made it happen he may
this is a two-way conversation
[Laughter]
well another theme that we wanted to
talk about was the use of media as
source material and as evidence so i
guess i'd like for each of you to talk
about the kind of media and we you've
done that a little bit already but the
kind of media you consulted
and what insights they gave you
want to start john
sure
one of the fun things about doing the
the ptl project was
i got to talk to living people
i'd never done that before in my career
i did get my cub up and said that uh
sometimes the you find out that uh the
living are less cooperative than the
dead
in what they will and will not tell you
but the other fun thing was just the
range of sources so newspaper sources
trial transcripts
i learned that a good trial transcript a
good prosecutor does half your work for
you
more than half because they can compel
people to say under oath things they
don't want to say
trial transcripts and video in this case
jim and tammy
lived their life on the screen so to
speak in fact it's it's similar to your
story when i was very early in this
project
over 20 000 hours of their television
show was in the han was in the hands of
a private collector
and i started trying to find this and at
one point the guy called me up and
offered to
sell me 20 000 hours of videotape he had
in like four tractor trailers
and it ended up going to the assemblies
of god archive in springfield missouri
and i got to use it there which was
obviously a much better home for it but
uh
um uh i'm not quite sure how this
addresses your question but just the the
range of sources and and a lot of them
were media
and again that was that was it was one
of the great things about working on
this you you
work with people who live their life in
the public eye
they leave a big footprint
they leave a lot of sources to work with
did you watch all 20 000 hours so
the the good and bad of that is no i
couldn't and it's probably a good thing
because that's several years of 24 hours
a day
it turned out that since it most of it
was from the 70s and 80s some of it from
the 60s it was on a variety of different
film mediums including two inch
quadruplex tape
and it had to be digitized
to be useful and in fact a lot of the
machines to digitize that kind of stuff
are are 40 years old themselves
and so the archive could only afford to
digitize a few hundred hours at a time
so i think i only ended up with three or
four hundred hours in the end
they let me select what to digitize out
of out of the collection as far as as we
could tell but um the vast majority of
it still sits there um sort of slowly
decomposing
yeah well randy one of the things about
your
blood brothers book you talk about how
muhammad ali
and malcolm x had a strong relationship
that was
underappreciated
and in some cases it was actually
in the public eye
and you went back to old media
sources can you talk about that yeah it
it wasn't it wasn't in the public eye i
mean here we have muhammad ali this is
before his muhammad ali he's cassius
clay and his goal was to become
heavyweight champions of the world
then and he meets he meets malcolm x and
he's influenced by malcolm x and he's
he's already starting to embrace the
nation of islam
but yet
if it if the word gets out that he's a
black muslim that he's a member of the
nation of islam
he's probably never going to get a
chance to fight for the heavyweight
championship of the world he's going to
be toxic at that time i mean you know
boxing's going through a period there's
has all sorts of problems they don't
need a champion that has identified in
the early 1960s with a movement is
considered a hate movement
wasn't but
that's how americans viewed it at the
time and so
we were able to johnny smith and i we
worked on it together we were able to
find
you know a lot
an incredible amount of material on
malcolm giving speeches and muhammad ali
giving speeches and giving talks and one
of the things we were able to
reconstruct is
would watch malcolm say something
okay and he'd give a speech and then use
a metaphor and use a story and then
shortly afterwards you know you'd see
muhammad ali use the same story the same
metaphor the same example and the great
thing about muhammad ali he was a
wonderful person is if you told him
something if you told him a story the
next day he would tell the story and the
next day he'd tell it again and pretty
soon you'd think he was the origin of
the story and he would tell it better
than anybody else would tell he was he
was just great at telling the story so
using that media was good uh and with
the john wayne
of course
there were interviews uh there were 200
films roughly that he made and you could
see him progress his his art progress
his character progress that that
individual that iconic individual how it
evolved over
over times you know i i have one more
story
it's an interview story on a john wayne
book again one of these
serendipitous
moments
i i we i tried to get an interview with
a woman by the name of mary saint john
who was uh john wayne's personal
secretary his entire career and she had
never been interviewed really by anybody
and i called her and she was living in
kansas city at that time
right outside of kansas city and she
said you know i don't know
i you know i don't know anything more
than anybody else knows you know
okay can we come can cam come out and
talk to you okay come show up at nine
o'clock eight o'clock whatever it was it
was early in the morning
and um i started asking questions
and she
said no no i i don't want to answer
questions let me just talk
okay let me just tell you okay so tell
us the story
it was like therapy okay she just
started i mean clearly she was in love
with john wayne i mean
not romantic i mean she just admired the
guy
nothing salacious
and she was on every set with him she
you know she was his personal secretary
she went on every set and basically
people on the set you have actors that
are performing in the movies and then
you have people behind this set
hair dressers and makeup people who have
nothing to do all day long except gossip
okay so she knew every
every gossip you know
who was sleeping with who in hollywood
at this time what was going on i mean it
was incredible and
when
took her to lunch okay we went to lunch
she kept talking went to dinner she kept
talking came back
literally the first interview lasted
close to 17 hours wow just you know it
was just
all material that i hadn't and it
allowed me to see john wayne in a
different way
i'm rambling i'm sorry i i i want to
pose this to to the rest of my panelists
i i've i've interviewed people who who
work with people we interviewed say
obviously jerry lewis but billy crystal
who not only went on to impersonate
sammy davis on television but actually
opened for him for many years so they
have this kind of backstage knowledge
but i i often found that the people you
interview
it's important important for them to
well it's important to go in there
knowing that you may know more about
them than they do
and and not necessarily just sort of
like say oh this is the real this is the
horse's mouth as it were so therefore
i'm gonna hear everything sort of
unfiltered or undistinguished sometimes
if you throw stuff out them or you
contradict them you actually get some
more interesting stuff out of them did
you find that sometimes your best
interviews are people that are not used
to being interviewed you know if you
interview celebrities they have a
you ask a question i remember when i
dealt with jack dempsey i would ask a
question he would never really answer
the question it would remind him of
another question and he would give me a
stock answer that he had given a million
times before and they're used to
protecting their persona
whereas if you're interviewing somebody
that's a makeup artist they're not used
to being interviewed so you get
sometimes i think better stories from
them did you find that i think it's also
great uh sometimes i mean uh
uh i also find it if you have some sort
of documentation you can present them
with i did a american masters on richard
rodgers who's had two daughters who were
very successful in their own right and
he had written something in his
autobiography that said if i kept
working with larry hart into the 40s i
would wind up
going crazy or being an alcoholic or
both
and in fact we know that he was both
and i read that quote to his daughter i
said what do you make of him writing
that in his autobiography and she said
on camera well of course he did become
both and he was able to compartmentalize
it and he the fact that he could write
that he wasn't when he actually was and
we had to put him into a into a drink
tank and while he was about to open a
big show in 1954 blah blah blah so i
think sometimes if you have
if you have stuff that you can something
they said earlier or something they
wrote earlier it can really
pose a kind of disjunction which i think
is sort of what you're talking about you
you want to create some kind of of of
improvisation out of people because
that's when the best stuff comes out so
the key is when you interview somebody
really do your homework
you know what you're looking for yeah
bringing pictures sometimes helps or
going to an actual location with them
and
just
seeing what they think about it what
they remember
i found has been useful
or contradicting them with something
that somebody else has said and have
them react so that way you're they're
not arguing with you they're arguing
with the person you brought in the quote
about so it's not confrontational
necessarily
i think also people whose perceptions
have changed and who's
whose experiences would be interpreted
differently now
um you can they'll they'll tell a
different story than maybe they told 30
years ago so what i have in mind is um
one of the best interviews i had for the
ptl book was jessica hahn
and jessica had told her story in the
you know in the late 80s and early 90s
but the late 80s and early 90s was a way
different time in the way that her
experience would be looked at especially
post me too movement
and then talking to her more recently
it it just offered an entirely different
take from all of this evidence all of
this you know video of her and
interviews and so forth that i had for
30 years ago is just wonderful to to
to now dive back into the story 30 years
later in an entirely different context
and someone who had lived
thinking about that for 30 years and
who's who's who's thinking about it it
had changed
well another thing that all of our
subjects have in common is that they all
seem to bring something new to the media
landscape
there something exciting or something
different or something revolutionary
so could you all talk a little bit about
what that is
i mean the the our work on it or the
subject we've written about the subject
you've written about
um well
we were talking emily
i think she's a little modest about it
appears quite wonderfully in our
documentary and is able to contextualize
sami's contribution to the civil rights
movement in a way
that um
uh harry belafonte and sydney poitiers
frankly sort of pushed him
out of the spotlight
in the years after sammy died for their
own sort of complex reasons
and harry wouldn't speak to us foreign
did you speak to harry yeah directly i
tried yeah difficult
but uh uh you know again if you're doing
sammy davis jr you're talking about
someone for whom the spotlight was
breakfast lunch and dinner so a little
bit like your twenty thousand hours of
of videotape we had a we had almost too
much material but
in a visual documentary which hopefully
again you'll you'll get to see
if you know you have something
in the bag
we had some performances that had if we
did not know we had them if we did not
know we could license them if we did not
know we could digitize them and show
them then we'd simply have to write
about something else so so you don't
want uh jesse jackson or quincy jones or
whoever say well there was this night in
chicago in 1972 i'll never forget it and
sammy got up and he sang this and he did
that and the audience booed him and blah
blah we happen to have that footage so
we have the footage of uh you know his
his groundbreaking performance on all in
the family so we were able to build our
interviews back from that but again
um you know i'm talking about
documentary biography which is obviously
a visual and auditory medium so i would
say that sammy davis jr thing and i'm
wondering certainly like you mentioned
john wayne certainly muhammad ali you
part of the the flip side is often you
deal with subjects who are an
embarrassment of riches and the question
is what to leave on the cutting room
floor whether it's a book or a
documentary
and it is it's harder when you're
writing about a performance than when
you can just
show it
but as far as far as media source
material for me and then
how
sammy davis jr brought something new to
the media landscape i think the most
valuable thing for me was
his
appearances on variety shows which in
and of themselves don't sound that
exciting because they're usually just a
few minutes and you know they're just
kind of in and out but
he in the 1950s was on
at least this is what i could count like
47 different variety show appearances
and by seeing a number of them they're
not all available but by seeing a number
of them
i was able to realize that he brought
something really new to television most
network programming was very
stereotypical in the way that it showed
african americans on television programs
you know like a sitcom
but on these variety shows he could come
out and just be himself and joke around
and have a familiar relationship
and a semi-intimate relationship with
the
white people on the show that
really showed an integration
that you just weren't seeing on network
programming and that's how most
americans got to know sammy davis jr it
wasn't
most people didn't go to night clubs you
know most people saw him on tv
and he became so familiar and so beloved
that that was one of the reasons he
could be
a really effective civil rights activist
so without just this kind of constant
variety show
presence
then i just i think it would have been a
lot different but it's so interesting
you say that because there's a corollary
to that which is
again you'll see in the documentary that
that him being embraced by white
performers in some cases literally
was a a uh
like a hand reaching out to an entire
community and based on knowing that we
had that footage to show we then
interviewed a number of black critics
and and professors who grew up during
that time and they said to me some of
the most revelatory things we have on
camera like you've no idea if you were
an african-american family in detroit or
atlanta or new orleans where these
people grew up they you would call each
other up on the phone and said oh my god
lena horne is on tonight on ed sullivan
or sammy's on the eddie cantor show and
everyone in the community would gather
around because it was so rare in the
1950s to see a a black individual let
alone a major black individual on a
network television show so when you find
those media things it's important then
to stretch the canvas a little bit and
say well i like his performance he
certainly sings really well here huh i
wonder what black audiences felt about
that in 1954 and make sure that you get
that context in as well yeah and to just
know that he was on isn't enough you
really do have to see it to see steve
allen like uh mopping his brow and and
steve allen does too um mop his bro and
like it's like they're friends you know
so it's really it was effective from
that standpoint
so john what about jim and tammy what
what did jim bring that was new to media
in the late 70s and 1980s
yeah i think the the one way to describe
this is this story has at least three
layers to it
so most people's entry point to the
story was the sex and money scandal in
in the late 80s
but the thing
one of the one of the things you can do
in telling that story is
is jump back earlier so why did why were
these people celebrities why did anyone
care at that point
and basically
ptl had three innovations
really quickly the first one in the 60s
and early 70s was baker created a new
kind of christian talk show
he were he and tammy were small time
pentecostal evangelists in the south and
they would unwind at night by watching
johnny carson who was kind of the height
of cultural cool
in the 60s and baker would say why can't
why can't somebody
do that do a christian version of that
and up till then most christian
television was a church service on tv
more or less
um so his first big innovation was
creating this new format the christian
talk show that looked initially a lot
like the tonight show with johnny carson
it later looked like oprah i mean it it
was it was innovative and
it was something new
the second was in the late 70s
they figured out because the small uhf
station they were broadcasting in
charlotte from
was owned by ted turner and they watched
ted turner put his station up on
satellite
and they in effect created the first
private satellite television network a
year before espn went on the air
and it was innovative and it it
dramatically expanded their audience
and it also produced a tremendous amount
of money
and that led to the third innovation
which
which was really
their their undoing as well but baker
wanted to create a christian disneyland
and so he built heritage usa and in
1986 they had six million visitors it
was the third biggest theme park after
disneyland and disney world
and so you have all of these innovations
and a lot of them and they they revolve
around media
they revolve around the talk show and
the satellite network
and this is kind of what built them up
to the point where
the the sex and money scandal mattered
but that's the entry point for most
people and the service you can do is
sort of pulling it back and and telling
that story that leads up to that
um and then i think the third layer is
is to further step back and just say why
does this matter why does any of this
matter what does this say about american
culture and american religion
did other evangelicals
sort of pattern themselves after him
with the satellite network and the
television show yes
they did
he actually he was with pat robertson
before he launched his own
ministry and helped create the 700 club
and then he was with paul crouch in
southern california and helped create
the
trinity broadcasting network and
there were there were many competitors
and uh
people doing more or less the same thing
but as all of this is sort of developing
and swirling around they're one of the
people at the at the center of the story
and they're just fun i mean tammy is is
endlessly engaging everyone loved tammy
that's one of the things i found out
doing the book is
she was someone that just
everyone loved her and she and she
continues to have this enduring
following and presence there's going to
be they keep threatening to do a musical
broadway musical about her yeah kristin
chenoweth has has one
yes absolutely larger than life
yeah
i might could i just add i um got pulled
in to do an abc 2020 special on this
that aired earlier this year
and it ended up being their their best
rated program in a year
um it was though it was the episode that
pulled in the most viewers
because of you
yeah of course because of me on camera
no maybe because of tammy yeah i think
that's probably more likely
and don't you say in your book that
they sort of created in a way the first
reality show because they're on tv so
much
they did um and uh yeah i mean their
show was uh
originally two hours a day um they did
it unscripted jim refused to script
anything
um the production people and i talked to
many of them never knew what was going
to happen next
and
viewers tuned in because they loved that
i mean sometimes it was sloppy and
ridiculous
but it was always
unpredictable and fun people tuned in
just to see what would happen next and
that's part of his undoing too right the
unscripted nature and how he
just starts selling shares to heritage
usa in a way that's no one has approved
in the organization
yeah exactly so um
jim said everything and anything on
television and when he finally went to
trial what the prosecutors were able to
do was to pull out the pieces that they
wanted
and they were things he had said and
they were inappropriate and they were
fraudulent but he had said just about
everything i mean if you wanted to
if you if you wanted to find him saying
nearly anything on any topic you could
do that because he was just on for hours
on it yeah
unscripted
what about muhammad ali what what did he
bring that was new to the media
landscape
before muhammad ali
athletes were we had the stereotype
athlete you know ah shucks the mickey
mantle type of athlete uh very few words
non-controversial
you don't deal with politics you you you
just stay away from everything
controversial well muhammad ali was was
controversial i mean he wins the title
as soon as the day after he wins the
title at his press conference he says he
announces that his name is no longer
muhammad ali he's going to go by
muhammad by cassius or his name's no
longer cassius clay he's going to go by
cassius x
that um
he he's a member of the nation of islam
or certainly hints that he's a member of
the nation of islam that he's going you
know he's he's political suddenly
he he he was just a little bit ahead of
his generation i you know he comes out
against vietnam before it's the popular
stance to take so i mean he just
completely changes the landscape for for
for an athlete i mean he creates the
landscape for the athletes have today
where they can take political positions
most of them don't but they they
certainly can and some do
i think that's an interesting um
again a kind of venn diagram because
what we're talking i'm gonna i'm gonna
sort of injudiciously lump uh uh tammy
fay into the entertaining entertainment
category but typically these are these
are roads that have such
um
tension when they're cr when the wires
get crossed and you know i'm always we
worked for a long time on a documentary
which we couldn't get made but maybe we
will do called actors in america which
was the offstage history of actors in
america and
edwin booth in april of 1865 was the
most famous actor in america and he was
doing repertory in boston
and when he finished the show that night
federal marshals came in and said what
do you know about what happened down in
forge theater which your brother did and
he was escorted in the dead of night by
federal marshals from from boston to new
york um and he essentially retired from
the stage for about five of his most
important years because he was an
entertainer and all of a sudden the
political world just spilled one of the
gravest messes in american history onto
his lap and he did not there was no
there was no precedent for how to
toggle between those two things and i
think we find a lot about obviously we
live in a world now with with
basketball athletes in the post muhammad
ali world where athletes are comfortable
in some cases expected to be political
but in the entertainment world it was to
be avoided at all costs and sammy davis
said look he was in that sort of johnny
mathis era of people who said literally
i i don't have any
uh
providence to make statements about this
i sing i dance i act and the world got
too much with him late and soon until
harry belafonte in particular said
you've got to come down to selma and
sammy davis jr was born in new york he
had never gone south of the mason-dixon
line in his life because he knew what
would happen to him if he did and he
literally had to be dragged kicking and
screaming down to selma by hara
belafonte and martin luther king so
there are these aspects of politics
where where you know again we live in an
era with obviously a former actor became
president or head of the nra or sean
penn and susan sarandon people like that
gravitate towards a political stance
easily comfortably and
passionately but that is not the
extensive history of this country at all
those were lines you did not cross you
did it at peril of your uh of your
entertainment career
i think one of the things that out that
muhammad ali did when he was cassius
clay is he he was one of the first
athletes who was just
fabulously aware of the camera okay he
would do anything for publicity he he
read poetry down at the bitter end in
greenwich village he uh
he was really interested in getting in
like saying a musical number on the ed
sullivan show he sang him usually he
brought out an lp yeah a musical lp and
and he was he wanted to get in life
magazine okay life was big back in the
early 1960s and he knew that he sports
illustrated was good and sport magazine
and boxing magazines were good but how
do you get in life magazine and so a
photographer was taking pictures of him
for sports illustrated and this
photographer had had
life magazine pictures and and so
muhammad ali knew that he took
underwater pictures and he had done an
underwater
spread for life magazine so muhammad
cash's clay still at the time says well
you know um i work out i've got this new
workout regimen it's it's underwater you
know it develops the tension develops
the punchings better and you ought to
take pictures of it so the guy comes
down with his underwater camera with a
scuba diving gear and he gets it
he does contrails of bubble water coming
out and he gets these great shots and it
gets in life magazine
cassius clay had never worked out in
water in his life you know he couldn't
swim but but he knew that this was a way
to get a new audience and so the camera
was important the new audience the
spreading his name
yeah i think that's another thing that
all of these topics have in common is
the way their relationship with the
press and how sometimes it could be
adversarial and sometimes it could be
[Music]
the
the celebrity playing the press and
other times it would be more the
opposite where the press was playing
them
um
and so with muhammad ali you talk a lot
about and with mickey mantle you talk a
lot about
sports writers and what they saw their
their view
you know what they viewed themselves as
their role in terms of their subjects
yeah well that was all media too it used
to be in the 2030s 20s 30s 40s 50s up
through the 60s is
the sports writer's job was to describe
what took place at an event
so that's that's what they did and the
sports writer's job was the g whistle is
to build up the athlete okay the
athletes are are godlike so you have
people like grantland rice you know
etched against the blue gray or
october sky the four horsemen ride again
all that type of thing
by the 60s you have a new group of
journalists that are called they call
themselves or jim cannon gives them the
name chipmunks and so they call
themselves chipmunks and what they do
is they realize people are seeing
they're seeing on television they're
seeing the fights
the fight is is is all across america
the events are all across america so
they need to get into they need to get
into the locker room and they need to
tell more not
building them up as athletes but showing
what they're really like you know we
have a new form of journalism like
mountains ball four you know
expose journalism and so the the
landscape is changing and muhammad ali
comes in to the world when that
landscape is changing and he's perfect
the chipmunks love him there's a great
story that bob lipsite tells and and he
he's interviewing muhammad ali and it's
down in miami before the list and fight
before he wins the championship and ali
is just spectacular he's talking a mile
a minute he's giving the reporters
everything they want and then joe lewis
shows up and joe lewis
said virtually nothing he was a quiet
guy but all the old sports writers all
the jimmy cannons the the old sports
writers go with to talk to joe lewis and
and
lipsite says to one of the sports
writers said
where are you guys going the story is
here
and the sports writers said to bachelor
lewis
you don't understand you should have
seen them when you know that that was
the hero of their youth you know this is
a new generation
but there's also i'm fascinated because
that's what i grew up with this
complicity as the the the
the performer slash athletes
have more
um real estate in the media like you're
saying you can show the fights now so
they don't have to be done on the
microphone
i was always fascinated by that
complicity between cosell and ali right
and then you have an equally the
probably the most improbable media
reporter of all time in terms of cosell
but they
must have worked out something that was
mutually to their advantage right in
their in their
sort of uh relationship no no question
about it they both understood that the
other was helpful to their career was
creating a larger fame of course ali was
probably more important to coasel than
cosell was to ali but they both
they were an act really it was always an
act yeah and they used the same routines
over and over same poems you know your
your hair looks like a horse's tail or
something like that for uh cosell's
toupee yeah because i see a sort of an
analogy between that and the rat pack
and sinatra and sammy davis that there
were these public events
that that were
magnified private events i mean they
obviously
said i mean uh sammy davis idolized
sinatra and in many ways sinatra was
better for sammy davis than sammy davis
was for sinatra but they had a they had
something that went on behind closed
doors they were they were able to sort
of metamorphose into something that was
a like you said a great kind of double
act in american entertainment how do you
deal with uh i i listened to serious
sinatra on their radio station and
sometimes they'll play the stuff in
vegas and the rat pack will be there and
sammy davis jr and in the unbelievably
condescending way
that sinatra and dean martin will treat
sammy davis jr do you deal with that
there's easily 20 minutes in the
documentary about that
but i think it's an unresolvable issue
because oddly enough i mean just to fill
you in if you don't know the rat pack
were two italians a jew and an
african-american who converted to
judaism right and the son-in-law of the
president
and a lot of their humor was very
hard-hitting it was
because sammy was not only black but was
the youngest of the group
um
and uh had a uh uh was physically short
he was picked on a lot there are all
sorts of things i mean dean martin used
to pick him up and say i want to thank
the naacp for giving me this tremendous
award oh cut that out
and and there's the the documentary
really
uh doesn't come down on any side because
whoopi goldberg and billy crystal
who would ostensibly be sensitive to
that say you know what in the
entertainment business that's the way it
was and what we don't remember
because we don't see them are the clips
of dean martin being told he was a drunk
or anti-italian jokes about sinatra or
anti-jewish jokes about joey bishop but
but because of the world in which we
live understandably the sami stuff has
sort of bubbled to the surface and it's
a it's a bit it's interesting um again
with with coastal and ali it's a bit of
a devil's bargain because
sammy knew
that this was the biggest platform in
america and playing with sinatra and
getting access to all of that was the
golden ticket to his career and they
genuinely loved each other but again the
world spins around and um you know i'm
sure what with the lewis schmelling
fight and all sorts of things that are
racially sensitive in our in our history
are looked at one way when they happen
another way 30 years later and another
way 30 years later
so you have to be i think cognizant of
where that ball is bouncing all the time
well and
speaking of relationship with the press
um how would you describe jim and tammy
baker's relationship with the press
did they try to cultivate the press or
they just do their own thing
well not really um before the scandal
their their biggest contact point was
the charlotte observer and that was a
decidedly hostile relationship on both
sides and again it was the kind of
relationship that i don't really think
could happen today
between that kind of local newspaper and
this
enormous
ministry christian ministry and theme
park
right in their back door outside of
charlotte
everything changes once the scandal
happens in in 87
and
the the kind of
highlight of this is they they go on
nightline with ted koppel which was
enormously influential at the time
and it was the highest
rated episode of couple's career
and he was widely criticized afterward
for being too soft on them one
one reporter wrote that he had all the
ferocity of an overweight house cat
[Laughter]
by the way in the abc thing that aired
earlier this year the couple's on there
quite a bit and they really treat him
gently they don't bring up any of that
at all
he gets to reinterpret his interaction
with with jim and tammy
but it proved that if nothing else that
even though people didn't know them
koppel didn't know them he didn't know
what to make of them or how to handle
them they knew media they spent their
entire careers on television and they
knew how to handle television
and
that they pretty much ate him alive that
night
one thing you talk about
is
how
you know
i guess as biographers we always have to
grapple with the public versus the
private and
how much these interviews how much are
they really telling us about the private
lives and one thing i found so
interesting in your book was
we could tell how stressed tammy pay was
based on her
makeup
yeah her makeup
it was really a mask that she wore
to distance herself from
the public
and all of the staff said we we could
tell every day what kind of a mood tammy
was in the the thicker her makeup the
worse her mood
um and uh yeah that that's and so you
can almost use that as a source
sure like you know you could cross-check
what's going on in her life
and see what kind of makeup she's
wearing that day
you actually could and her hair
um if she was wearing her natural
usually short hair
um later in her career or if she was
wearing one of the big wigs that
that she often wore
the big wig was not a good day
it was
just super stressed out
yeah exactly
well another thing that our subjects
have in common
is that they were
only somewhat interested in politics or
sometimes not interested in politics at
all
but they still came to play an important
role in political culture in the
post-war
era
so
that's kind of kind of my concluding
theme before we turn it over to to
audience questions so
larry in the movie about david yeah i
mean again that's that you actually hit
the nail on the head that is the major
one way one major trajectory of of
telling his life which is he grew up
um
as
self segregated as self-segregated as
you could be in america because not only
was he black he was an entertainer
and
when he managed to hitch his wagon to
the magic that was the rat pack the rat
pack threw all of their weight behind
john f kennedy and
we have some very wonderful i think uh
commentary about how the rat pack
represented you know a group of ethnic
people coming together to support a
young president
but
as we know um once the inauguration ball
happened sammy was actively disinvited
by the white house because kennedy did
not want to incur the wrath of some
southern democrats that he had dragged
on board reluctantly and sammy just was
totally disillusioned he was dragged as
i said somewhat kicking and screaming
initially into the civil rights movement
but i think you might concur that
towards the the end certainly by the
time martin luther king is assassinated
he's he's out in the on the front lines
and thanks to emily in fact uncovered
the the information that uh he probably
either in kind or actually out of his
pocket contributed more to the civil
rights movement than any celebrity
uh and then of course
this guy who comes you know nixon comes
along and and starts to dangle bright
shiny things in front of him and an
ambassadorship or speaking on behalf of
the black population and would you like
to come to the white house would you
like to stay overnight in the lincoln
bedroom
and sammy says sounds good to me
and throws himself
quite forcefully behind the nixon
administration in 72 and 73
goes to visit vietnam
on the administration's behalf and is
essentially so tone deaf
um to his own
uh community that the reverberations i
think were felt through through the rest
of his life that's where we start the
documentaries so you know performers are
not
you know necessarily excellent
barometers of political taste or
political action and frequently
find themselves
quite thrown into the wind back or
thrown back and forth on the boat
depending on the shifting tides of
politic uh popular opinion of the day so
i think in a way
uh sammy's story is a kind of um
you know a bit of a warning story about
what happens when people who are frankly
out of their league politically uh
embrace causes that they may not know
the the deep uh the deep consequences of
yeah i mean he was drawn
more through personal connections than
political ideology
so
um
and
after being totally shunned by the
kennedy administration you could see why
if he developed a relationship with with
nixon then he would be comfortable you
know pushing for him but it does it has
such a devastating impact at the time on
his reputation as an activist
and i felt that his reputation as an
actor too yeah and i felt like it
until i came along
and looked at some of his civil rights
work in the 1950s very early
that it totally undermined his
historical reputation
into the present so it was
one of those situations where he wasn't
that interested in politics politics
came to him and then he played an
important role
in sort of racial
political culture in same way with the
bakers they weren't that interested in
politics but they were sort of on the
front lines of this evangelical
political culture in a way
i think this is one way in which this
story can be useful today
because throughout most of their careers
jim and tammy were very politically
naive
they did not start with much of a
political agenda at all
by the time by the late 70s they have a
big following and they have they become
attractive to politicians because they
control a big audience
and so
baker goes to the carter white house he
rides in air force one with jimmy carter
he interviews ronald reagan on camera
when reagan's running in 1980
and in one sense you can say well
they're politically important
but the problem is if you start there
and say
these people are are primarily political
actors you misunderstand them entirely
um they're not primarily political
actors the politics was a secondary they
the thing baker loved about politics was
the celebrity value of it right who
doesn't want to ride on air force one
who doesn't want to be photographed in
the white house shaking hands with the
president or having lunch with the first
lady
that was their their primary interest
and
the reason i say i think it's
informative today is i i think a lot of
people when they look at the so-called
religious right and evangelicals they
tend to say well these are political
organizations let's start there and if
you start there you you misunderstand
them sure they may have political
involvement they have a sort of
political
footprint
but you'll never understand them if you
start there and say this is all about
politics because certainly in this case
it wasn't all about politics the
politics was secondary
did the did their scandal like the
sexual and financial scandals
did those scandals hurt
the religious right politically
um
i don't
that's a pretty broad category
um it certainly hurt televangelists
um and they weren't the only ones jimmy
swagger general roberts at exactly the
same time had their own meltdowns in
spectacular fashion
it it changed the
it changed the way
in the case of evangelicals it changed
the way they interacted with politics
but it didn't
it didn't
it didn't really reshape the contours of
that because again they weren't
primarily political organizations so
their demise so to speak as an
organization didn't really have any
effect on that because that wasn't what
they were primarily about
okay
randy one of the things i learned from
your book was that the nation of islam
discouraged politics
like discouraged voting
discouraged it was a separatist movement
so yeah they're not trying to reform
america they're trying to separate from
uh and
and and that allowed them to be a little
bit less controversial i mean
oddly enough it was a it was almost
going back to the 19th century i mean
they're going back to the marcus garvey
they're going back to it's a nationalist
organization
and and at that time where cassius clay
is coming into the picture
malcolm x is beginning to tire of that
malcolm x is saying look we've we've got
to do something in the civil rights
movement we've got it
you know we talk we talk a good game but
we're not doing anything and and he
become and he's starting to become more
controversial of course most famously
after uh john f kennedy is is
assassinated and he's told say nothing
the nation of islam the preachers were
said do not make any comments on this
assassination this was a revered man in
america don't say anything and of course
malcolm does malcolm says well you know
as an old country boy you know this is
just chickens coming home to roost and
this doesn't make me sad it makes me
glad and of course he's uh he's
officially silenced by the nation of
islam so
muhammad ali cassius clay still is
caught between now who does he follow
does he go with elijah muhammad does he
go with this more conservative really
separatist movement or does he go with
malcolm who's being pushed out of the
nation of islam and is clearly going to
form his own
organization that will be more orthodox
in terms of civil rights movement so it
puts him in a difficult situation i i
think this is one of the problems he is
actively political there's no question
about it but he was a boxer before
anything else
you know he's like john wayne
john wayne didn't serve during world war
ii he becomes the image of the american
soldier american sailor american flyer
in world war ii but he never enlisted he
never served in world war ii but after
the war his interest in politics
to generalize with two things number one
he becomes a cold warrior most americans
adopted the cold war position number two
is he couldn't stand america's taxation
policy the world war ii taxation which
was taking like charleston heston like
ronald reagan you know 90 of your income
you know he wanted to change so he he
moved from being a democrat to being a
republican but
if you talked with people talked to john
wayne he didn't talk about politics he
talked about movies
but you you you get that image of john
wayne uh that's attached to western
iconography and you throw it into the
republican party and it's it's a pretty
heady brew
it's interesting because johnny johnny
mathis actually said it um during
birmingham he said you know
don't ask me about that i'm just an
entertainer
and i'm wondering whether those four
words are actually
you know certainly in this generation a
kind of meaningless paradox
i think in the 50s and 60s you could
probably get away with saying that but i
think that's actually a meaningless
thing to say post muhammad ali post
sammy davis post sydney i mean post a
lot of people but uh i think there was a
period in american history where that
was a position you could take
and now i think it's it's probably just
not possible i don't know yeah it's just
politics and political culture sucks
them in a symbol well it's the media i
mean you know khan kaepernick i mean i
mean everything in in athletics has
changed post ali and a lot of that has
to do with and i know nothing about
sports mind you um i only know
entertainment but again these platforms
are so large and they meet so many
people and they meet you
um
also in in john wayne's ear and i
suppose
certainly joe lewis's era you could
control the me you could control when
you were on camera now you get
interviewed or you say something or
somebody picks up something on a mic or
backstage in a locker room backstage and
you just that you you lose control of
your narrative in that way the most
ironic one i think is sidney poitier i
mean what was it 67 or 68 he has three
huge movies guess who's coming for
dinner uh concerned with love and in the
heat of the night in the heat of the
night
and by the end of the year he's passed
the movement has passed them by
he goes from being the greatest hero to
not an uncle tom but
passe
well i think this is a good time to open
it up for audience questions if anyone
has something they'd like to ask
we can't
yes
oh we can bring you the microphone
yes
oh great
so this is a fascinating panel i greatly
uh admire uh this genre i should say i'm
uh cole jones i teach at uh purdue um
but it strikes me that that biography is
actually very uh
it's actually a very challenging genre
right because how do you reconcile the
imperative to to tell the story of
someone's life with the necessity of
making an argument uh that intervenes uh
in scholarly debates right that that
reveals something new that
and so how do you do that do you is it
explicit is it implicit how do you weave
argument and analysis with narrative
when telling the story of an
individual's life
okay
go ahead oh that's a biggie
it's also to tell the story of a
person's life i mean to tell john
wayne's life
he made 200 films as i said before
well you just can't go one filming they
did this film he did that film he did
that you have to you have to search for
a larger meaning in that life why was he
important why is he iconic you know why
was he politically
a focal point of america in the 1960s
into the 1970s
and the 50s beyond that so it's you're
just telling the full story uh the the
if sammy davis jr i mean to tell his
story without telling the story of race
in america would make no sense you'd
just be telling an entertainment story
you you have to engage there they're all
they all meet at that point that i said
earlier where
political culture and popular culture
meet and so you're you're telling the
life and you're telling the meaning of
the life and to me that contextualizes
it and brings it involved with uh with
the issues that political historians
maybe or cultural historians are
interested in
i think you have to be passionate about
your subject it's very hard to do you
don't have to love them
all the time you have to be passionate
about what they went through because
it's you're spending a lot of time with
that person or persons and the only
other thing i would say in terms of
documentary work that i've done
i think it's always to me about what i
call heavy lifting or double duty that
there has to be
something they made i'm guessing it's
the sir
i didn't read your book i wish i had
done i will do the searchers or the
green berets or in my case with sammy
davis um i got to be me or when we did
ethel waters in the broadway documentary
her sing suppertime which is a song
about lynching written for broadway in
1933 that's almost unimaginable that you
find those you have to find
the moments where their lives either
represent or interact with something
that has a larger metaphorical value
otherwise you're just going and then he
made and then he wrote and then she did
so you have to find and it can be
utterly subjective that's i think that's
the fun part you get to decide that this
song is more important in sammy davis's
life than that song because it says more
to me me personally in 2017 or whatever
than something else
as if as if history isn't subjective
right
it's all subjective
john anything um i agree
with
all my fellow panelists um you have to
have a larger point you want to make and
there has to be some reason why you want
to write this story
and in that sense
every account is selective
you don't you can't throw in absolutely
everything you know and just sort of a
nondescript hodgepodge
and i think it's the reason that you can
have more than one interesting biography
about the same person
people come with different interests
they come with a different
basic point they want to make and uh um
sort of pull together the evidence that
that uh moves that story along
an earlier book that i'd written was on
jack johnson who was the first black
heavyweight champion in america he won
the title in 1908
and i had a larger point that i was
interested in i was interested in his
life but he's the heavyweight champion
during
the progressive era okay well
this is a progressive error was the era
where the the highest lynchings in
america it was race-baiting in the south
it was
vardaman and bilbo and the other race of
southern governors and so
a larger question i'm asking is
was there progressivism for for black
americans you know what was it what was
life like for a black american during
this progressive era so you're
connecting with a historiographical
question at the time
and i think things change cyclically i
mean one of the things that made sammy
very attractive to us
is is what the subtitle the documentary
is i've got to be me
and here's a man who was black and
famously archie bunker says on all in
the family i know you were born in
college you couldn't help that but why'd
you decide to turn jew right and he
chose to be jewish and and he made his
own identity politics and identity
politics now strikes me among my
students at nyu certainly the two or
three most vibrant passionate topics you
can come up with so that's bubbling up
here in 2019 and makes it a great lens
through which to see somebody from
another time in another place just the
way it's interesting 50 years ago
tonight
tonight the great white hope won the
tony award for best play which is about
jack
yeah for best play so so i mean again 50
years ago that story was interesting to
people at the end of the civil rights
movement about jack johnson and now post
ollie posts all sorts of other people
it's interesting in a different way yeah
and i think too to answer your question
is to try to measure the impact of the
subject and to try to build an argument
around that
with my stars for freedom book i was
i found out pretty easily how much
people
raised money you know or how many
benefits they did
but then trying to figure out well
how did that help the civil rights
movement what exactly did they bring to
it and tried to build an argument about
that overall impact and then again sort
of context how they brought it to
hollywood and helped change the
culture of hollywood which when they
started
allowed black actors and that's the only
way they employed african americans and
so these stars for freedom
went back to hollywood and started
pushing and hiring on their own becoming
producers or directors themselves and
saying we're gonna hire african
americans behind the scenes so that was
a way for me to kind of think about that
it is hard though constructing a
narrative and an argument at the same
time
any other questions yeah there's one
back here
have you ever done a biography of a
scientist or another intellectual figure
i have not no
no
the kind of stuff the kind of writing
you're describing
i
you know i've i've read biographies of
scientists well yeah
celebrity most of what we've dealt with
i i think all four of us were dealing
with with celebrities with with high
profile individuals now there are
celebrity scientists too but i don't i
think the questions that you would ask
you're explaining number one you're
trying to explain what they did you're
you're focusing on them you're
interested in the individual you know
who were they what made them tick what
did they do that's important how would
and if if it's if they are important how
were they perceived uh
was the movie the
beautiful mind that was that was out
which is you know kind of a narrative of
a of a mathematician of a scientist um
and and it was a utterly compelling film
and it was a compelling book too i think
it won all sorts of awards so we're
you're asking we ask i think the same
questions
right here
and just ask you about process
the process of developing the argument
and
constructing the narrative which comes
first usually
of course you have these these wonderful
stories you have the anecdotes you have
the um the things that you want to put
in the book
um
does the um
the story kind of
and the argument come after
you you
sort of put in the make the major points
that you wanted to
to make and then
then you're then
then you start to work on the
uh how it all fits together
uh
well i think i mean i just tell you from
my point of view it's an inquiry when i
was
seven or eight i saw sammy davis jr on
ronan martin's laughing and he was this
sort of goofy gesture he jester he did
all these silly goofy things um and then
two years later i went to the public
library and i looked in the original
cast album section and there was a
record called golden boy and here was a
musical about the civil rights movement
which had never existed in the 1960s
that was done in 1964 and here was the
same sami davis junior singing about
being a black man in love with a white
woman in america in the 60s and here was
the alpha and here was the omega and
from
you know before i was even 11 i was like
how can that be the same person
how can that be the same person and i
would say that was a question i was
always in the back of my my mind for
four or five decades until i had a
chance to work on this documentary how
do you reconcile that that that person's
life and i think you're always
trying to grapple with you got to find a
good question in that person's life that
seems to me
unreconciled right i don't think that
i don't know some bob cummings from the
bob cummings show in the 50s would be a
compelling documentary subject but
jackie gleason's a compelling subject
how could this lovable guy be such a
monster to all the people he ever worked
with or whatever you have to find
something you want to wrestle with
and and then that i think it flows
naturally out of that i think you know i
begin with kind of immersion you know
you just have to immerse yourself in
their life um
robert cairo when he started to do his
multi-volume biography of lyndon johnson
he went down to austin to work to do
research and he worked he would work for
five and a half days because it was
closed sunday and it was only open the
archives the johnson archives for only
open on a half day on saturday and every
day
after he worked he would go to the hill
country which was not that far from
austin and interviewed somebody that
knew johnson from that area and on
sundays and saturdays he would interview
maybe he'd interview two people but he
realized you know
i don't i don't understand these people
i i just don't get them i mean he's
going to the hill country which was
extraordinarily poor in the 1930s when
johnson was brought up earlier in the
century
um
and
and he was from new york city cairo is
from new york city so he just said to
his wife
you know
we've got to move to the hill country
i've got to live in that land i've got
to i've got to understand these people
i'll never understand johnson unless i
understand the people and his wife who's
a french historian said can't you write
a biography on on uh robert moses on
napoleon we could go and immerse
ourselves in paris but no i mean he he
so he went until he felt he read all the
other biographies in johnson he said
nobody understands you know what made
him what makes him tick
and it was going to the hill country
living in the hill country suddenly he
was living there and people would talk
to him they would tell them things they
wouldn't tell him before when he was
just sort of a fly by new yorker
dropping in and asking questions and so
i think
i and and you started always immersing
yourself with uh
with sammy davis junior young and you
know i i was interested in boxers when i
was young i mean there's a there's a
kind of a person i don't know there's a
personal interest that factors into this
i i just add i think you need to start
with some big compelling reason that you
want to do this some big compelling
question that you want to answer but
after that
it all evolves
it all evolves together
i think an interesting exercise if you
could ever get authors to show it to you
would be their first proposal for any
book
because it never looks anything like the
final book
and you know that's a good thing your
your your ideas change as you get into
the sources but but it starts with a
central question and then beyond that it
just sort of all develops together
well i think our time is up so thank you
for the excellent questions and thank
you to the panelists
yeah and um
sammy davis jr is playing at 3 30 down
the hallway if you want to come see that
[Applause]
tonight at 8 pm